IF YOU'RE. A GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
CALLING THE HEARING OF THE.
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER AS A SUB COMMITTEE WERE
GOING TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE DO NOT AS OF YET HAVE
A QUORUM.
THE SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL AND I DO WE NOTICE THERE'S
POTENTIAL FOR A QUORUM.
ARE WE HAVE THIRTY SEVEN BILLS
ON FILE TODAY THREE ARMED
CONSENT FOR HAVE BEEN PULLED THE
CONSENT ITEMS ARE. AS FOLLOWS I
NEVER TWENTY NINE AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY ONE BY MISTER ALL
MY DON'T OVER THIRTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE ZERO FIVE EIGHT BY ME.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE BY
MISTER KILEY OF THE CONSENT
ITEMS THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
PULLED R. A. B.. I'M SORRY ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE MINISTER SANTIAGO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY THREE OF US
REYES.
I AND NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO AYE MR
GIPSON ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE.
AB THIRTY TO SIXTY MINISTER
KILEY THAT LEAVES
THIRTY BILLS TO BE HEARD THAT'S
A LOT OF BILLS.
ARM.
WE WILL TAKE TESTIMONY AND LET
ME THEY MAKE THIS CLEAR TO
EVERYONE WE WILL TAKE TESTIMONY
FROM TWO WITNESSES SUPPORT AND
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ONLY.
AND THE SERB.
JUST OF A PRIOR ARRANGEMENT.
IN THIS TO EACH MEASURE EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TO MINUTES THE
COME UP NEARLY ALL OF TWO
MINUTES.
WE ARE THE TWO WITNESSES WELL
ALL OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ARE WELCOME TO COME
THE MICROPHONE AND ONLY DO THIS.
ONLY GIVE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL IS ANY MORE CONVERSATION
YOU WILL BE CUT OFF.
THAT AS THEY THE THE THE TWO
WITNESSES THEY'RE COMING FORTH
WITH THE TWO MINUTES ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO GIVE THE
D.. TAIL DISCUSSION AGAIN EVER
COMING UP TO THE MIKE AFTERWARDS
LINING UP.
YOU ONLY SAY WHETHER OR NOT YOU
ARE IN SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF
THAT.
I WHATEVER RATHER FOR OUR FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS AND THAT IS MR
MEDINA.
AND THAT IS.
.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX.
I DON'T A VIOLIN NUMBER ONE AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY MR
MEDINA YOU MAY.
.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
NO.
IMPETUS BEGINNING.
A.
FROM A.
VERY.
.
A.
NOTORIOUS CASE IN IN MY DISTRICT
THE TURBAN CASE THAT HAPPENED IN
THE CITY. OF PARIS THAT I
REPRESENT.
I I WON A STATE FOR THE RECORD
THAT I HAVE BEEN A.
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS.
.
SOMEONE WHO VALUES EDUCATION AND
ALL THE CHOICES THAT THERE ARE
IN EDUCATION.
SOMEONE WHO REALIZES THAT NOT
ONE SIZE FITS ALL WHEN IT COMES
TO EDUCATION SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES.
THAT THAT PARENTS AND STUDENTS
SHOULD HAVE A CHOICE.
AND HOW THEY EDUCATE THEIR
CHILDREN.
I MYSELF WAS EDUCATED IN PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ATTENDING.
PAROCHIAL CATHOLIC SCHOOLS FOR.
NINE YEARS.
SO I THINK THAT MEANS THAT MY
PARENTS WERE WILLING TO.
SACRIFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THEIR FOUR CHILDREN HAD THE KIND
OF SCHOOLING THAT THEY WANTED.
SO AS I PRESENT TODAY I WANNA BE
CLEAR. THAT I VALUE HOME
SCHOOLING THAT I DO NOT SEE THIS
BILL AND ANYWAY. AS AN ATTACK ON
HOME SCHOOLING I'VE ENJOYED THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES A JAMES GALLAGHER WHO
HIMSELF. A HOME SCHOOLED HIS.
CHILDREN.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED.
.
AFTER THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
AND I I I THINK IT'S A A BETTER
BILL NOW.
THAN IT WAS BEFORE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH MISTER
GALLAGHER.
SO TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX.
IN CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOLS ARE
CLASSIFIED UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
PRIVATE SCHOOLS
AND THERE IS LITTLE INFORMATION
KNOWN ABOUT HOMES SCHOOLS.
AND THE TYPE OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ALL PRIVATE SCHOOLS INCLUDING
HOME SCHOOLS.
FILED THE PRIVATE SCHOOL OUT
AFFIDAVIT ANNUALLY TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
A PRIVATE SCHOOL AFFIDAVIT IS A
REGISTRATION DOCUMENT.
REQUIRED TO BE FILLED ANNUALLY.
BY OPERATORS OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
OR HOME SCHOOL. TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS NO VIOLATION. OF THE
TRUANCY LA.
INFORMATION COLLECTED ON THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL AFFIDAVIT.
IS GEARED TOWARD AN INSTITUTION.
AND AS A RESULT. WE HAVE VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION.
ON THE NATURE OR THE TYPES OF
PRIVATE SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND THE NUMBERS ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM.
OUTSIDE OF MAKING ASSUMPTIONS.
BASED ON ENROLLMENT NUMBERS
WE DO NOT HAVE THE DEFINITIVE
WAY. TO KNOW THAT WHAT THE
NUMBERS ARE.
ASSOCIATED WITH DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PROGRAMS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX.
CLARIFIES THE DEFINITION.
A PRIVATE SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
HELPS TO DIS AGGREGATE
INFORMATION
COLLECTED ON THE PRIVATE SCHOOL
AFFIDAVIT.
BY ADDING A FIELD.
ON THE AFFIDAVIT THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE FILER.
SELF SELECT.
THE NATURE OF THE PRIVATE SCHOOL
FROM A LIST OF OPTIONS.
AND I THINK I YOU ALL.
WILL HAVE A A COPY OF THAT
AFFIDAVIT.
THIS INFORMATION WOULD THEN BE
ADDED TO THE DIRECTORY A PRIVATE
SCHOOL.
SIX OR MORE STUDENTS THAT IS
ALREADY LISTED PUBLICLY.
ON THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
WEBSITE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAS BEEN
CONFUSION.
ON WHETHER THE BILL.
WE'LL IMPACT THE PRIVACY OF
SCHOOLS.
FIVE OR FEWER CHILDREN ENROLL.
IT IS NOT THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL.
TO INCLUDE INFORMATION OF THOSE
SCHOOLS PUBLICLY.
TO MAKE THIS EXPLICITLY CLEAR.
I HAVE REQUESTED AMENDMENTS FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
THESE AMENDMENTS INSURER.
THAT ANY SCHOOL
FIVE OR FEWER STUDENTS
WILL ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE PUBLIC
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WEBSITE.
I BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT.
PRINT EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS.
TO MEET THE UNIQUE IS THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF EACH CHILD.
ALSO BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE MORE INFORMATION.
ON THE TYPE OF PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE.
SO THAT WE AS A STATE CAN BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS DR
RON REYNOLDS.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE SCHOOLS ORGANIZATION.
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF TWENTY
FOUR PRIVATE SCHOOLS SERVICE
AGENCIES.
AND ADMINISTRATIVE UNITS
THAT SERVE APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
ENROLLING ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN GRADES K. THROUGH TWELVE.
I'M ALSO JOINED BY JEFF BACA.
CHIEF GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
OFFICER FOR THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
BUT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON.
RON REYNOLDS CAP SO.
WE ARE APPROACHING THE ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
LANDMARK U. S. SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN PIERCE VERSUS
SOCIETY OF SISTERS.
THE DECISION THAT FIRMLY
ESTABLISHES THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT OF PARENTS
TO DIRECT THE EDUCATION OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
IN ITS UNANIMOUS RULING THE
COURT DECLARED.
THE FUNDAMENTAL THEORY OF
LIBERTY UPON WHICH ALL
GOVERNMENTS OF THIS UNION REST.
EXCLUDES ANY GENERAL POWER OF
THE STATE.
STANDARDIZE ITS CHILDREN BY
FORCING THEM TO ACCEPT
INSTRUCTION FROM PUBLIC TEACHERS
ONLY.
CHILD IS NOT THE MERE CREATURE
OF THE STATE.
THOSE TO NURTURE HIM AND DIRECT
HIS DESTINY HAVE THE RIGHT
COUPLED WITH THE HIGH DUTY. TO
RECOGNIZE AND PREPARE HIM FOR
ADDITIONAL OBLIGATIONS.
HOWEVER.
THE RULING.
CONTAINED ON ADDITIONAL FINDING
THAT IS NO LESS SIGNIFICANT AND
I QUOTE.
NO QUESTION IS RAISED
CONCERNING THE POWER OF THE
STATE.
REASONABLY TO REGULATE ALL
SCHOOLS
TO INSPECT.
SUPERVISE AND EXAMINE THEM THEIR
TEACHERS AND PUPILS.
TO REQUIRE THAT ALL CHILDREN OF
PROPER AGE ATTEND SOME SCHOOL.
THAT TEACHERS BE OF GOOD MORAL
CHARACTER AND PATRIOTIC
DISPOSITION THAT CERTAIN STUDIES
PLAINLY ESSENTIAL TO GOOD
CITIZENSHIP MUST BE TAUGHT. AND
THAT NOTHING BE TAUGHT WHICH IS
MANIFESTLY INIMICAL.
THE PUBLIC WELFARE.
ONE CANNOT UPHOLD ONE TENET
WHILE IGNORING OR REJECTING THE
OTHER.
BOTH PARENTS AND THE STATE
POSSESS RIGHTS
THAT MUST BE BALANCED
THROUGH COOPERATIVE EFFORTS.
SEE THAT REGULATION IS
REASONABLE.
I CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT SUCH A
BALANCE HAS LONG BEEN MAINTAINED
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I BELIEVE
THAT AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
THE BILL BEFORE YOU IS NOTHING
IF NOT REASONABLE.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE PRIVATE.
THEY'RE NOT SECRET.
WE ARE HAPPY TO DISCLOSE OUR
ESSENTIAL NATURE TO THE PUBLIC.
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMEMBERS
AND STAFF.
JEFF BACA WITH THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
REPRESENTING.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS DR JUDY WHITE.
THIS IS NOT NORMALLY AN ISSUE
THAT WE WOULD ENGAGE AND. AS I'M
SURE YOU'RE ALL AWARE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION DO NOT HAVE
STATUTORY ROLE IN EITHER THE
ESTABLISHMENT OR THE OVERSIGHT
OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
OUR INVOLVEMENT IN ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE ISSUE REAP RESULTED
FROM THE.
TURPIN CASE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA REFERENCED.
AND VERY QUICKLY WE.
HEARD FROM A LOT OF OUR
PARTNERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THIS MORNING TO FIND OUT WHAT
WERE THAT RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
RESPECT TO OVERSIGHT OF HOME
SCHOOLS THAT WERE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. WAS THERE ANYTHING THAT
COULD BE DONE TO PREVENT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS FROM
HAPPENING.
WE'VE CONTINUED TO PLAY A ROLE
AS THE MONTHS HAVE INTERCEDED IN
WORKING WITH HE COURT APPOINTED
ATTORNEYS FOR THE CHILDREN. AS
WELL AS THE COURT APPOINTED
PUBLIC GUARDIAN IN ORDER TO.
IDENTIFY OPTIONS FOR A SOUND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM FOR THESE
CHILDREN MANY OF WHOM ARE NOW
ADULTS SO IT HAS PROVEN TO BE A
BIT OF A CHALLENGE.
WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE REQUIRED TO DO THAT
BY STATUTE. WE'VE DONE THAT
BECAUSE WE FELT IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IN WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AS WE TALKS TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ANSWER THE
INQUIRIES THAT WE ARE GETTING
FROM. OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ABOUT
THE ROLLS OF DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
AVE BECAME CLEAR TO US THAT
THERE ARE SOME GAPS IN THE
INFORMATION THAT IS AVAILABLE.
AND IN SOME INSTANCES YOU HAVE
THE UNFORTUNATE CASE WHERE. A
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE REVIEW THE
PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE REVIEW WONDER STATUTE
DOES PLAY A VERY SMALL ROLE WITH
RESPECT TO VERIFYING THE
EXISTENCE OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT DID NOT KNOW
WHAT THE EXISTENCE OF CERTAIN
HOME PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
SO WHILE IT'S CERTAINLY NOT OUR
INTENT TO INFRINGE ON THE RIGHTS
OF PARENTS TO EDUCATE THERE'S
CHILDREN AND I SETTING THAT THEY
BELIEVE IS MOST PROPER FOR THEM.
THE RIGHT AND HIGH DUTY THAT THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER MENTIONED.
WE DO SEE AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX AS A MODEST ATTEMPT.
TO PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION THAN
IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
WITH THIS IF YOU COULD SUMMARIZE
PERHAPS WORRY WITH THIS HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN THE TURBAN
CASE I DON'T THINK ANY OF US CAN
ANSWER THAT.
BUT WE AS I PREVIOUSLY STATED WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND WE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SO TO ED IS OPPOSITION TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH WITNESS.
YOU DID NOT ASK FOR OTHER
WITNESSES AND AND I I YOU KNOW I
YOU'RE RIGHT I'M. I'M NOT WILL
PRACTICE TODAY.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
USE A GOOD SKATER SIT DOWN.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IT'S GOOD TO THE OPPOSITION
HOUSE ONE OF TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES.
EACH THANK YOU.
IS IS MICHAEL I'VE YES UP WHEN A
MISSILE THEY SINGLETON I'M HOME
SCHOOLING PARENTS SPEAKING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOL
NETWORK.
FIRST
WE OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX
FOR PRIVACY REASONS.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
WORKED HARD TO KEEP.
THE NAMES AND ADDRESSES OF
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN PRIVATE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DOES
NOT NOW PUBLISHED DIRECTORY
INFORMATION ON PRIVATE SCHOOLS
WITH FIVE OR FEWER CHILDREN
WHICH ARE PRESUMED TO BE HOME
SCHOOLS.
IF AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX PASSES
AS WRITTEN SCHOOL SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIED AS HOME SCHOOLS WILL
BE POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
IT.
EXCUSE ME EDUCATION WEBSITE.
THE INFORMATION WILL INCLUDE THE
FAMILIES.
ADDRESS AND THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN IN EACH GRADE.
THIS IS A.
.
PRIVACY AND SAFETY ISSUE.
SECOND.
WE OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX.
BECAUSE IT MANDATES ADDITIONAL
DATA COLLECTION FROM
HOMESCHOOLING FAMILIES.
THAT ARE INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE FROM THE DATA.
THIS DATA IS NOT NEEDED TO
ADMINISTER ANY EXISTING LAW OR
SOLVE AN EXISTING PROBLEM IT IS
NOT APPROPRIATE TO BASE A
POLICY.
ON ALARM ISM AND HEADLINES.
DECADES OF STUDIES
SHOW THAT HOMESCHOOLERS ARE
THRIVING PARTICULARLY IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN ESTABLISHING
ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF EDUCATION.
HISTORY SHOWS THE DATA
COLLECTION.
NATIONWIDE HAS AND WILL BECOME A
PRETEXT FOR HARASSMENT OF
HOMESCHOOLING FAMILIES.
AND A PRELUDE TO REGULATION THE
SOLE FUNCTION OF WHICH IS TO
ELIMINATE FLEXIBILITY FROM
EDUCATION.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THIS CHANCE TO
SHARE OUR VIEWS AND I HOPE
YOU'LL REACH OUT TO ITS IF YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THE HERE NEXT WITNESS.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS NATHAN PIERCE PRIVATE HOME
EDUCATORS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE ALL HEARD OF THE ALLEGED
ABUSE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
ARE APPALLED.
.
SOME HAVE TAKEN THE POSITION
THAT WHAT HAPPENED THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE REMEDIED BY FOR
THE LEGISLATION OF HOME BASED
PRIVATE EDUCATION CALIFORNIA.
HELLO HOWEVER MY COLLEAGUES AND
I WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY IF
THERE WAS NOT MORE TO THE STORY.
I'M HERE WITH SOLVING SINGLETON
OF.
CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL NETWORK
ALSO WITH DEBBIE SCHWARZER.
HOME SCHOOL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND AMEND EVER OF CHRISTIAN HOME
EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WITH DARREN JONES
OF HOME SCHOOL LEGAL DEFENSE
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE ALL HERE TODAY WITH ONE
VOICE TO ASK YOU TO CONSIDER A
FEW POINTS.
AND TO NOT PASS AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX.
INITIAL STATED INTENT OF THIS
BILL WAS TO ADDRESS SAFETY
CONCERNS FOR HOME SCHOOLED
STUDENTS.
PROM AND RECENT STUDY COMPARING
THE FREQUENCY OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT TO PRIVATELY HOME SCHOOL
CHILDREN IN LOW MEDIUM AND HIGH
REGULATION STATES FOUND THAT THE
FREQUENCY WAS THE SAME IN EACH
CATEGORY. SHOWING CLEARLY THAT
MORE REGULATION WILL NOT IMPACT
THE FREQUENCY OF THE VIEWS OR
NEGLECTING CALIFORNIA.
THE TRAGIC CASE OF THE TURBINE
FAMILY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY FROM
WHICH SO MUCH INTEREST AND
CONCERN PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLING
HAS BEEN STIRRED UP DOESN'T
REFLECT THE HOMESCHOOLING
COMMUNITY.
ACCORDING TO THE STATISTICS THIS
TYPE OF ABUSE ISN'T PREVENTED BY
INCREASED REGULATIONS AND IT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN PREVENTED BY
THE TYPE OF DATA COLLECTED BY
THIS BILL.
THE CLAIM THAT THE ATA GATHERED
WILL BE HELPFUL.
TO.
SCHOOL OFFICIALS WILL NOT
ACTUALLY BE REALIZED IN A REAL
SENSE AS TODAY. ARM CURRENTLY
THE TRUANCY OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA DO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
DATA RELATING TO THE PRIVATE
SCHOOL AFFIDAVITS FOR THOSE
SCHOOLS. ALL SCHOOLS INCLUDING
THOSE WITH FIVE OR FEWER
STUDENTS.
AB TWENTY FIVE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX IS
UNNECESSARY.
I MAKE THIS BRIEF FILED BY THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL JERRY SURE HE
COULD SUMMARIZE.
SIR.
SHOULD NOT SET POLICY OUT OF
SENSATIONALISM I WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
.
WITHOUT ANOTHER SOME THAT DID
NOT MAKE IT THE ROOM'S THESE A
LARGE LINE OUT THERE WHO WANTED
TO SUPPORT.
I THIS I'M GONNA GO BACK THE
SPORT THEN I'M GONNA GO TO OTHER
OPPOSITION SO YOU JUST PLEASE
COME A MICROPHONE AND IF THERE'S
ANY OTHERS IF THEY COULD COME
THROUGH. IN SUPPORT. ONLY RIGHT
NOW.
VERY BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIR I'M
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA SPILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
INSIDE OR OUTSIDE.
WE WILL.
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION.
MAY COME TO THE MICROPHONE STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY THIS
COMMITTEE DID YOU WHAT I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS DID YOU WANT TO DID
YOU WANT TO DISCUSS THOSE RIGHT
NOW ARE NO.
IF YOU WANT TO CLARIFY THOUGH SO
PEOPLE ON IT HERE TONIGHT TODAY.
YEAH WOULD ALLOW. SO YOU MIGHT
WANT TO LISTEN TO WHAT MISTER
BRADY'S GOING TO SAY RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT WHEN WE
SEE A MAN THAT MEANS HE IS GOING
TO CHANGE THE BILL TAKE
SOMETHING OUT TYPICALLY.
WELL AMENDMENTS OF READY BEEN
GIVEN.
TO REDWOOD JUDICIAL.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
TO MAKE IT.
EXPLICITLY CLEAR.
A THAT THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
INSURE.
THAT ANY SCHOOL WITH FIVE OR
FEWER STUDENTS
WOULD ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BE MADE PUBLIC.
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WEBSITE.
AND AND THAT IS AMENDMENT TO
CLARIFY THE INTENT AND WHAT THE
BILL DOES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST SAW
THERE WERE SOME OTHER
INDIVIDUALS AYE HIM.
WHO CAME IN LATER OF MISTER
CALDERON IT?
HAS PULLED AB TWENTY FIVE SEP
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY TWO HAS BEEN
PULL THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN WERE NOW GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
ONLY PLEASE. LIKE DARREN JONES
ATTORNEY WITH HOME SCHOOL LEGAL
DEFENSE ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ANY BOTH CHAIRMAN OF SACRAMENTO
CHRISTIAN ORGANIZATION A PARENT
EDUCATORS WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANDREW VANDIVER FROM THE
CHRISTIAN HOME EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO THE SELAH A SUPPORT GROUP
FROM SILICON VALLEY AND FROM.
ASSEMBLYMAN COLOR COLORS
DISTRICT AND.
WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
CHRISTOPHER SAID NOW OUR HOME
SCHOOL GRADUATE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
WESTERN POTTER HOMESCHOOL
GRADUATE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JESSICA CALLED LIAM A PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AMBER HEALY I SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES OF SUBTLE BUT
CHRISTIAN ACADEMY WHICH IS A P.
S. P. IN ORANGE COUNTY AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
BEVERLY WALL TO BAKE WITH PARK
ACADEMY HOME SCHOOL GROUP IN
TEMPLE CITY CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE
THE BILL.
EVELYN CHAVEZ GARCIA I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER AND ALSO
WITH FROM FOUNDATION CRISTIAN
ACADEMY.
OF GLENDORA CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PAUL TAM AND I
REPRESENT THE GATES CHRISTIAN
HOME SCHOOL FROM VICTORVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DARLA TAM AND I ALSO
REPRESENT THE GATE CHRISTIAN
SCHOOL. IN VICTORVILLE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE BRACERO
REPRESENT A REVIVAL CHRISTIAN
ACADEMY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
MENIFEE AND WE.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TANYA SALINAS SOLELY CHEN
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL RIVERSIDE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DIANNE PADGETT CHRISTIAN HOME
EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
TATIANA DORIA'S.
HOMESCHOOL MOTHER OF SIX FROM
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED SPELL. GREAT THANK YOU
YOU HAVE TWO LINES YOU CAN LIGHT
UP RIGHT BE ON THE OTHER PERSON.
THANK YOU PLEASE CONTINUE KAYLA
DARIUS HOME SCHOOL STUDENT OF
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HANNAH WILLIAMS UP PRIVATE HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TAYLOR JOBA HOME STILL STUDENT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL VICTORIA GREEN
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
TAMMY GREEN AND HOME SCHOOL MOM
OF THREE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
LISA DROVE OFF RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA IN A HOME SCHOOL
MOMENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FRANCE TO GLAZE PRIVATE HOME
SCHOOLER LA MIRADA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AMANDA KLEISS
CLASSICAL CONVERSATIONS
SUPPORTING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
ON FISCAL.
AND.
BOB WAS.
BILL.
ANGELA LAST HOME SCHOOL PARENT
REPRESENTING FOUNDATION
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL FROM LONG RUN
TO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
KILL BLUSH FROM FOUNDATION
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
JESSE POCKET FROM FOUNDATION
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. JORDAN LASH
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE FROM
FOUNDATION CHRISTIAN SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. NANCY PACKET
FOUNDATION CHRISTIAN SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AT HOME SCHOOL MOM
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
JENNIFER MENDOZA FOUNDATION
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL I'M ALSO OPPOSE
A SPELL.
NATHAN MENDEZ I AM A I I AM A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
VALLEY ESPINOZA HOMESCHOOL
GRADUATE IN A STRONGLY OPPOSES.
MICHELLE ESPINOZA HOME SCHOOL
MOTHER FIVE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MICHAEL
ESPINOZA HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM JULIA CAMP AND I'M FROM THE
GATE QUESTIONS GOING TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S JENNIFER OBVIOUS I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL MOM FROM
SENATOR DOLE AND I PUT THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JAMIE SOME MODELING
AND WITH THE CHRISTIAN MILITARY
HOMESCHOOLERS OF SAN DIEGO AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOHN GALLON HOME
SCHOOL PARENT ALSO REPRESENTING
GRAYSON GLORY ACADEMY FROM
CORONA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KILL MY GALLON HOME SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOSH FROM A GALLON.
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND AYE
OPPOSED BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ONE
DOLLAR TREES I REPRESENT RIGHT
WHAT THE COMMUNITY OF RIGHT WOOD
AND WE OPPOSE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX.
MY NAME IS JULIE MCGOWAN I'M A
FORMER HOME SCHOOL AS WELL AS
HOLES MOSTLY MY CHILDREN NOW AND
I'M FROM CHRONIC CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KILEY MEAN IS CLARA. AND.
THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BARBARIC. OUR HONESTY.
AMBASSADOR AND THE STATUS HOME
SCHOOL SUPPLY. IN CHINO AND.
AFTER THE FIVE HUNDRED OPPOSES
THIS BILL.
IT.
INLET.
HOME SCHOOL PARENTS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
APRIL DELA CRUZ I AM A
REPRESENTATIVE.
FROM THE CITY OF CHINO OF
CALVARY CHAPEL OF CHINO HILLS
AND OUR TEN THOUSAND
CONSTITUENTS OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SANDRA UP I AM A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM JUST LEFT AND I'M A PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOLER STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CECILIA CHAFIN REPRESENTING
SEATS CHRISTIAN FAMILY SCHOOLS
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
SANDY CORROSION PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA PARENTS INVOLVED IN
EDUCATION AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
BETH'S ONE ALSO A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA PARENTS VOTED
EDUCATION AND A HOMESCHOOLING
MOM AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR
PRESIDENT HEALTH. ITEMS ESTO
MORALIS I AM A HOME SCHOOLER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LUCAS WELLS I'M I'M
SCORE AND I POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULY WELLS I'M HOME
SCHOOLER AND AYE OPPOSED TO
SPELL MY NAME IS DIEGO FOR US I
AM A HOMESCHOOLING I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MELINDA WELLS AND I'M
A PARENT HOMESCHOOLERS. AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BUT AIMS LOOK MCCREIGHT I'M
PRIVATELY HOMESCHOOLED AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MILLION IT CRAMPED
HAVE HOME SCHOOLING AND I ALSO
WAS THIS.
MY NAME IS IF I'M CREATE.
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER AND I'VE
OPPOSES BILLS.
I'M LOW LIMON CRAM PRIVATES
HOMESCHOOLERS STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A BONTA MCRAE AND I'M
A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENTS
AND I POSE A SPELL. AS AMENDED
MY NAME IS SAYING INVENTIVE IN
I'M A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY VANDER VEEN I
AM A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I OPPOSE BILL AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX.
I'M JOSH BENDER VIENEN I'M A
PRIVATELY HOMESCHOOLED STUDENTS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ELIANA DUGGAR I AM A
HOME SCHOOL PRIVATE STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS BREANNA VANDER VEEN
I'M A PRIVATE HOME EDUCATOR AND
I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS MOLLY DUGGAR AND I AM
A PRIVATE SCHOOL STUDENT.
LA POLICE TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY DAGGER I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND HOME
SCHOOLED OTHER OF SIX THAT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MIA DUGGAR AND.
I AM.
A. HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND THAT
PUTS A SPELL.
MY NAME IS MARK DUGGAR.
I AM A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CARRIE OF LAVENHAM
FROM SUNNYVALE CALIFORNIA I'M A
FORMER HOMESCHOOLERS OF TO
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GERRY SALINAS I AM A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SAN AND FRIEDMAN I'M A HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ELI FRIEDMAN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ANGELA WARNER I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENT AND
AYE OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS HARRISON WARNER I AM
HOMESCHOOLED. I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE BURKE CHEN
AYE PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAMES ABBEY MEYERS I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER AND. POSE THIS BILL.
I RENEE MEYER APPARENT AND I
OPPOSES.
IN CASE MY. AND I AM A HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I PURCHASED.
I AM SCARED INCLINED I AM HOME
SCHOOL SOON AND POST THIS BILL.
I'M KATHLEEN DAN QUINN FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING PARENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONGLY EVEN
AS AMENDED. BY MICHELLE DAN
CRYING I'M A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I CAN REALLY DAN KLEIN I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GONNA ANDERSON I'M
HERE WITH PARENTS UNITED FOR
KIDS. I'M A FORMER HOME SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE GRADUATE WAS SUMA
* LAUDE HONORS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE FETZER AND
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER OF THREE
CHILDREN AND THE CO FOUNDER OF
PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS. A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING PARENTS'
RIGHTS I DO REPRESENT YOUR
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THINK YOUR NAME EVALUATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY'S DONE SO WELL. IS
PLEASE KEEP IT ON WE WANT TO
HEAR WE WANNA HEAR YOUR OPINION
WE DO AS A THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
MY NAME SHAUNA LAMBERT I AM A
MOM AND WITH PARENTS NAY FOR
KIDS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE MAKESHIFT
MEN I REPRESENT OVER FIVE FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED FAMILIES WITH THE
HOMESCHOOL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THREE HUNDRED
FAMILIES FROM RAN HOME SCHOOLERS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY TROST I AM A
SECOND GENERATION HOMESCHOOL
HOMESCHOOLERS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M FROM
RIPPING CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS RILEY TRUST I'M FROM
RIPPING CALIFORNIA AND I PUT A
SPELL.
HI MY NAME SU ZI BORN I'M A
VETERAN HOME SCHOOL MOTHER FOR
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL RIPPING
CALIFORNIA. I AM TODAY BORN
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF THREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M TYLER BORN FOR RIPPING
CALIFORNIA A SECOND GENERATION
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M ELIZABETH SHILLING FOR
RIPPING CALIFORNIA I'M A HOME
SCHOOL MOTHER FOR AND I AM WITH
CENTRAL VALLEY ADVOCATES FOR
PARENTAL RIGHTS AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
AND JASON SHOWING FOR WRITTEN
CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL FATHER
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M W. SHORES ARE FROM LOS ALTOS
CALIFORNIA WITH THE HOMESCHOOL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALL THAT ALSO THE GIFTED
HOMESCHOOLERS FORUM AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
PRETTY GREEN REPRESENTING
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE IN
SACRAMENTO AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS HILLY MACMILLAN FOR
MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
TWO BOYS THAT I HOME SCHOOL AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM BATTLING GONZALEZ FROM
MODESTO CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M LACY GONZALEZ FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
TAKE YOUR PROPERTY MODESTO
CALIFORNIA FORMERLY USD IN WHILE
THEIR FUTURE AND AYE OPPOSED TO
SPELL.
MY NAME IS LAURA CAREER I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S IRIS CHENEY FROM
MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA VAN HOW HARD
HERE FROM MODESTO AND I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF TWO BOYS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM SAWYER PART OF.
HOMESCHOOLING MODESTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THE RIVER THERE'S TWO MIKES UP
THERE SO I MIGHT SAY BEHIND EACH
MIGHT.
RACHEL WILLIAMS AND I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM FOR RIVERBANK
CALIFORNIA AND MY FAMILY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY MEMBERS OF SADDAM HERNANDEZ
FOR MOBILE CITY CALIFORNIA AND
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALLISON JASWANT.
I AM A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL JAMIE HESTON
REPRESENTING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
FAMILIES WITH BAY AREA GIFTED
HOMESCHOOLERS I'M ALSO HOME
SCHOOL PARENT I OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS LEASED OUT ONE A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MARIA PALATAL FAMILY LAW
ATTORNEY SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M AARON SWANSON FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA A MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER OF HOME SCHOOLED
KIDS NAY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OLIVIA MICROSOFT ROSE GOING HOME
SCHOOLING MOTHER NAY OPPOSE.
I MIGHT ANY SMARTER CALL THOUGH
AND I'M FROM VOLATILE CALIFORNIA
I'M AT HOME SCHOOLING MOTOR THE
FORMER UNIVERSITY INSTRUCTOR AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN HE WAS JOSHUA COLEMAN FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL WE THEORISTS.
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE MERCER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. I MY NAME
SHANNON STURGES OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF
THREE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS STACY NICHOLSON
I'M FROM TEMPLE CITY AND I
REPRESENT MY OWN POWER PRIVATE
STUDY WILDERNESS ROAD ACADEMY
AND. MY GROUP THAT ARE PART OF
CULTS FUNDAMENTALS IN MONROVIA
THANK YOU.
SO SORRY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NEIGHBORS DESIREE DONALD'S
AND I'M A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR FROM DUBLIN CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
BROWN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
EVEN AS AMENDED.
HI I'M SHERRY HANNEMANN FROM
MERCED AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AMERICAN MEN FROM MERCED AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
HOLLY GROZA CLASSICAL
CONVERSATIONS OF REDLANDS MAY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
THE WE HAVE TWO MICROPHONES SO
COMPLY BEHI BEHIND EACH
MICROPHONE PLEASE JUST WALK UP
EVERY WALK ON A.
HI MY NAME IS MIKE IT IN.
I AM A HOMESCHOOL SIERRA POSES
BILL.
JAMIE KAMALI ARE MY HOST SCHOOL
GRADUATE A HOMESCHOOL MOM OF
THREE AND I REPRESENT JOSH'S
BRINGS ACADEMY OF PS SKIING UP
ABOUT CALIFORNIA. AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KAREN RICHARDSON FROM
YUCCA VALLEY. I AM A PREVIOUS
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M LINDA SEE FUENTES FROM
CONCORD CALIFORNIA MIAMI HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM POLICY FIND THIS I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND HAD A NOSE AND I AM A
PRIVATE HOMES FULLER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM ALEY GARVIN AND PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS NINA MILLS I
PRIVATELY HOME SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M JUST A GUY MAN I'M A PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOL AND I OPPOSES.
I'M GRACIE PLANT IS IN A PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOLER AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL. I AM CLEAR MOUNDS NAME
PRIVATELY HOMESCHOOLED AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SANDRA KIM AND I AM A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ELLIOT CAM I'M
HOMESCHOOLED SOON AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M ALEX KIM A HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BRANDON CAM I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND I POSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN CAM I AM A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL HAS BEEN.
I STEPHANIE BURDEN AND I AM A
HOME SCHOOL TEACHER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I MARIN BURGER IN NUMBER THEM
SCHOOL STUDENT I POSE THIS BILL.
TECHNICAL GROUP STAFF PRIVATE
HOME TO CATER TO A THREE FROM
MOUNTAIN VIEW IN NAPLES
SPOKESMAN AND.
TO LEARN GIVES TAT I AND A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLERS STATED.
THAT.
HI MY NAME IS NAY ANY WELL MAIN
AND UP PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND SINCE HE GAVE STAFF AND THE
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
I OPPOSE THIS BETH. CAME ALLEN
GRAPES CAN.
I AM A PRIVATE PUBS COOLER AND I
PLEDGE TO SPEAK. AND CAN I HAVE
IRAQ AND I'M A PROGRAM OF SCHOOL
AND POSTED SPELL. AND THE TAIL
PARA I AM A PRIVATE HOME
SCHOOLER TO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM ELLEN CHEN HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT FROM SAN JOSE I
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I NUYS SUSAN TRAN I'M A PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR FROM SAN
JOSE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL MY NAME SUCH
ENTRANT.
ENNOBLE.
AND.
THEN.
MANY AM IS CARLA HERE WHERE I AM
A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENTS OF
FOR AN A AND AMEND OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JOHN THE ROMAN DRIVE
A HOST OF PROGRAMS COOLER AND
OPPOSES DO.
MY NAME IS CARLOS HARRIMAN.
HOMESCHOOL FATHER OF FOUR AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ONE OF AGREES TO LINE'S YOU CAN
LIVE BEHIND EITHER BROKE FROM MY
NAME IS KRISTEN CHEVROLET I'M A
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF FIVE.
THE OLDEST IS A GRADUATE FROM
COLLEGE IN COMPUTER SCIENCE.
THE SECOND GRADUATE AT THE TOP
OF HER CLASS IN NEUROSCIENCE.
AND NOW HAS WILL INJECT SO I
WILL HAVE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IMPOSITION OF THE BILL ONLY.
OKAY I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MINING SALAS WHO I'M A MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M FROM THAT
MEMBER CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
BUT ISN'T MICHAEL WHERE VOTE DI
MUBARAK WE EAST DEVOTEES
STROMBOLI DEFINITELY OPPOSES
BILL.
MY NAME IS PAUL ALONG AN FROM
CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND THE HOME
SCHOOL MOTHER AND I RUN A
TUTORING BUSINESS AND I CLICK
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KAREN SHELTON I BEEN
SENT HERE BY TO HOMEOWNERS
VENTURA COUNTY THE ASSOCIATED
CHRISTIAN HOME EDUCATORS OF
VENTURA. AND THE CHRISTIAN
ATTACK ADVOCATES SUPPORT
ASSOCIATION OF CAMERINO AND THE
HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES THAT ARE IN
THOSE GROUPS HAVE SENT ME HERE
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
ROOMS EVEN THOUGH. PURPOSELESS
BEAR.
I'M HOLLY LARSON FROM CAMBRIA
CALIFORNIA PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL
ARE ALSO PART OF THE CHIEF OF
VENTURA COUNTY AND CONSERVE
CAMEROON I OPPOSE THIS BILL
ISN'T IT.
AND CIRCULATION AND HAVE THAT
HOME SCHOOLING A CLOSE
DISPENSED.
PUBLIC HILL ARSON.
I'M A PRO HOMESCHOOLING AND I
FUNDS THEM. AND STEPHANIE
DEPARTAMENTO MISSION VIEJO I
REPRESENT COSTS WILL
CONVERSATIONS AROUND TO SANTA
MARGARITA AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED AND JOSHUA TO BORROW
AND PRIVATE SCHOOL HOME SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I KNOW THAN TO BAR ON THE
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENTS
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THEY MARRIED STAFF AND SAY.
YEAH SHE KNEW NAM BONNIE WERNER
AND THEN EL DORADO HILLS
CALIFORNIA. I OPPOSE AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX AM THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HANNAH
BURNER I'M FROM OLDER TO HOST
CALIFORNIA AND I AM FIRMLY
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU.
I'M SAM OVER MY THIS TIME FROM
REDONDO BEACH I'M A HOMESCHOOL
GRADUATE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EFREN SYLVIA I'M FROM
LAWNDALE I'M HOME SCHOOL
GRADUATE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LAUREN MAFRA MONTY FROM REDONDO
BEACH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME AS QUAINT RAFFERTY NINE
FROM LAKE OUT CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICOLE RAFFERTY IDEA
OF HOME SCHOOL FROM LAKE ERA
THIS.
ACTUAL DATA ANALYST WE ARE NOT
DATA ANOMALIES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
LISA CERVANTES BILLY ORANGE
COUNTY.
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER TWENTY YEARS
SINCE FOUR STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
NAME IS DIRTY BUT NO I AND I'M A
FORMER HOME SCHOOLER AND A
GRANDMOTHER LITTLE SCHOOLS TO.
AND I'M A MEMBER OF A LARGE
VOTING BLOCK OF SENIOR VOTERS
WHO STRONGLY OPPOSE A BLANK
CLEAR SEVEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CLEARLY LOPEZ I. M.
OF PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLERS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH LOPES AND I AM
FROM FOTOLIA CALIFORNIA NAY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BUT IT IS ONE THOUGH PASS FROM
MY SIDE CALIFORNIA I POSE THIS
BILL.
SEE LOPEZ FROM FACE VALUE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHERRY WALERAN
FROM BETHEL ISLAND I REPRESENT
HEARTHSTONE CHRISTIAN ACADEMY
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THINK YOU.
MY NAME IS SANDY ABELSON OF FROM
TURN LIKE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BELL AS AMENDED I'M
A HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF SIX
CHILDREN.
HI MY NAME IS SILLY OLSON AND
HOME SCHOOLED.
AND I'M THRILLED TO A CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM CARRYING DAVIS FROM MERCED
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DENISE LESTER I'M
FROM LAKEWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
AM A TEACHER OF. ONE HOMESCHOOL
GRADUATE WHO HAS SPECIAL NEEDS
AND ONE OTHER TWELVE YEAR OLD
LIST YOU NAME SEVENTH GRADE
SOLUTION.
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
ROMAN PLEASE I AM CARE THE
HUSQVARNA HOMESCHOOLING BUT
THEREFORE IN CENTER MONNING AYE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S PALOMA SHOOK FROM.
CENTER ON CALIFORNIA I'M
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M TAKE A SHOTGUN
APPROACH FIVE A HOME SCHOOLER
FROM SAN RAMON AYE OPPOSED.
JOHN SHOOK ENGINEERING MANAGER
HOMESCHOOLING DEBT FOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
EVENTUALLY ANGELES FOR PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA. AYE.
AND A HOME SCHOOLED GRAND
MOTHER OF EIGHT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ABLE IN I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX.
BLOOM IS DAVID ANGELES
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA. I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
PLEASE TWO LINES THERE'S TWO
MICROPHONES COME DOWN COME DOWN
COME DOWN I AM A HOME SCHOOL
MOTHER OF FIVE IN A POSSESS BILL
AND I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMAN
GALLAGHER.
I MEAN IT'S I CAN AND I. AND. I
OPPOSE AB TRAINS EMPHASIS.
I MY NAME IS RYAN LAWLER FROM
OUT VIOLENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DAN NEIGHBORS SPAM.
WHO PAN?
HI MY NAME IS REBECCA BERG I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL TEACHER FROM
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
HI I'M ALLEGED BERG AND I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI AM CHERYL I'M A HOMESCHOOLING
MOTHER OF FIVE IN A FIERCELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M BY SCRIPT IS FROM SING
MANY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM JOHN GRIFFITH FROM THANK
MANY OF PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER
AND I POSE IS STILL.
MY NAME FRIDAY DALY OF GRAPHICS
AND I'VE.
I MEAN THE SECOND AS A GRATEFUL
SMILE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOANNE MICKELSON I'M
FROM CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA I'M A
FORMER PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND
A CURRENT HOME SCHOOLER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMANDA MICHAEL CINEMA
AND I AM FROM BECAUSE BY CAL
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA MICKELSON
I'M SANTIAGO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA MICKELSON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NEEDS NATALIE FLETCHER I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
AND MY NAME'S JOHN FLETCHER ALSO
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND I
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
MAYBE SAY GOALS NOT PREPARE
OUGHT CALIFORNIA THAT POSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS LOGAN OLSON ON
THE HOME SCHOOLER FROM TELE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS LAURIE FLETCHER HOME
SWING PARENT OF A PROUD COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LUCAS STORY I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CONNOR FLETCHER FROM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
TYPOS THE SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN
FIVE SIX.
MY NAME IS ARIANNA DILATORY FROM
WHITTIER I'M A HOMESCHOOL MOM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HELLO MY NAME IS RALPH DILATORY.
HOMESCHOOL FATHER A POLITICAL
APPOINTEE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS NINA EASILY AND
I AM FROM THE GALLEY A
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FOR TEACHING
KIDS AND HOME SCHOOL FIVE KIDS.
AND I ONE HUNDRED PERCENT OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THIS IS TWO MICROPHONES YOU COME
DOWN TO HAVE MY LICENSE TO LIE
HENSHIN I'M FROM PORTABLE COUNTY
FOR CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M HANNAH RESILIENT I'M FROM
MCGILL YOU CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS CLINTON I AM
HOMESCHOOLED IMPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S LORI FALABELLA FROM
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF TRIBAL EXPLORERS
HOME SCHOOL SUPPORT GROUP THAT
IS IN ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES SIX HUNDRED FORTY
MEMBERS STRONG AND WE ALL OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JOHN HARRIS AMEND
DOUBLING CALIFORNIA MY WIFE AND
I HOME SCHOOL OUR THREE KIDS AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE NAME IS EMILY CHILL FROM
PETALUMA CALIFORNIA I'M A
CERTIFIED TEACHER AND A HOME
SCHOOL PARENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SUMMER JESSE FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I HOME SCHOOL
THROUGH A PUBLIC SCHOOL CHARTER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE SAME AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SALLY JESSE AND I AM
FROM SCHOOL AND I AM IN
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY ALL DAG FROM
UNION CITY CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF TWO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
JULIANNE LOST IN FROM ORANGE
COUNTY PARENT OF TWO PUBLIC
SCHOOL CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CANADA ALL DAGEN EN
POSES.
I MCKENNA HAMILTON A MILITARY
WIFE AND HOME SCHOOL EDUCATORS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS COURTNEY THIRTEEN NOW
AND I'M FROM FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU JUDY AND I.
MY NAME IS HOW JOHANSEN I'M A
HOME SCHOOL TEACHER I'M ALSO
PART OF THE TRACY HOME SCHOOL
ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS JOHANSSON AS
SOMEBODY WHO STILL BELIEVES IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN FREEDOM
KITTY SURPRISE CLOSER TO LASSEN
AND THEY YOU KNOW YOU.
IF YOU WANT TO EDITORIALIZE.
THERE'S NOT A TIME FOR THANK
YOU.
IS NOT A POSITION MY NAME IS
KENDRA RYAN EMPHASIS SOON CITY
I'M A HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM VERY OF OUR AS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. HOW MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA FEAR I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER FROM DISCOVERY BAY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL?
MY AIM IS ANTHONY FEAR I'M HOMES
CLERK AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS DON MURRAY I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE A JOURNALIST
IN HOME SCHOOLING MOTHER AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FEAR. I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER MINDS I'M
FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS CYNTHIA SAUNDERS
FROM BRENT WHAT CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LEANN.
MY NAME IS HERE LET THAT ROYAL
FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JERRY AND LESS NINE
THE HOMES GLAD HER FACE.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE RASH I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED BY NAME THE
SCALAR.
RASH AND FROM THAT WOULD GRANT
WOOD AND I POSES BILL AS AMENDED
MY NAME IS BOBBY CHAU METERS. IN
I'M A HOME SCHOOLER FROM
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA NYPOST
SPILL.
MY NAME IS RACHEL TELL ME DOES I
AM I HOME SCHOOL PARENT OF SOON
TO BE SIX IN BRENTWOOD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS THOMAS COOL COLE AND
THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT. THAT I
POSED THIS VILLAGE AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CARRIE CALL I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER FROM BRIT
WHAT CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
ANALYSTS FISCAL FROM BRENTWOOD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS GEORGE R. DOZER. I'M
FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S VANNATTER SAYS
THEY'LL.
LET ME MAKE CARE ACT AYE POSES
NO MY NAME IS JOSH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL. MY
NAME IS ALICE THAT OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN RAY GOES AND A
FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY LOW DEFAZIO
I'M FOR DISCOVERY BAY CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CATHERINE ANDERSON
AND FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA I'M
HOMESCHOOLING MOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS HENRY JOHNNY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL WAS A PAIR AS
AMENDED.
I'M PARKER CENTENARIAN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS A MAN. I MILLION
JOLENE I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I MEAN WE SEND SEND A HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR IN A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M KATHY WHILE STILL
GRANDMOTHER OF HOME SCHOOLERS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'M JENNIFER JOLLY AND FROM
DISCOVERY BAY HOMESCHOOL MOMS
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'M SHERRY COMBS REAL COUNTY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TARA CONTENT I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL MY NAME IS
MAX MARTIN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS CASEY
MUFFIN I REPRESENT CONTRA COSTA
BALLISTIC LEARNERS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE FAMILIES AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MADELINE MUFFIN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN AYE GOES I
AM A OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CURED AND FLY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CALLING WATSON AND THE HOME
SCHOOL PARENT
ONLY BECAUSE THIS.
MY NAME IS STILL WATSON AND I AM
A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND CLOSED
HIS BILL.
MIMES DOT THE WATSON AND THE
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL MY NAME IS MELANIE
HANSON FROM CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS OLIVIA HANSON AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHRIS HANSEN FIREMAN PARAMEDIC
HOME SCHOOL DAD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS RACHEL HUNTINGTON AND
I ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RAMANA HOLD BACK
THROUGH THE GAL I'M A HOMESCHOOL
MOM OF FOUR AND A BUSINESS OWNER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS PATRICK SILLY GO
FOLLOW FOR.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED ALSO A BUSINESS OWNER
AND A HIGH AND.
DEVELOPER.
MERCEDES CHASE BACK BILL. I AM
ALSO AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR A HOME
SCHOOL GROUP REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED FAMILIES AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED
THANK YOU.
CAN LINES OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOLING MOM AND FORMER
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KAI STEWART HOME
SCHOOLER OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TO MARRY ROMAN HOME
SCHOOLER OF FIVE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOSH A ROAMING UMMAH
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER. AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AN IMAGE OF ON A ROMAN AND I AM
FROM SAN JOSE. I HOPE THE PRESS
HOME SCHOOLER NOW OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AND MASON MARIN HOME. FAIRFAX I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DAVID BRODER AND I AM
A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DIGGING ALLOY AND I
MY NAME IS HEIDI HEALTHLINK
BRONNER. AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
I'M FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS KAREN RESET FROM
OAKLEY CALIFORNIA I PART OF IT
AT NATIONAL GROUP CALLED
POSSIBLE CONVERSATIONS AND WE
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOME SCHOOL STUDENTS AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL. MY NAME IS
CALORIES AND OPPOSES.
I'M DINEEN HEINZ I'M WITH MARIN
HOMESCHOOLERS ARE FROM SAUSALITO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SAMUEL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS JENNIFER
HOW HELP OF CALIFORNIA I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENT THE
AND I CLOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW HOWELL. ON
AND THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M JOSHUA HOW. I'M HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M KATIE HELL AND I OPPOSE THE
SPELL.
I'M MELISSA DEVORE HOME SCHOOL
PARENT FROM ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. AS A
DOVE OR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SOON ENOUGH MARIN
HEALTH CALLS FOR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL NAME IS MIRIAM AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
BRITTANY MAN I'M PRIVATE HOME
SCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY CLARK ON AN
ATTORNEY AND PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
HELLO I'M LA CLARK I M. A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLED STUDENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL AS
AMENDED. I AM KEEN CLARK ON A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM JANET NAPOLITANO MARIN HOME
SCHOOLERS AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FROM KEPT BURKE. EVER STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YEAH MY NAME IS EMILY GALLO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BOTH AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN GALLO I AM A
FORMER CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER MY HUSBAND IS ALSO MY
MOTHER WAS ALSO IN MY DAD TAUGHT
AT UC DAVIS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED I AM A HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR.
HI I'M KAREN DARK WATER AND I'M
HOME SCHOOL ALUMNI I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
RESPONSIBLE HOME EDUCATION AND
THE OVER ONE THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS OF IT. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KIM FIFTEEN AND I'M
FROM CALAVERAS COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LIBERTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S DESTINY SCHEMES AND I.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MALLORY SCHEME I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WESLEY SKIN I
MY NAME IS WENDY SITES FROM
YELLOW COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH STATES AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS PHILIP STOTT TO AN
OPERA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
BRIAN HANLEY SPAIN AND I STYLE
CLAY POSTED THE.
I.
WITH TO KNOW.
MY. STUDIES HAVE. STRONGLY
OPPOSED HIS PALE.
MY NAME IS EMILY STATE SLASH
STRONGLY OPPOSES BOTH AMEND. MY
NAME'S LOGIC I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BELLIS ME.
MY NAME SEVERAL STARTS IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KAYLA WHILE BEEN FROM
UKIAH CALIFORNIA.
I'M A HOME EDUCATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACK I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER FAMILIAR CALIFORNIA AND
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS BROUGH I'M A
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF TWO FROM
WHITTIER CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JULIA AND I SUPPOSE.
MONIES FALCO LISTEN I STRONGLY.
OPPOSES.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED.
RICK GRIECO HOMESCHOOLING DATA
FROM LA MIRADA CALIFORNIA THAT
POSES BILL AS AMENDED.
AND REALLY LUIS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M EMILY LUIS AND I STRONGLY
I STRONGLY OPPOSE IMPOSES BILL
AS AMENDED YEAH FOR CALIFORNIA
AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHERRY SKATE I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB TWO SEVEN
FIVE SIX AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CONVEYANCE GAVE
I AM FOURTEEN YEARS OLD AND A
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON THE ENGINEERING
DEGREE. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SCOTT SKATE
FROM SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
THE NAME IS ERICA FOR ANDREA WE
PRIVATELY HOMESCHOOLING SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS VIVIAN FLANK JEAN I
PERSIST THAT.
HIGH END AND REALLY PLAN ON WHO
SCHOOL FIRM YUCAIPA AND MAYOR
PURSES PARA.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS SO WE'VE
DONE AND I AM A HOMESCHOOLING
MOM FROM YUCAIPA. AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME'S RENEE WHEATLAND I
FROM THE KAIBA. AT A OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM PATRICK WOODLAND I'M IT
CURRENT PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR
AND I OF CHILLS KNOW HOME SCHOOL
MY FOUR KIDS MY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON A KEY DICKEY
I AM A HOMESCHOOLING PARENT AS
WELL AS A BOARD MEMBER OF A
COOPERATIVE IN IN MARIN COUNTY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
BELOW HERE I'M SONIA DE I'M
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD IN TEXAS CAL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
I'M JAN ID <c.green&gt;AND I SPOT</c&gt;
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED I'M MY ID AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M ROOSTER ENOUGH FROM LAKE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM JOHN STERNA. OF FROM A
HIDDEN DEL HAVE LIKE CALIFORNIA.
AND EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
POLICY.
THAT IN THE WASHINGTON DC AREA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TWENTY SEVEN.
SKINNER TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ALEX SCHOOL DAY I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER WHO WAS
ALSO DOING ROLLED AT A PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS STACY GILDAY AND I'M
A HOMESCHOOL MOM OF SEVEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER MASSEY
FROM MAKERS FOR CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS JOSEPH MASSEY.
I'MA KERN COUNTY SOME HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT TRASH STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL OCT MINDY.
HELLO MY NAME IS THOMAS MASSIE
AND I.
TRONG. DOES THIS BILL ASMUND.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA SMITH I'M
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA. AND
I AM A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER OF
FULLER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE HI THAT'S
AND I AM HOME SCHOOLED STUDENT I
POSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED. MY
NAME IS LESLIE HORVATH ON
HOMESCHOOLING PARENT FROM
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS A TINY CASKET AYE
VOTE FROM MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA
I'M A LICENSED SOCIAL WORKER AND
A HOMESCHOOL MOM. MY NAME IS
ELIJAH CAST HIM FROM MARYSVILLE
CALIFORNIAN I POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MIKE A CASKEY AND I
OPPOSE THIS.
MY NAME IS DANIEL METER I'M AN
AIRLINE PILOT NINETY STRONGLY
BIG MY WIFE TELL THE SCHOOL OUR
KIDS SO I CAN BE WITH THEM NOT
LOUSY MAYBE TWO DAYS A WEEK I
MIGHT BE HELD WITHOUT.
RATHER THAN BEING IN SCHOOL SO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ANYTHING THAT
MESSES WITH MY WIFE'S VERY HARD
WORK. AND VERY SERIOUS
RESPONSIBILITY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RACHEL METER I'M A
LICENSED PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND
HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR TO CHILDREN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHANNON ROBERTS FROM
BROWN. AND A HOME SCHOOLING
PARENT OF FOUR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS HEALING DISRUPT
BIRDS.
I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY MOST THIS.
OPPOSED BILL.
AND.
MY NAME IS OLIVIA ROBERTSON FROM
BRADLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SCHOOLS AND.
MY NAME IS DALE ROBERTSON
UTILITY SUPERVISOR AND HOME
SCHOOL FATHER FOR AND I POSE
THIS BILLS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LOREN ROBERTS I AM
FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY OF I'M A I'M A PRIVATE
HOMES WHERE AND IT'S ONLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EDWARD SHOCK I AM AN
OFF DUTY CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICER APPEARING TODAY AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND NOT
REPRESENTING MY DEPARTMENT.
I AM FROM CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HOME SCHOOL GRADUATE I AM
ALSO THE FATHER OF THREE HOME
SCHOOL CHILDREN. I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEY TO SHAW I'M
THE ORGANIZER OF MOUNT DIABLO.
HOME SCHOOL GROUP IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY I AM I HOME SCHOOL
GRADUATE AND HOMES WHEN MOTHER
OF THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MEGAN ARMSTRONG THANK
THE CO ORGANIZER.
OF THE DIABLO VALLEY HOMESCHOOL
GROUP I'M A HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE
PSA MOM OF TWO.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KATIE TO COUNTY AND
I'M FROM ANY CALIFORNIA. AND I
CERTAINLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DIANA AND STRONG.
I AM A HOME SCHOOLER AND A
STRONG PUTS A SPELL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHLOE ARMSTRONG.
I AND A HOME SCHOOL.
LEARN.
SAY.
FOR.
AND I. OPPOSES BILL AND OF THOSE
SO AS AMENDED.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
PREPAYMENT SCANNING MY NAME IS
JD HARRIS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
THE RISK.
MY NAME'S SEPARATE CICCONI AM A
MUSIC EDUCATOR AND A HUSBAND OF
THAT WONDERFUL WIFE OVER THERE
WITH THE THREE HOME SCHOOL KIDS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS WELL.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN HERE SOME OF
WHOM SCHOOL DEBT STUDENT FROM
SAN DIEGO. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEILA HARRIS
I'M A REAL ESTATE BROKER AND A
HOME SCHOOL MOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NIELSEN HUXLEY M.
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KEN HUXLEY I'M AN
ATTORNEY AND HOMESCHOOLING
PARENTS FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED. MY NAME IS
A MY SHE EVEN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THAT IS AMENDED.
I'M.
EVEN HIGHER MCCHRYSTAL.
I'M FOR FRENCH CAN CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME'S JOHN MCFARLAND
FROM BAY POINT CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOMESCHOOL FATHER AND I WOULD
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM VERY CLERK I HOME SCHOOL
PARENT FROM TWENTY COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MATT CLARK ALSO
CONTROL ME COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRIS CITY MONO I'M
FROM NO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DENNIS EVEN THOUGH
FROM YOU KNOW AND I PLEASES
THEM.
MY NAME IS SARAH SEEM ORDER FROM
COLONEL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY MYERS IN A
PHARMACIST AND HOMESCHOOL FATHER
OF OVER TWENTY YEARS THAT VERY
MUCH OPPOSED TO STILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMY MYERS I'M ALSO
HOME SCHOOL MOM TWENTY PLUS
YEARS AND MORGAN FOR CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HOW MEANINGLESS THREE PJ AND I
OF PER? YEAR. HI MY NAME IS INTO
THREE DIFFERENT MORE HE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SHANNON ROATAN I'M
A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENT
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF LIBERTY
CHRISTIAN COOPERATIVE. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THOMAS ARE CAN AND
I'M HOME SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ABBAS NOTAM A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SASHA NOON YES
I'M A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL PARENT
AND. AYE SCHOOL SCHOOL BY THREE
DAUGHTERS AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL ADAMANTLY.
HI MY NAME IS A CIVIL UNIONS AND
I'M A HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL STRONGLY.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXIS NEWS
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA I'M A
PROUD HOME SCHOOLING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IN LIGHT OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS IN THE
AMENDMENTS.
HI MY NAME IS LOU UNIONISTS.
I'M FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND
I'M A PROUD HOST CO STUDENT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THAT YOUNGER OF
YEAH I'M FROM SPAIN AND I'M
BEING HAPPILY HOSTED BY A
HOMESCHOOLING FAMILY AND AYE
OPPOSED IS TO BE A.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA RACHT
HOMESCHOOL MOM TO TWO WONDERFUL
KIDS IN SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM SERENA WE I'M A HOME SCHOOL
STUDENTS SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND I ALONG WITH MY FRIENDS AND
FAMILY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELINA LEE I'M A
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHENEY RAN FOREVER
IS THERE.
I MEAN THIS CLASS THEN LAUGHED
AND POST THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S WENDY LAMB I'M A
HOMESCHOOL PARENT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AT CEMENTED THE
QUEUE.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL MAY POSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELA LEE I'M PART
OF A CLASS OF CONVERSATION IN
FREMONT. AND ALSO PARENTS OF.
STUDENTS AT STILL DEBATE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRIS COACH HAY FROM
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA I HOME SCHOOL
MY TWO DAUGHTERS AND WE ARE.
EXTREMELY OPPOSED TO THIS
BALLOTS AMENDED.
TELL YOU COULD SAY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M AUTUMN ENTERTAIN I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CELESTE MORE AND I
LIVE IN BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M
A PARENT OF ONE.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH MORE WITH THE.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH MORE. I LIVE
IN BRENTWOOD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN HIS MARK MORE FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S JESSIE GALA AND I LIVE
IN ANY UP AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ISAAC ALLEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A
MAN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SONYA GOLLA AND
I LIVE IN ANTIOCH AND I HAVE
GRADUATED THREE ADULT CHILDREN
NOW ONTO A WHICH OUR SHARE OF
DEPUTIES FOR SAN FRANCISCO. MY
HUSBAND IS A POLICE OFFICER IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND THAT HAS BEEN
ONLY. THE REASON WE CAN HOME
SCHOOL BECAUSE MY HUSBAND HAS A
WORKED. LONG AND HARD TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR US AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED
THINK MONEY WAS JUST TYPING DATA
ELEMENT ANYA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS RALPH PANETTA NOT
FROM ANY AKEN I POSED THIS BILL
AS AMENDED HI TANYA PENNETTA
HOME SCHOOL PARENT OF FULLER
FROM ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI I'M THE NET AT LEAST THAT
ALLOWS I AM FROM OAKLEY
CALIFORNIAN I HOME SCHOOL TWO
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS ALICIA CORDOVA I'M
FROM ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS HAYDEN VETERAN
CARRILLO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL MONTHS.
MY NAME IS FAITH CORDOVA AND I
I'M FROM ANY ARE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NATALIE AND PHONE A
UP CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS A MAN.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA ON IT
HOMESCHOOL MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DAVID. AND. I COME
FROM ANTIOCH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WOLFGANG WHAT.
I'M COME FROM ANTIOCH OF THE
BUSINESS OWNER. I'M FATHER OF TO
HOME SCHOOL CHILDREN AND AYE
OPPOSED BILL AS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL ACT AYE FROM
ANTIOCH.
AND HAD BEEN HOMESCHOOLED MY
WHOLE LIFE AND I.
OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONGLY AS
AMENDED.
MANY OF US LET'S BIT PER FIELD
I'M A HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE
COLLEGE GRADUATE MORTGAGE BROKER
I HOME SCHOOL MY FOUR CHILDREN
IN ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM EVELYN. AND I AM A HOME
SCHOOLER.
FOR.
IN ANY OUT CALIFORNIA.
HELLO MY NAME IS DIANE PFEIFER
AND FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS JOSEPH FOR I AM A.
I'M HOME SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES. THE BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN REINA FROM
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND HOME SCHOOL
MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANKS FOR HEARING US
TODAY.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHERYL MA'AM
I'M FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA
HOME SCHOOL MY LOOK THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CALTRAIN EQUIPMENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
AIR MY NEIGHBORS CLOSENESS AND I
AM FROM BRENT WOODS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I AM.
A MOTHER OF SIX HOME SCHOOLED
ALL OF THEM AND THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO I'M DEBORAH LYRICA FROM
ANY CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR OF SIX AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I'M ON NAVAL ERICA AND I COME
FROM ANY ARE CALIFORNIA I'M A
THREAT. PROBLEM SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HELLO I'M DOMINIQUE THREE NOW MY
FAMILY CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOLED
HEARING. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AB T. SEVEN FIVE SIX
AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
I'M PAVE SWEET NAM AND I COME
FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS FAITH GALA AND I
AM OLD SCHOOL STAY INTO
CALIFORNIA. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AN AND.
HI MY NAME IS KILL BELLA I'M A
WHOLE SCHOOL STUDENT. AND I LIVE
IN AND HOW CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS IS IT OUT THERE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL IVAN NAGY.
MY NAME IS ROSY GALA I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF NIGHT KIDS
GOOD TO GRADUATES.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS WILLIAM AND.
AND.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. OF.
AS ELAINE.
HELLO MY NAME IS YET I GALA.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI I'M KELLY OCCURRED IN HOME
SCHOOLING MOTHER FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM KRISTIN SHEPHERD I'M FROM
ORANGE CALIFORNIA AS A FORMER
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I REPRESENT OVER
HUNDRED FAMILIES IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
HELLO I'M SANDRA BRONZE FROM
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA I AM A
PRIVATE.
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SIMILAR AYE
RANDOLPH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED THINKING.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JESSICA CLAN I HANNAH A. M. FROM
FULLERTON CALIFORNIA I AM A
PUBLIC MIDDLE SCHOOL COUNSELOR
IN GARDEN GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I AM A FUTURE HOME
SCHOOLING MOTHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM PERSON TAKAMORI FROM
WESTMINSTER HOME SCHOOL MOM TO
FOUR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THINKING.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANNY SMITH AND
I AM FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA I
HAVE GRADUATED MY CHILDREN FROM
HOME EDUCATION THEY HAVE
MULTIPLE MASTERS AND BACHELORS
DEGREES I AM NOW A. SECOND
GENERATION HOME EDUCATOR WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS THERESA GOOD
MAN I'M FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING BELVEDERE ACADEMY
IN HOME SCHOOL MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS OF ALL GOOD MEN
I AM FROM OAKLEY I'M HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM UNCLEAR FOLLOW AND THE HOME
EDUCATOR FROM CONCORD
CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
I NO LONGER OVERALL AND I.
THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANKS NO.
MY STATUS ELEMENT TRAVIS ALLEN I
AM THE CALIFORNIA CITIZEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX. IS
ABSOLUTELY WRONG IT MUST FAIL IT
MUST FAILED TO DAY.
CALIFORNIA'S.
NO AFFORD USED PARENTS AND OUR
CHILDREN HAVE A RIGHT TO THE
VERY BEST EDUCATION.
THEY THIS STATE COULD POSSIBLY
RIDE WHETHER IT'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS MISTER
I'M HOUSE NOT CLINTON'S NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THAT
PRECISELY AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THEY WAS ON MY OF THE PART. ONE
I I'VE BEEN IMPORTANCE DRAWS
MANY TIMES LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING I AND THE CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS HERE. BY THE WAY TO
FLORA ALLEN I'M SORRY BUT WE
NEED TO GET ON TO THE NEXT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX MUST
BE AWARE RIGHT EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA TRAVIS ALLEN
HUNTINGTON BEACH PROUD FATHER OF
TO VOTE NO.
THAT'S A TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW AND
MY.
MY NAME'S DANIELLE LEVERS I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF FOUR IN
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SLANTED LEVERS I'M
FROM BRENTWOOD AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM SHANNON SURELY FROM BRING
ONE CALIFORNIA I'M A HOME
EDUCATOR OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY LITTLE ZACHARY. AND.
I'M FROM THREATEN TO CALIFORNIA.
AND. I.
OPPOSE.
THIS
WELL AS AMENDED.
THOSE SHOULDN'T SHARE.
AND HAVE CHIANG NCURSES DOESN'T
MEAN.
I AND AUTOLYCUS I CAN FROM
OAKLEY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I CHAU VIA DEL CREWS FROM
WEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND I.
A PURCHASED THIS BILL FROM. AS
AMENDED.
HI AM ERICA I'M FROM OP
CALIFORNIA I HOME SCHOOL THREE
GIRLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO I AM AMANDA BARRACKS I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR FOR MORAGA
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM AND HOW.
AND I AM THRILLED FELL ADMIN.
I ARIANNA HOME SCHOOLER AND SEE
SAUL LANDAU COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M FRANCIS NOT ALL ON
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF SOLANO
COUNTY THEY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'M STILL ON OWNS COOLER AND I
APPLAUD.
SIX PRINTER TOTAL REGISTER THEIR
PUBLIC INFORMATION HOMESCHOOLERS
ARE NOT CRIMINALS I'VE A
HEAVENLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED REGARDLESS OF AMENDMENT.
I'M ROBIN DAY FROM RIPPIN I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR OF THREE AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MATTHEW DAY AMONG HER A HOME
SCHOOLER ASH ON THE POST THIS
BILL.
I'M JULIE BETH WHAM WHAM PEN
HOMESCHOOL MINISTRIES FROM
OAKDALE CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI I'M CHRISTY ANDERSON FROM
OAKDALE CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I MEAN WE ANDERSON FOR MOTO
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED NO.
I'M NATALIE CHAPELLE FROM OAKLEY
CALIFORNIA REALTOR AND A
HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX AS
AMENDED.
I'M CAITLIN CHAPELLE FROM OAKLEY
CALIFORNIA I'M MY NAME'S TEST
WHEN HE WAS.
MY NAME'S TESSA QUINN BMI MOTHER
OF TO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AS.
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX AND I
WILL NEVER ACCEPT IT I WILL LET
EVERYONE KNOW WE WILL NOT STOP
COMING BACK STOP TRYING TO TAKE.
TRYING TO POINT.
I'M.
I AM IS HALEY PEARSON I'M FROM
NAMPA IDAHO. I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX
IF YOU PASS THIS BILL.
THEN YOU DO NOT HAVE THE HOME
SCHOOLED CHILDREN'S BEST
INTERESTS.
I'VE SPEAK AS IT WENT ON.
HI MY NAME IS DANIEL YEAR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
WELL.
HI I'M ALISHA PETERSON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN
FIVE SIX.
THE BAN ON HOME SCHOOL AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS I WILL NEVER
ACCEPT THIS BILL.
I'M STEPHEN GEAR AND FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS JOSEPH GEAR AND
STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL AS A
MAN.
I'M AUSTIN BENNETT I'M A FATHER
FIVE HOME SCHOOLED ALL OF THEM
ALL I'M ALSO A M..
CANDIDATE FOR STATE SENATE FOR
THE SIX DISTRICT. AS THE BILL
WAS WRITTEN IT VIOLATED THE
THIRD THE FOURTH.
THE THIRTEENTH AND FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT
AND.
RASKIN THE REPRESENTATIVES TO
START REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE
AND REMEMBER EURO.
L. REMEMBER YOUR OATH TO THE
PEOPLE TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION.
NAME IS MICHAEL GEAR.
HERE FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
WE OPPOSE THE BILL ISN'T.
MY NAME IS HEATHER MARTINSON I'M
FROM YOUR PAPER CALIFORNIA AND I
AM A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOL NETWORK THEIR HOME
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M AREA REP FOR
A TUNE ALL THE ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION RESOURCE ORGANIZATION
I OWN OC HOME SCHOOLING DOT COM.
AND I RUN CELEBRATION EDUCATION.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THINKING.
I'M LEE MARTIN SYNDROME YUCAIPA
CALIFORNIA SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND SENIOR BENEFITS CONSULTANT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX.
I'M HARRISON MARTINSON FROM
YUCAIPA I AM HOME SCHOOLED AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I RARELY MARCUSSEN FROM YUCAIPA
CALIFORNIA SENDING YOU KNOW
COUNTY I WAS FORMER HOME
SCHOOLERS AND I OPPOSE BOOT BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NEAREST SIZE TRAFFORD I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA IN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S JOEL RADFORD I AM ALSO
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY REFUSE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS KATE RADFORD WHERE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND HOME
EDUCATORS AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I AM CHRISTIE LOW PER FROM
CLOVIS CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL
MAMA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'MABIGAIL BRODSKY I'M HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
I AM SURE WHAT'S HE FROM SHARE
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA HOME
SCHOOL MOM OF FIVE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JOSIAH FOLIO FROM
CLOVIS CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ABIGAIL PUGLIA FROM
CLOVIS CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHRISTY FOGLIA I
SUPPORT.
MY HOUSE CHRISTIAN SCHOOLING
HERE.
ON THEIR BEHALF AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME'S Y. HAVE VERY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
STACEY HOWRY FROM FRESNO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS IAN CAN TERRACE AND
I'M A HOME SCHOOL STUDENTS. FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S KIM CAN TERRACE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
SWAN ENCOURAGED YOU TO OPPOSE
THE SPELL EVEN AS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
HI I'M MATTHEW SMITH.
AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL EVEN
AS AMENDED.
I MELISSA REMINGTON I'M A DENTAL
HYGIENIST AND A HOME EDUCATOR. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M
FROM SUTTER CAT AND COUNTY.
MY NAME IS DUNCAN REMINGTON I'M
A HOME SCHOOLER FROM SUTTER
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALYA DARE TONGUE I'M
A PROUD HOME SCHOOL GRADUATE
CREDENTIAL TEACHER AND EVEN
PROUDER HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CARRIE OR FROM TO
MAKE YOU CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI AND AND OR FROM TECH TO MAKE
A CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AUDREY OR AND I POSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX DOWN THING I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS DONNA STUMP I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND HOME
EDUCATOR FROM WINCHESTER
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL STRONGLY.
HARMON IS RUSSELL STUMP AND A
RETIRED POLICE SERGEANT
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IF IT AIN'T
BROKE DON'T FIX IT.
HI MY NAME IS A DANIEL MYERS
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS FATTAH Y. AND I'M
A HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF THREE
I OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS TURN LIKE TELLING
SOMEONE A TOUGHER AND MANY HAPPY
HOME SCHOOLING IN I OPPOSE THIS
BELL AND.
NOW MIAMI MIAMI.
SPF IN NINETY.
MY NAME IS ALL IN THE SEVERE
FROM LAWNDALE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DANIELLE SAID BR FROM
LAWNDALE CALIFORNIA IN OUR LA
COUNTY I AM AN ADMIN FOR SOUTH
BAY HOME SCHOOL NETWORK AND A
BOARD MEMBER FOR RIGHT HE SAYS
HE SAID ME OUTSIDE THE CUSTOMER
DOES ALL THE VAST. AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANNA QUIZZING ME
STEIDLE AND I'M A SECULAR
HOMESCHOOLING MOM FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER JEROME I'M
A HOMESCHOOL MOM OF THREE I
STRONGLY APPEAL.
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THOSE WHO GIVE IN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS EVA MCGINN FROM
US COMMUTER CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS PASSED DOWN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MY COUSINS AND FROM
BRAZIL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
AND A MISTER CHAU I'M SEN AM I
HOME SCHOOL SOON AND I'VE FLOWS
OF SPILL.
MINDY ADAMS IN ROLES WILL
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M EVAN HINES AND I AM HOME
SCHOOLED AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE NAME IS SUZANNE HEIN SOME
FROM ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA IN A
HOME SCHOOL MOMENT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM WAS WITH LITTLE I AM HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. I'M MEGAN LONG
AND I'M A HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND CAROL EDWARDS FOR BIGGER SO
CALIFORNIA I FILED THE PRIVATE
SCHOOL AFFIDAVIT FOR THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS AND I REPRESENT
HOME EDUCATORS RESOURCE CENTER.
I'M THOMAS EDWARDS NOT OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DAVID WIDOW I WON I
WAS HOME SCHOOLED AND I'M IN
COLLEGE I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL
TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE HEARD I'VE
BEEN A CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED
TEACHER FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF PEACH
BLOSSOM SCHOOL. AND ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF SAN JOSE HOME
SCHOOLERS WHICH REPRESENTS
THIRTEEN HUNDRED HOMESCHOOLING
FAMILIES IN SILICON VALLEY AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M SHARON BARGAIN AND I HOME
SCHOOL MY SON AND I OPPOSE PEACE
DEAL.
YEAH SHE DID CHEN CONTACT. THE
HOME SCHOOLER FROM SAN JOSE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HOW MANY MACHINE KITTY SHANKAR
AMONG HOMESCHOOLERS INSANE AS AN
A PLUSES DEL?
HI I'M CINDY THOUGH SHANKAR
HOMESCHOOLING MOM TO TWO GOES
FROM SAN JOSE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME'S KEPT THOMAS ON THE
HOME SCHOOL PARENT FROM SANTA
CLARA CALIFORNIA. AND I OPPOSE
THIS A BILL AS AMENDED AS WELL.
MY NAME IS JAMES ONE GARDEN I'M
A QUICK FROM DEVELOPER IN SEXUAL
DESIGNER AND I AM HOPEFUL FATHER
ONE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
ILL CONCEIVED LEGISLATION.
HELLO I'M FINESSE AREAS I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF TWO
CHILDREN. ONE OF WHICH HAS
SPECIAL NEEDS AND GREATLY
BENEFITS FROM BEING HOME
SCHOOLED. I'M ALSO THE ORGANIZER
AND SAM CISCO OF. A GROUP OF
HOMESCHOOLING GROUP OF COMPRISED
OF FORTY FAMILIES I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT THEM WE. OPPOSE THIS
BILL STRONGLY AS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELENA TRACEY M.
FROM RIGHT WET. AND I'M A
EDUCATORS MY TWO CHILDREN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M LEE TRACY FROM WRIGHTWOOD
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M TERRACE ONE FROM TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ASTRID ANGER LOW FROM
TORRANCE I AM HOME SCHOOLED AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M RENEE WILCOX FROM BUENA PARK
CALIFORNIA I'M A LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT MY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM SORRY FOR.
FELINA PART AND I OPPOSE.
I'M QUE LUCIER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
LITTLE THING.
I THOUGHT WE WILL KERN.
AND.
FOR.
AND I'M.
NO.
AND THIS BILL.
I AM DENNY FROM JOSHUA TREE
CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED TO
SPELL.
I'M CATHERINE THIS YEAR.
I AM.
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL IS MEANT.
I AM ANGELA UP ALL EARLY BOOST
THOSEI AM A HOMESCHOOLING
MOTHER FOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CA PENITENTIARY AND
I'M SIX GREAT HOME SCHOOLER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SCIENTIFIC GANTRY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CARRIE WE DEMEYER
ENTRY I'M A HOMESCHOOL MOM OF
SEVEN FROM MORGAN HILL
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KELLY NJ AM A FIFTH
GRADER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SPELL. MY NAME IS KIND KNOW
ANDREW I'M A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
MY NAME'S CHO INJURY AND THE
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KEITH ANSWER FROM
MORGAN HILL CALIFORNIA AND THE
FATHER CONSUL FATHER SEVEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M A HOME EDUCATOR MY NAME
IS JACQUELINE WOOD FROM SAN JOSE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS POLITICAL WAS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. I'M DOCTOR
KATIE STEPS GUY AND PHD FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DON COLE AND A
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER OF NINETEEN
YEARS OF TWO CHILDREN COLLEGE A
GRADUATING SENIOR FIVE KIDS TO
HOME I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT I'M A
MILITARY WIFE. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER COLE AND
ASH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED MY NAME IS RACHEL CALL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BUZZING.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW COLE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED MY
NAME IS MADDIE CALL IN HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS HEATHER BECAUSE I AM
A HOME SCHOOLED STUDENT IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS BEVERLY SENATE YOU
FROM ANYA CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED HAVE BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING. OF HOMESCHOOLING
MOM FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
HI MY NAME IS LISA AND A DIEGO.
AND I'M FROM ANY UP CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CASEY TEAR FROM
ORANGEVILLE HOMESCHOOL MOM OF
TWO AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS DIANA DE HAS OF
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HOME SCHOOL MOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I MEANS TOMAR CERVANTES FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL MY
NAME'S EMILY GUEST LEARN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME JULIA GESSLER I AM
TWELVE YEARS OLD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE.
MANY OF US CAN REALLY KESSLER
BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR TEN YEARS
OR ALSO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND TRACY CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ACTUALLY VIZAG SCHOOL
NEXT ALLEY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS HOWIE PRECISELY FROM
ORANGEVILLE CALIFORNIAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
THERE'S TWO MICROPHONE SO WE CAN
HAVE TO LINES COME DOWN KEEP
COMING KEEP WALKING.
I'M CLOUT AT COCONUT OUR OF BACK
A BILL CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
HOME SCHOOLING PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JOANNE AND I'M
FROM VERY BAPTIST CHURCH HOME
SCHOOL GROUP AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MELODY AND FROM
FAIRVIEW BAPTIST HOME SCHOOL
GROUP AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I MEAN IT'S ALL OVER GONZALEZ
FROM SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOL FATHER THREE NAY
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME'S PASSED A ROGER HE
MAN AS I REPRESENT THE VERY
BAPTIST CHURCH HOME SCHOOL GROUP
ON BEHALF OF OUR FIFTY MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO SAY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
STAYING ON YOUR BACK YOU.
NAME IS DAVID SANTIAGO
SACRAMENTO KIND OF CALIFORNIA
HOME SCHOOLED DATA SIX STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AURORA FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF SIX AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO SESSION DAVIS FROM ELK
GROVE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL I WAS HOME SCHOOLED MYSELF
AND WENT ON TO RECEIVE MY
MASTERS OF SOCIAL WORK AT SEX
STATE.
I THINK IT'S A GOVERNMENT
OVERREACH ANNECY CON THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NATHAN DAVIS FROM ELK GROVE
CALIFORNIA.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
INFRASTRUCTURE I DO THINK THAT.
MY NAME'S MOLINOS LOST A PURSES
FROM SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA I'VE
BEEN HOME SCHOOLED MY WHOLE
SEVENTEEN YEARS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S TALLULAH TO PURCHASE
AND AND THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S CASEY TO PERSIST FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA HOME
SCHOOL MOTHER OF FOUR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
I'M JULIE OBVIOUSLY.
SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER.
SECTION I'M FROM SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY AIM IS TO ANNUAL JORGENSEN
I'M FROM WALKIE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SURE I'LL AND I'VE HEARD OF
THIS.
MY NAME IS LEE LINE JORGENSON
I'M THE UNLIKELY HOME SCHOOLER
PAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S HEATHER GREEN CREWS
AND I HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
EDUCATION I'M A CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIALED TEACHER FOR HIGH
SCHOOL AYE FOR HOME SCHOOL KIDS
AND I DIRECT A COOP OF
HOMESCHOOL MOMS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS SIMILAR OVER
FROM CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
LANEY HELLO MY NAME IS HAVE THE
GAS GUY FROM I WOULD CALIFORNIA
AND THEY HOME SCHOOL SIXTH GRADE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS LIES
IN MAKING.
HELLO MY NAME IS SEAN SOUSA I
AM.
SEVENTH GRADE HOME SCHOOLER
FROM BROWN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILLS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS QILA SKY I. A HOME
SCHOOLER FROM GRAHAM WOULD HAVE
EIGHTH GRADE AT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILLAS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KATIE SINCE I AM
HOME SCHOOLED FIFTH GRADER FOR
IT WOULD CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AN ARABIAN FROM
GRANITE BAY CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR GRADUATED FROM UC
DAVIS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KATIE MOST
NINETEEN FROM CAMERARIA AND I
HOME SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JOEY MOOSE AND I
HI MY NAME IS ISAAC MOTION I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPILL.
I MEAN THIS I NESS AND STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA NEWSON
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR AND MUSICIAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX MISSION I AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JACOB NOTION AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MALCOLM MILITANT NAM
PERSIST.
HI MY NAME IS BECKY HENRY I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF FOUR FROM
SUTTER CREEK AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS OWING HENRY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL CEMENTED.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELLA HENRY A
NINTH GRADER I MEAN NIGHTS GREAT
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
FEW. AND I AM HOME SCHOOLED.
DOES THIS BILL.
I'M SO HE BACK THEN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M CLAIRE BROCKLIN HIGH
SCHOOLER AND I'M HOME SCHOOLED
AND AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SCRIPT MCQUEEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MYNAME'S JENNIFER MURPHY AND
FROM BACK OF ALL CALIFORNIA AND
COFOUNDER OF IRON HOME SCHOOL
ACADEMY AND ONE OF THE FOUR
MEMBERS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HIGH AND JUST SIRED THAT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME'S NATALIE ARNETT I'M
FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY I
REPRESENT SLOW HOME SCHOOLERS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JAMES HILL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DANIEL HILL IT
CALIFORNIA. TEACHER AND A HOME
SCHOOLER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CAITLYN HELL EIGHT
SCREEN FROM THE HEALTH PRO
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY OPPOSES
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CASTELLA PROMOTING
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS CAITLYN TO
SELLING I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS LARISSA PASSED
DOWN FROM BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
STRONG OPPOSE THIS BILL. FAMOUS
MEGHAN OF ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CARRY BEAUCHAMP FROM FOLSOM
CALIFORNIA. AND A HOME EDUCATOR
WITH CLASSICAL CONVERSATIONS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
LIKE MY NAME IS DAVID DUNN CHAIN
CHO. I'M A HOME SCHOOLER.
IN A STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOSH WHAT THOUGH
TYPICAL THAT OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EVEN DONE SHINGO FROM
CITRUS HEIGHTS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AUDREY BUYERS FROM
LINCOLN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS EATING CURTIS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE CURTIS A CREDENTIAL
CALIFORNIA TEACHER AND A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KELLY WEBSTER I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
OUR PURPOSE.
MY NAME IS.
THE NIMITZ ELIANA FISH YEAR
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS GERAL IN FISHER I'M
FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS AND I HAVE
FOR STRIDES CHILDREN THAT I HOME
SCHOOL MYSELF AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS LYDIA SHUTS OFF
AND I'M A HOMESCHOOL MOM OF TWO
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND JULIE JONES
AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS WENDY JONES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MATTHEW SUZUKI IN
I'M A HOME SCHOOLER FROM CONCORD
CALIFORNIA AND I VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS L. C. JONES AND I
OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA PETERSON
FROM CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI I'M CINDY HERMAN FROM CONCORD
I'M A HOMESCHOOL MOM OF FOUR
KIDS AND I OPPOSE.
HI ELIZABETH HERMAN.
I'VE BEEN HOME SCHOOLED FOR
ALMOST TEN YEARS AND I STRONGLY
UPON THIS OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HEINZ CHILI CARO FROM ANYA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL HAS MIND.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
CAROLINE FROM ANTIOCH
CALIFORNIA.
I AM A HOMESCHOOLING ELEVENTH
GRADER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI I AM MENTIONING THAT CAROL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HOW NAME MY NAME IS LISA Y.
LEARNED I'M FROM UNION CITY? AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN WEILAND AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOANNA WHILE
INTERNATIONALLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IS MEANT.
MY NAME IS DAVE WEILAND
APPLICATIONS ENGINEER.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
VERY VERY MUCH SO.
HI MY NAME IS SARAH GORLIN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS RECOUNT FOR WHEN
I'M FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL MOORE I
LISTEN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MANY MAJOR BOTTOM ROW CENTER
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. MY NAME IS FAST RALLIES
FROM LATE THAT CALIFORNIA'S SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S STATUS I GONZALEZ I AM
FROM RATES UP AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ISABEL AND THEY
SHRUNK THE. M.. EN MASSE GATE.
SHALL WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A
MEMBER.
MY NAME'S CARRYING GRAVITY HOME
SCHOOL THREE KIDS FROM BREAK
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NEIGHBOR IS KILEY GRAVEL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. MINIMIS JESSE CARA FROM
ANYA CALIFORNIA I HOME SCHOOL MY
EIGHT CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE STUFF.
CRISTINA PARKER FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I MEAN THAT. DOES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES DOESN'T MIND.
MY NAME IS ALI SCULLY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHARITY I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF FOUR FROM
PLACENTIA CALIFORNIA AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE VIA FROM
FONTANA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
WHEN IT IS DAN KAY'S FATHER
HOMESCHOOL PARENT OF THREE YOUNG
MEN THAT'LL STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
SAN JOSE RESIDENT PHYSICIAN
ANNOUNCER.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT NO.
LARA RUN UK'S SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOLING MOTHER
OF THREE ONE GRADUATE FILES TO
REPRESENT A PATH PRIVATE SCHOOL
SATELLITE PROGRAM REVIEW SENDING
FIFTY FAMILIES AND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY
STUDENTS. WE ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANDREW KAY'S PROUD
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AS I SAID GRASS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS GUY'S AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MAX LOCATED SOME HOME
SCHOOLER FROM SAN JOSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IS A
MAN.
I NEVER SCHOOL REFERRERS AND I.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S CRAP TO LASSEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A SPELL.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE PRESS FROM
TO MACULA CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
NINE CURRENTLY HOMESCHOOLING SIX
HOME SCHOOLING FOR NINETEEN
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR ABOUT IT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS EVA BRAUN AND
FROM AN AMAZING HOME SCHOOL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TRACY BROWN ANY UP CALIFORNIA.
AND AYE OPPOSE AND REBUKE THIS
BILL IN JESUS NAME.
MY NAME IS GENOCIDE MARIPOSAS
FEEL.
MY NAME IS NICK HEARING NOW SO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS RUNNING THE NURSE NOW AND I
FOUND ME A PERSON SPELL. MY NAME
IS HOLLY SALAS ARE IN THE HOME
SCHOOL OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PEDRO AWESOME FROM
OAKLEY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
VARIOUS PRESS SERIOUS.
AN ALIEN AMERICA LEANN AND
PLEASES STILL.
MY NAME IS JOYCE HINKLE AND
PURPLE SAM AND I FELT TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS LEAH GOSLIN I LIVE IN
HERCULES CALIFORNIA I HOME
EDUCATE TWO BOYS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO I AM CHILDREN OSBORNE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I AM ISABEL OSBORNE IN THE
HOME SCHOOLER NAY OPPOSES THOSE
AMENDED.
I AM DURING OSBORNE FROM EL
CERRITO I HOMESCHOOL THREE
WONDERFUL CHILDREN IF WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS THE MOSQUE BOARD I
OPPOSE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
AMENDED.
HI I AM A CHECHEN DEL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME THINK THE MACHINE NO
AND I'M HOME INDICATOR TO
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ELLIOT XIN NO I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS SERENITY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. NAMES PAXTON
REGULATIONS BEAR.
I'M SERIOUS WHEN OF ANYONE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS RICKY HERNANDEZ AYE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM JEREMIAS WHEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS PAUL OF ONTARIO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JOHN EISENHOWER ON A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY PURCHASE GO.
HI MY NAME IS KIM EYES NAM A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I REPRESENT
VALLEY HOME EDUCATORS NINE
HUNDRED FAMILIES IN MODESTO
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSED STRONGLY
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LET ME COMMENCE FROM
SAN IS A CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL
MUCH OF THREE WITH ONE IN
COLLEGE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN MEN'S I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER I AM FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A MUSCLE SHE A COME
FROM SOUTH SAN JOSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED BILL IS A MAIN.
HIGHWAY ME WITH IRAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE THE JAG
COME FROM.
SENATE A CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELISE PRESCHOOLER
HIM FROM SOUTH CENTRAL IS A AND
A HOME SCHOOLER A HOMESCHOOL MOM
OF TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KIRA URBAN OF
DAVIS CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOLER
THREE KIDS ONE GROWN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KEVIN SHEA I AM
FROM MENLO PARK CALIFORNIA HOME
SCHOOL PARENT OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS CALLING.
AND HER OWN SCHOOL FROM MENLO
PARK CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS BETH DO BLACK EYE
FROM SACRAMENTO AND THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND A MANDATED
REPORTER. I'M A HOMESCHOOLING
MOTHER FOR TWELVE YEARS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US.
MY NAME IS STILL YOU BLAH. AND I
AM A HOME SCHOOLER I AM A PROUD
ELEVEN YEAR OLDS HOME SCHOOLER.
AND I'M LEARNING A LOT TODAY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS REBECCA ROSENHEIM
FROM LOS GATOS CALIFORNIA I HOME
SCHOOL TO. CHILDREN SIXTEEN AND
NINE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AMY READER FROM THE
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA.
AND A.
I HAVE SEVEN CHILDREN. HAVE BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING FROM THE BEGINNING
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS WENDY DAHLE I'M FROM
FREMONT CALIFORNIA I'M HOME.
MOTHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL IN ANY FORM
WHATSOEVER.
MY NAME IS DEVON RYAN DOG AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
WHEN SAM GLORIA AND HOME SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CORBITT I'M
A MASSIVE PUBLIC REALLY A PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND I'M A HOME SCHOOLER.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S TAMMY OIL LA I'M A
FORMER PUBLIC EDUCATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HYMENIUM IT'S INTERFACE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BET.
HI MY NAME IS AMBER MUSTN'T I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IN ANY
FORM WITH THINK YOU HI MY NAME
IS MICHAEL HORAN SPEAK AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
VANNATTER.
OPPOSES THEM.
MY NAME IS AS EROTIC AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS PIPER PLANET NINE THE
HOME SCHOOL AND AYE OPPOSED A
SPELL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA BRETTON I'M
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LINDA SAPPINGTON I'M
A HOME SCHOOLER IN SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS SON NICHOLAS
SAPPINGTON. AND I'M A HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT FROM SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED TO
SPELMAN.
AND SALINAS SAPPINGTON I'M A
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT I'M FROM SAN
LEANDRO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
AM I SO I EVER OTHER AND.
I'M A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I MEAN SIX RATHER AUTO AND THE
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT FROM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IPOD POSES BILL AS
AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS AUTUMN AS THAT
I THOUGH AND I AM I HOME SCHOOL
PARENT. I.
WORKING HEALTH INFORMATION
SPECIALIST AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA NOLL I
FROM CASTRO VALLEY CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. MIMI SCARING SPRING
ANTHEM SOUND INTO AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALWAYS BRINGING FROM
SAN LORENZO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED. MY
NAME IS DOES A SPRINGER FROM
SOMEWHERE AND SO AND I REPRESENT
THE DA VINCI HOME SCHOOL GROUP A
SEVENTY THREE FAMILIES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
AND KRISTIN RUSHES OFF I'M FROM
SOUTH FREMONT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS PAT MANY NAGRAJ FROM
CASTRO VALLEY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SARAH MAYES FROM
MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
THREE CHILDREN AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JAN I THINK THE ONE I
THINK GOOD AND I LIVE IN
WATERFORD AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
FLIGHTS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M GOT SCHOOL
AND I'M HOME SCHOOLED STUDENT
STUDENT THE SARATOGA CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
GOOD OUR AFTERNOON.
I AM FEDERAL LANDS I LOVE HOME
SCHOOLING AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL ASTHMA AND.
MY NAME IS AARON ROLAND I'M
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER FROM
SARATOGA CALIFORNIA AND I POSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS EVELYN RULE AND
I HOME SCHOOL IN SARATOGA
CALIFORNIA. AND STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I MEANDER FERRIS SOME LAND OF
FROM LANCASTER CALIFORNIA AM A
DEGREED R. F. ENGINEER I WAS
HOME SCHOOLED AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M SAFETY FERRIS FROM LANCASTER
CALIFORNIA AND I STAY HOME MOM
OF ONE WHO HAS A FUTURE HOME
SCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DANA HARTLEY AND I AM
FROM THE POEM CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH HURLEY
AND I. AM NOT PERFECT.
VARIOUS.
MY NAME IS RACHELLE HARTLEY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SARAH STEARMAN
FROM MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S MY SON MIKE ESTERMAN AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICK ARRAY GOES AND
I'M FROM MERCED CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MY NAME IS OLIVER LITTLE
SANCHEZ AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR NAUTICAL HAD
THREE LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS REGINA NELSON I'M
FROM CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
I REPRESENT.
CHRISTIAN HOME SCHOOLERS OF THE
FOOTHILLS AND PROBABLY ABOUT
FIFTY FAMILIES THINK YOU.
MY NAME IS GORDON I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER FROM PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL CLAIMING THE SAQLAIN.
I AM FROM THE HUBBLE CALIFORNIA.
I AM A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS.
THEY'LL ASK ME.
HI MY NAME IS MADISON RYAN AND I
OPPOSE HIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS LOOK CRYIN I'M
FROM HARPER CALIFORNIA. CLAIMING
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
HIS BILL AS AMEND.
MY NAME IS LAUREN RYAN I'M FROM
LA HABRA CALIFORNIA I AM HOME
SCHOOL MOM OF FOUR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HOW MANY WITH AND YOU VIA AND I
AM FROM LA HABRA CALIFORNIA HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THE
BILL AS AMENDED?
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY BEALL IM FROM
LA JOLLA CALIFORNIA RETIRED
UNION ELECTRICIANS. AND I'LL
HOMESCHOOL GRANDPA. I
RESPECTFULLY AND.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU. PRIMICIA
ADRIN I'M FROM BELLFLOWER
CALIFORNIA AND THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AN INITIATION ADRIN I COME FROM
I'M THOMAS LINCOLN.
FROM NORWALK CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'M CAN REALLY CONTRAST LIKE IN
NORWALK CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM I WORTH A FROM FOUNDATION
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL AND AYE POSES
BRAS AMENDED. I'M ISAIAH WORK
THE AND.
I'M A STUDENT FROM FOUNDATION
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM AS A OUT OR TAX AND I'M
FROM FUND ASIAN CHRISTIAN SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DANIELLE WORTH THAT
FROM FOUNDATION CHRISTIAN SCHOOL
AND WHAT YOU'RE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL AS
AMENDED.
AND MY NAME IS MEDI SALAH MORALE
IS
I AM A. BIOMEDICAL MECHANICAL
ENGINEER BY PROFESSIONAL I AM A
MEDIA PUBLISHER AND A HOMESCHOOL
MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH WALLACE I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM THROUGH A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM KIM EMAIL AN FROM CASTRO
VALLEY IN A OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM ALEX. SO. I AM HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AND YOU MARRY.
LARA.
I PERSIST PARA.
I'M CAROLYN MELON I AM A HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
FOR PASSED RALLY BEHIND MY NAME
IS SKINNER OWNS AND I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING AYE OPPOSED.
I AM AMY ENDS FROM HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA I'M A HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND COUNTY MARION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THEM.
I.
HUMMUS GOTTA NONI I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE BY PROFESSION
AYE WE HOME SCHOOL GETS.
AND FROM CASTRO VALLEY INTERVIEW
NOT STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI I'M SAID BASHED ME AND NO
MONEY. AND I STRONGLY AT. A
POUND THIS BILL.
I AM LADY AND NONI I HOME SCHOOL
FOR KIDS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HIGH AND MIGHTY SELA MONDAY ON
IS FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I POSTED IT VIA THE.
HI I MY CELL OUR PIECE FROM
BAKERS FAIL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I AM CINDY MCCLATCHY.
FROM HAYWARD CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL AND THE
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AS IN RIVIERA MAYA
HOMESCHOOLED I SCHOOL FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND AS LISA TO SO I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MASHED INSTRUMENT TOY YOU FROM
CEREMONY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'M ADDISON'S STEAMER TELL YOU.
FROM SAN RAMON AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S AKSANA STEM A TOY YOU
I AM A HOME EDUCATOR AND AYE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I'M GETHSEMANE DOES A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THEIR.
HI I NELLA.
HE.
HIGHER YEAH THEN.
NOW.
I'M DANIEL MENDOZA AND FROM THE
WAY HER CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS WONG I'M
FROM DUBLIN CALIFORNIA I'M A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND MY WIFE
I HOME SCHOOL OUR THREE KIDS.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE SIX AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS DANA LONG I AM
FROM SET AND DOUBLING CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS. JOSHUA CENTER
FROM A CEREMONY CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHT BE TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS IAN SARAH AND I
COME FROM OF SAN RAMON
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS GINA SANTA I'M A.
EDUCATOR OF COMPLICATED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AB.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX.
HIGHLIGHTED CLARA HAD AYE
OPPOSES.
TIM SALADO FOR MANY A CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY SALADO FROM
ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA AND I
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS ENACT A THEN
MASS LATIMES THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSES BUILDING.
THIS IS JUST A COVER LINE.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA KOVALAINEN
FROM LIMITS CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOMESCHOOL PARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE AND
COLLECT CATHERINE COVER LINE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM RARELY CHAMBERLAIN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CARISSA CHAMBERLAIN I
MY NAME IS AMY CHAMBERLAIN AND I
AM A HOME SCHOOL PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANARCHY
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS SPELL GOD
BLESS AMERICA.
HI MY NAME IS WINIFRED OR TEASE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALBERTO TEETH.
A MECHANIC AND HOME AND HOME
SCHOOLING FATHER I STRONGLY
OPPOSES AB SEVEN.
FIVE TO.
TWENTY FIVE FIVE SIX.
I'M MY NAME IS KATHERINE WEBB
AND I AM A HOME SCHOOL PARENTS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ADA WEB ALLENDER I AM
FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS WENDY WEB OUT
UNDER. I AM A HOME SCHOOL KID I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND JAMISON ARE STAGGERING.
YES.
THEY'RE ALL THOUGHT I PUT OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALISA ORTEGA I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND HE'LL BE HERE I CAME. IN A
STRONG THEIR PURCHASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSHUA HAD A
SURE MAY PERSIST FOR.
MY NAME IS BETH RETAINERS HAS A
CALIFORNIA RECENT RETIRED POLICE
SERGEANT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KELLY ARE STATE
ORTEGA HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AN EAGLE MEN I AM I'M
SCHOOLS DATA AND I STRONGLY
MY NAME IS EMILY GOLDMAN I'M A
HOMESCHOOL PARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
SAMIR GOODMAN I'M HOME SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LANI GOLDMAN A
BUSINESS LAWYER FROM SAN CARLOS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND THEN THEY.
THIS BILL.
HI AM BRANDON I'M NINE YEARS OLD
AND I OPPOSED TO FILL.
I AND THEIR BABY FROM HOLLISTER
CALIFORNIA.
AND.
.
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS REBECCA BATEY FROM
HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA I WAS
HOMESCHOOLED THIRTY YEARS AGO.
AND IN COLLEGE GRADUATES AND I'M
A HOME EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELA O. ST I'M FROM
LODI CALIFORNIA I'M A HOME
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LEANN STATE.
YEAH THE OF. STRONGLY OPPOSES
FAIR.
MY NAME IS TODD DOES AND I'M A
CORRECTIONAL TENET. OUT OF LODI
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YOU HAVE NAMELY PAUSES PARA.
MY NAME IS HELEN PRINTS ON A
PRIVATE SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND AYE
OPPOSED STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL A TWENTY SOMETHING SIX.
MY NAME IS THOMAS PRINCE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA PRINCE
I AM A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT I
ARDENTLY OPPOSED THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HANNAH PRINTS ON
THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS A AND T. GARDEN I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR AND I REPRESENT
HARD ACADEMY FROM SAN JOSE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I'M KRISTIN TEAGARDEN I'M A
HOME SCHOOLED STUDENT FROM SANTA
CLARA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I'M JUST SITE YOU GARDEN I AM
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ESTHER BEAL AND
FROM FOSTER CITY CALIFORNIA I AM
A BUSINESS OWNER AT HOME SCHOOL
PARENT OF FOUR CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE AMENDED BILL
TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX.
MY NAME IS SOPHIA PATH THIS I'M
A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID PAPPAS AND
I'M. HOME SCHOOL STUDENTS AND I
HOPE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
PAPPAS AND I AM A PRIVATE HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN PAPPAS AND
THE PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT
AN ENTREPRENEUR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LEANN.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I OPPOSE THIS NO.
AND MY NAME IS MICHELLE TELFORD
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MATT ABOUT HOW FOR
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KRISTIN GROSSMAN I'M
A HOMESCHOOL MOM FROM DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA CRESSMAN I'M
I'M SCHOOLS TODAY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BROOKE NESTS PER FROM
THE SCARY BIG CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR AND I.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WILL LEARN MATH
SPIRIT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
DEL.
AND THE WHOLE SCHOOL STUDENT.
I'M A NEWS RICHARD DEATH RUMORS
GO BAD I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ELIJAH MISSUS AND I
PUT THIS BILL.
HI I'M JODY MISS THE SIN FROM
GARDEN VALLEY AND.
HOME SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LONDON MISSUS AND I
MY NAME IS ERICA WILCOX FROM
BRENTWOOD AND I HOME SCHOOL AND
I WAS THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI. THIS IS.
HE STEINORTH HIS MERE.
HI MY NAME IS BIANCA MAYORGA
FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SARAH LEAN AND I'M
A HOMESCHOOL MOM FROM BRENTWOOD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DANIEL LANE FROM
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS WENDY SANABRIA FROM
ANY ON CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MY SOLANO.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN ARENA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MY CASE LOOK FROM
ANTELOPE CALIFORNIA AND I AM WE
HOMESCHOOL BED.
EDUCATOR AND AUTHOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GENERALLY HAZELTON I
MY NAME IS ANY PRICE AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL. MY NAME IS
KYLE PRICE MAY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS HARLEY PRICE NYPOST
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS REBECCA
PRICE I REPRESENT MY HUSBAND AND
MYSELF JIMMY PRICE WERE FROM
FALLS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANA BEING MEN THERE.
AB NO SLING FOR NINE YEARS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AND I BE EVEN BETTER
I REPRESENT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE CIRCLE OF
HOMESCHOOLERS GROUP AND MY
HUSBAND AND MYSELF MY CHILDREN
WE HOMESCHOOLED FOR TEN YEARS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JAY COMPETING MANNER
ON THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND
OF TEN YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JC BEATEN BANG THEIR.
I PERSONS.
MY NAME IS LINKING CODDLING HOME
SCHOOL GRADUATE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EMILY FLANNEL HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AT TEN YEARS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MANY ZEKE FLAME I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA DONOVAN THE
HOME SCHOOL PARENT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
WINNING IS MIKE AND BEAMS AARON
LOW WHO SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
MISATO. AND I OPPOSE BILLS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NAOMI DAMES ON A
PERSON'S DEL.
MY NAME IS EMMA BEING SOME HOME
EDUCATORS FROM NEVADA CALIFORNIA
I POSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MANY OF HIS OWN SCHNEIDER IN A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOLER I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MAKE SCHNEIDER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HELEN SLATER I'M A
CREDENTIALED TEACHER AND HOME
EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
WHEN I WAS VOTER BECAUSE AND I.
MOST OF HOUSES BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS PHOEBE HER CALL FROM
SAN RAFAEL AND HOME SCHOOL
PARENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DAVID BENGAL I'M FROM
A.
FOUR FULSOME CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME ISESTHER BENGAL. I'M
ALSO FROM FULL THEM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HE AN EVERYMAN AYE
IN THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND
I.
LIVE AND AUBURN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SARAH HOOD AND I
LIVING REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME'S MARY BETH HEARD AND
I'M FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA HOME
SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN HOOD I AM
A FIFTH GRADE HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT IN REDDING CALIFORNIA. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED KILL THE BILL.
MY HOPE.
MY NAME IS JONES VERNE I AM
ELEVEN YEARS. AND I AM FROM.
ANDERSON CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A MAN. HI MY
NAME IS IRIS A VERY AND NINE AND
FOR MANY CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE US MANDATE.
HI I'M JESSICA SERVER EARN A
REPRESENTS A HOMESCHOOL
COMMUNITY OF OVER A HUNDRED
FAMILIES CULTURALLY MASON
READING AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS OBVIOUS OF OUR. AND
HOME SCHOOLING STEVEN I PLAN TO
KEEP BEING HOMESCHOOLED SO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH QUITE US I
CAME HOME EDUCATOR IN FACT BILL
CALIFORNIA AND THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I'M OUR PRINTER QUICK JAMES
KLEENEX AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA CUEVAS AND
FROM VACAVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL AS
AMENDED.
FIRE MACHEL RIDGE ON
HOMESCHOOLING PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI.
BY SITEK. FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AARON
HAILING FROM WEST SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRIS HAMMOND AND I
OPPOSE THE STUFF.
I AM DOES RE FETCH FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA I'M A LICENSED
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
HAVE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR SIX
YEARS APART HOME SPUN. OUT OF
THE HOUSE HOME SCHOOLERS IN
PRESCHOOL AT HOME AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DAN HALL FROM SAN
JOSE I'M A FATHER AND HOME
SCHOOL. EDUCATORS THE PSP I
OPPOSE IT THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
PRIMARY HALL FROM SAN JOSE AYE
POSES DON'T THINK YOU.
I AM SRI VEGA FROM VALLEJO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RAFI VEGA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS IS EVEN YEAH AND I'M
A KNIFE GREAT HOME SCHOOLER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IS
MEANT.
MY NAME IS TOMASI WILLIAM MAN
AND I COME FROM SACRAMENTO CA
CALIFORNIA INITIALLY OPPOSED
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
FINALLY SEAMAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL HAS BEEN.
I TEDDY MEN AND.
AND.
I AM BASING THURMOND AND I'VE OF
CATHCART CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
I AM AMBER MAN.
AND I'VE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR
NINE YEARS FROM KEMPER
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NICOLE GARCIA FROM
PLEASANT HILL CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LUCAS GARCIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME'S GAVIN GARCIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DENISE LETO I'M FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING EDUCATOR FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS EMILY IN LITTLE*
A STAPLES.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH I'M LIVING
ALAMEDA IN A STRONGLY. OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS WENDY FRESH. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. MY NAME CLEANUP PART
MIAMI AND PARK IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSE THOSE. BY.
I MEAN NO PART A STRONG OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS HOLLY MEMORIAM I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BLOWN MARTY AND I
PUSHED SPILLWAYS MENDED.
MY NAME IS CASH BIAS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS COOL BISON AYE. UC.
I OPPOSED THE BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER BIAS AND
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOME EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS HEIDI ETHERIDGE I'M
FROM EL DORADO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHINA ETHERIDGE I'M
FROM OUTER ON A COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM KATHRYN KERN. AYE AND FROM.
FOR A STEP CALIFORNIA IN A.
AARON CAME HOME SCHOOLED IN A
CLASH THE OPPOSES SPELL I SEND
MEN.
MY NAME IS SHANNON HI AND I'M
FROM LATER CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN
A HOME EDUCATOR FOR EIGHT YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KRISTIN FIRST I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR PRIVATE SCHOOL
WE'VE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR TEN
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL AND
FOR FAIR OAKS CALIFORNIA AND I
MADE CHARTER HOME SCHOOL TEACHER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THINK YOU.
I MEAN THIS AND YOU AND. I AM
FUNDING FOR IT AND. I HEARD THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELAINE ARNOLD I'M
FROM LAKE FOREST.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ERICA HIDES A I HOME
SCHOOL MY FOUR CHILDREN IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY I'VE BEEN A
HOME EDUCATOR FOR SIX YEARS HAVE
MAYBE A LIBERAL STUDIES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I AM AND LIKE A HIGH TECH FROM
ATLANTA GEORGIA AND. AYE OPPOSED
TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS VANO AND ENJOY HOME
SCHOOLING AND TO KEEP THE HOME
SCHOOLING I STRONGLY OPPOSES
PARA. MY NAME IS TOM TAKE A
BECAUSE THEY AND I CONTINUE I
CONTINUE TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I NOTICED ADRIN OF A GUY FROM
SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA I HOME
SCHOOL FOR MY KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THOSE WITH.
HI MY NAME IS AROUND OF A GUN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
HYMAN'S REBEKAH VAGANA STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL. I RAN A PARK I WAS
HOME SCHOOLED THE NOW IN SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL MAKE YOU.
CAN BAG WELL FROM ENACT.
I OPPOSE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
AMBUSH WANDER FROM VALLEY
SPRINGS CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MICHELLE DE OCAMPO FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA I HAD TO COLLEGE
GRADUATES AND I'M HOME SCHOOLING
MY THIRD. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM ORINDA MATTHEWS I AM FROM
CALIFORNIA SAN JOSE.
AND I'M IN THE ELEVENTH GRADE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
I'M JILL MATTHEWS FROM SAN JOSE.
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
I AM LAURIE MATTHEWS I'D BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THERE YEAH.
AND.
OUTSIDE CURRENT SPENT.
HI MY NAME IS SARAH Y. MARIN
FROM RESCUE CALIFORNIA BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING FOR SEVEN YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IF MENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SKINNER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S EMMA WIMER AND I
SURELY. PILLOWS AND.
HI MY NAME IS MEGAN LOPEZ A
HOMESCHOOLING FELL LAST FIVE
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS TENER LOPEZ AND I
POSES DOESN'T MANDATE.
MY NAME'S INTERLOPERS FROM
MARTINEZ NIGHT OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS DON HOLTON I'M A
FORMER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
EDUCATOR IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND I HAVE BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING. MY CHILDREN FOR
THE PAST THIRTEEN YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
I AM JUNIPER BANKS.
I LIVE IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
I'VE BEEN HOME SCHOOLED FOR MY
ENTIRE LIFE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI EMIL HOLTON AND I'M FROM
EMERYVILLE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS SLAM HOLTON AND.
I SHIRLEY POSTS BILL.
TAURUS AROUND US AND I LEFT MY
CAREER FIFTEEN YEARS AGO TO
BECOME THE MAIN TEACHER.
COUNSELOR COACH COOK JANITOR.
TRANSPORTATION COORDINATOR THANK
YOU JUST OUR WHOLE SENIOR
POSITION I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CLEVERNESS AND
HOMESCHOOLING IN SACRAMENTO IS
CLOSE THIS BILL AS A MAN.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH GRANNIS I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA NINE
SPOKESMAN.
HI MY NAME IS EASY KILL JAMES
THORNBERG.
AND THEY CAN THEM FROM. CRIME
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI I'M JUST GO THORNBERG HAND
I'VE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR
THREE YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SO I SURE
THORNBERG IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS NICOLE ABOU FROM
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA I'M HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY WILL BROUGH
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
EVEN AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS CATHERINE LAWLER
I'M FROM LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA
I'M A LIFELONG. PRIVATE HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AUDREY LAWLER I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN
AS AMENDED MY NAME'S LAUREN LA
BOO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL IS IN
THE.
HI MY NAME AS REBEKAH LAWLER
I'VE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER.
AND HOMES GOING EDUCATED FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
FROM LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY. DISAPPROVE OF THIS
BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
TARA PHARAOH DIRECTOR WILD WEST
GUY LEARNING CENTERS SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED
THINK YOU.
KRISTIN HAMILTON DIRECTOR OF THE
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL. FOR THE
FIRE ACADEMY IN PALO ALTO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS DMITRY DIFFER SURE
HEARD I'M A HOME SCHOOL PARENTS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DAN ECHO ALBRECHT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM MAKING HAD AND I STAND HERE
PER SE THEIR.
MY NAME IS ROBBIE ALBRECHT HOME
SCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS THURMOND JULY AND.
I'M A HOME SCHOOLER AND POSTERS.
MY NAME IS DETERMINE RONSON I'M
A TRANSLATOR AND TO HOME SCHOOL
PARENTS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JESSE LION FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA QUIRK IS A
MERTON SEE NURSE AND THAT THE
HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARE NO FUN AMONG
HOMESCHOOLED STUDENTS AYE
OPPOSED TO SPILLS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS SANTIAGO I'M HOME
SCHOOLED STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS SARAH OCAL I'M HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CLAIRE SWEENEY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KATE SWEENEY AND THE
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY. OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN
AS AMENDED.
I MELISSA SWEENEY HOME EDUCATOR
IN SOLANO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S MO JOHNSON IDEA FAIR
OAKS CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS RON AT WILSON I
REPRESENT CLASSICAL
CONVERSATIONS OF SACRAMENTO I'VE
BEEN A LONG TIME HOME SCHOOL MOM
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S AND THE CONTRACT SO
THAT MY PROPOSED.
MY NAME IS REI'S WILSON I AM A.
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND.
JIM CLANCY CLASSICAL
CONVERSATIONS AND I POSE THIS
BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS REBECCA ALICE FOR.
I'M FROM RESCUE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS MEN.
MY NAME'S ANGELICA ALLA
CORPORATE INFORMASI THAN I
POSSESS. EVEN AS AMENDED.
I AM CAMINO FLORIDA OF LOTUS
CALIFORNIAN I POSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
AMANDA CARLSON FRESNO CALIFORNIA
HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR OPPOSES
BILL AS AMENDED.
NAVISTAR FIVE AND I OPPOSE THIS
I AM HAPPY KILLING AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M CHAD FIVE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED. MY NAME IS
EMILY FIVE HAVE BEEN
HOMESCHOOLING FOR SEVEN YEARS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS SHELLY LAYING AYE
PERSON SPELL. MY NAME IS JANELLE
HOLBERG SCOTTS VALLEY I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE
HOMESCHOOLING PARENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER LANGE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BELA CAR NORRIS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL EYES AND.
MONEY WAS SALIM JONES I'M FROM
OKAY CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ALAINA SNYDER FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND THE
PROPER PROGRESSIVE VOTER AN
ACTIVIST AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS THE V. JOHN'S I'M
UNSCHOOLING FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS THIS LEAN QATAR I'M A
HOMESCHOOL PARENT TO HAVE THREE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE ALL BEEN HOME
SCHOOLED AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AS AMENDED.
PAM TELLING PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
HOME SCHOOL NETWORK WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CAROL TAYLOR I'M FOR
MEMBER TO THE CALIFORNIA I'M THE
GRANDMOTHER BY HOMESCHOOLING
FAMILY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
VERONICA TAYLOR FROM CASTRO
VALLEY MOM OF TWO HOME SCHOOLERS
AND I OPPOSE.
THIS I BILL AS AMENDED.
THE NEAREST CHENEY FEEL. ALARMED
HER SINCE BIRTH IN MAINE. AND I
HAD THE WHOLE DINNER I'M HOMES
SCHOOL EDUCATOR OF FIVE CHILDREN
NINE BECAUSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED.
AMY CALL REPRESENTING OLD SCHOOL
LEARNING IN OAKLEY CALIFORNIA
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS
AMENDED. MY NAME IS SANDY HI I'M
FROM BECKLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN AS AN.
MY NAME IS REBECCA HART I'M A
HOMESCHOOL PARENT IN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CLASSICAL
CONVERSATIONS IN BRENTWOOD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
MAYES BRAND HIGHER FROM BRITAIN
CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOL PARENT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KATE REYNOLDS I AM I
HOME SCHOOL GRADUATE IN
HOMESCHOOLING PARENT I OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS MATTHEW REYNOLDS
AND I OPPOSE A SPELL.
MY NAME IS PROTECT I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE AND HOME
SCHOOL PARENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL
EVEN AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM RANDALL I AM
HOMESCHOOLED I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I ENVISION A CHENEY FROM IT WAS
A CALIFORNIA AND THE HOME SCHOOL
GRADUATE AND PAT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS BOB COLLINS.
I AM A HOME SCHOOL PARENT. AND A
RECENTLY RETIRED PUBLIC EDUCATOR
AFTER FORTY YEARS OF SERVICE.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME'S MONIKA CROSS A HOME
SCHOOL PARENT FROM SAMMY NO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS BENTON CAUTION I
STRONGLY MEANT.
THEY'RE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS DAVE ACROSS SOME
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHARLES CLASS AND
THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A
MAN.
MY NAME IS BAD I AM I HOME
SCHOOL SHOOTING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE POLICE BILL AS A MAN
GAME.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER LOPEZ I'M
A HOMESCHOOL MOM I CURRENTLY
HOLD A CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHING
CREDENTIAL I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS MEASURE.
AND THIS AND THIS MEASURE AS
AMENDED.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME MAINTAIN.
I NEVER AND JULIA DESPAIR.
HELLO MY NAME'S ERIC LOPEZ HOME
SCHOOL FARTHER FROM HOLLISTER
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS OR.
LARA POSERS.
HI MY NAME IS SAVANNAH MERCER
AND I POSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM ABRAHAM MERSHON THE HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME AS KIM MERCER FROM
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LOOSE GANON DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA I AM A RETIRED
CALIFORNIA TEACHER. TEACHING
CREDENTIAL. ALL WHO HOME
SCHOOLED MY CHILDREN AND NOW THE
PROUD GRANDMOTHER OF.
CHILDREN WHO ARE BEING HOME
SCHOOLED BY MY DAUGHTER.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. BE TWO
SEVEN FIVE SIX AS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSICA DUTRA FROM
HOLLISTER HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA.
AMONG HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AGE EIGHTEEN CHAT AND
I OPPOSES DEL.
I CLEARLY. HEARD.
HI I'M TINY COLLINS FROM ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED
AND I AM NOT A HOME SCHOOLER.
HI MY NAME IS KATHLEEN MCGREADY
I'M FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
TURNED HOMESCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN
FIVE SIX AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PRISCILLA
GARCIA ARM FROM BENICIA
CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOL PARENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEATHER GIBBONS WE
LIVE IN WITH IN CALIFORNIA AND A
HOME SCHOOL MOTHER OF SIX
CHILDREN WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR SIX YEARS. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M TAMI GIVENS I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER AND AYE OPPOSED TO
SPELL.
MANY DAVID GIVENS I AM A PROUD
FATHER SIX BEAUTIFUL INTELLIGENT
LITTLE CHILDREN AND WE ALL VERY
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RAINN.
RAINN. CLOSE TO.
MY NAME IS GREG GARDNER AND.
I AM POSEHN.
FIVE SIX AS AMENDED.
AND.
YEAH.
MY NAME IS JOHN A GARDENER I AM
A HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF SIX
WONDERFUL CHILDREN FOR NINE
YEARS. I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
NONNA NOW THEM OKAY YEAH.
OPPOSES FAIR. AND NOW AND THEN.
MY NAME IS STACY BROWN MARTIN
I'M FROM CARSON CALIFORNIA I AM
A HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF TWO
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ELI AS GOD KNOWS I AM
FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA. AND
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MONIES CAGER GARDINER I'M A
FATHER OF SIX HOMESCHOOLED
CHILDREN AND A CURRENT PUBLIC IS
A SCHOOL TEACHER AND I OPPOSE
HIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS DEVON MARTIN PARSON
AND AYE OPPOSES BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH PILE AND I
POSE THIS BILL IS IN AND.
I ISRAEL PILE AYE POOL DESPAIR
AS A BABY.
MY CATALINA FILE I OF A MEDICAID
MY CHILDREN BECAUSE I WAS SENT.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS PEARL PILE AND I POSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ANYTHING.
I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS AARON SINCE AREA LIVE
IN ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME'S DULCINEA WHILE
IS AND I'M FROM MENDOCINO
COUNTY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS EVA LOPEZ AND I'M
FROM MAKE DEVELOP AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES SPAN.
MY NAME IS RUTH LOPEZ I AM A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF FIVE INCLUDING
TWO GRADUATES AND I'M FROM
VICTORVILLE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS VINCENT LOPEZ AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CAROL HEARN I'M FROM
HAS VERY CALIFORNIA CHRISTIAN
ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THIS BILL AS AMENDED THINKING.
MY NAME IS WITNEY HEARN I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER KNOWS VERY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MALLORY HEREIN I'M
THIRTEEN AND I LIVE IN HIS VERY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JANNA LOPEZ I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL I'M A HOMESCHOOL
GRADUATE FROM VICTORVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL IN ANY FORM
WHATSOEVER. MY NAME IS SOPHIA
LOPEZ AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS GOING HARD AND I'M
FROM NEWCASTLE CALIFORNIAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M VALERIE
HARLEM A PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IN
ITS AMENDED FORMAT IN ANY FORMAT
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIFFANY LUKA
AND I'M A PRIVATE HOME EDUCATOR
ALSO REGISTER DAHLE HYGIENIST.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU WARNING FOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK
LUKA FROM BENICIA CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND.
RESPECT YOUR.
YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA QUAN.
I AM A HOMESCHOOL MOM FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO
REPRESENT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FAMILIES FROM THE SILICON
VALLEY.
BASIC HOME SCHOOL SUPPORT GROUP
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER RANDALL HIM
FROM OAKLEY CALIFORNIA. IMA TEN
YEAR HOME SCHOOL MOM OF TWO
TEENAGE BOYS AND I'M THE HIGH
SCHOOL COUNSELOR FROM THE
FREMONT CHRISTIAN SCHOOL PSP. MY
HUSBAND STEVEN AND I BOTH
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IN ANY
FORM THANK YOU.
I.
I'M JANETTE CONKLIN IN I'M
HOMESCHOOLING PRIVATELY FOR
WITH THIS GUY TELESCOPE AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M BARBARA.
LARA.
IN I'M. FROM.
FONG.
NOT HOLE THERE.
NNAMDI. PERSIST BEAR.
RAINN.
AND OUR FRIENDS ARE FROM.
SAYS.
AND I. DON'T DAHLE PER SE SPARE.
MY NAME IS KATHY LET SOME I'M A
HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR. AND IN
SAM'S DISTILL COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JOANNE LEON
AND I'M FROM SAN MATEO COUNTY
I'M A HOMESCHOOL PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DEE DEE AND THE HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT FROM SANDIA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AS AMENDED.
ONE IS ROBERT JONES I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AS STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX. AS
AMENDED THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
MY NAME IS LAURA JONES I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NANCY KIM AND I'M
FROM DIANNE BY CALIFORNIA AND
I'M FELLOW LISTED CUSHION PSP
FIRM FOUNDATION. AND A BUNCH OF
OTHER HOME SCHOOLING FRIENDS IN
ORANGE COUNTY IN LA COUNTY AND
SEPARATE YOU KNOW COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THINKING. HELLO I MEAN EIGHTEEN
KNOCKED ON A SHAMLI AT THOSE
GUYS AND THEN. AND I'LL AYE NAME
IS TIMOTHY CAN'T. AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ARTHUR MARC
RICH RECORD OF THE CALIFORNIA
I'M A HOMESCHOOL PARENT FATHER
OF THREE AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX WAS
AMENDED. THANK YOU.
I'VE HAD REMARKED HOME SCHOOL
STUDENT FROM RANCHO CORDOVA
CALIFORNIA. I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SAMUEL MARK I'M A
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA WHAT JEFF
I'M HERE FROM CERES CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM A HOMESCHOOL PARENTS
THROUGH A CHARTER SCHOOL AND NOT
A PSA I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I AM ROMAN WOODRUFF'S.
AND I AM HOME SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS TRAVIS WOODROW FROM
HOME SCHOOL FAR FROM SERIOUS
CALIFORNIA WORKS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
DANIEL COLUMN WITH CAPITAL
RESOURCE INSTANTLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THINKING.
BRANDY FALCON FROM REDWOOD CITY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHE HOLE IN LOOD I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MAY VETS HAVE DAYS
AND HOME SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES SPAM.
THE.
ALL TIME. HARPER THANKS MAN.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER TOP US FROM
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA I'M
HOMESCHOOLING MOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ISAAC CHAVEZ
HOMESCHOOLING FATHER A PORTABLE
CALIFORNIA NAY STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL AS A AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LARA LEYVA RIVERO
FROM RUNNER PARK CALIFORNIA HOME
SCHOOLING PARENTS AND I STRONGLY
A BILL THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. THANK YOU.
I'M CARL RIVERO.
AND I'M THE HOME SCHOOL STUDENT
FROM RUNNER PARK AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI ANDY AND LEYVA FROM SALARIES
ó CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI AND DISHONOR I AM
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF FIVE IN
A HOME SCHOOL MINISTRY LEADER IN
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL AS
AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RENEE
SCRIPT LIKE I'M A HOME SCHOOL
MOTHER OF THREE INCLUDING TWO
GRADUATES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNY KNORR NAM FROM
MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM TENER SCRIPT NAKED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LUCY READ YEAR I'VE
BEEN HOMESCHOOLED MY WHOLE LIFE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LAURIE RIDGE ZERO I'M
A HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR FROM
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AND MARRIED ZERO AND
I AM OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS LEE AND DAY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE DAY.
I.
I'M WILL SCHOOLER. I SHOULD I
STRONGLY OPPOSES SPELL.
MY NAME IS JAMIE CENTER NICE
BURN. HOMESCHOOLINGAND I.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY DAY FROM
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA I'M NOW
A HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER AND
FORMER TECH EXECUTIVE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HEIDI GLEISNER I'M
FROM ONE THAT CREEK I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND IN ADDITION I
HOME SCHOOL MY TWO CHILDREN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IT WOULD WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AS WELL I OPPOSE
IT. AND THIS MADE OUT OF REAL.
MY NAME IS ABIGAIL SURROUND I AM
AN EDUCATOR AND I'M A HOME
SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND THIS IS.
KIND MERE TURNOVER IN A IN A
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT IN A.
PERSONALLY. I.
DISPEL THANK YOU.
I MEAN A SAVER.
AND I'M A HOME SCHOOLER IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE DESPAIR.
HI MY NAME IS WENDY VIENNA
WAIVER FROM BENICIA CALIFORNIA
I'M AN ACCOUNTANT AS WELL AS A
HOME SCHOOL MY MOTHER FOR THREE
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
IRON ES PARA.
ROOM.
MY NAME IS JESSICA CREW DEL
HAMMAM EDUCATOR FROM DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND OUR FAMILY
OPPOSED TO LIST THEM.
YEAH.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
WELL BECAUSE HE HAD GRINNED ON.
MY SON JONATHAN SIR HOW JONATHAN
HIGH. AND.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSES BUT MY WIFE
AND I WERE HOMESCHOOLED TRACE
CALIFORNIA.
I'M TINA JANSEN FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA MY FAMILY STRONGLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RUBY JAN ST I'M A
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW NINE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEANNE ANNA.
AND. GRAY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA EAGLES I'M
FROM SAN JOSE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA TERRENCE I'M
FROM LOS GATOS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE DORN FROM
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA AND I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF FIVE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. MY NAME IS BURKE GOING
FROM BERLIN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JOSHUA DURING NAY
OPPOSES POLLS AMENDED.
HI MONDAY WAS YOUR MIND TORN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI I'M JUST AYE GONZALEZ AND I'M
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JONES ALSO FROM INDIA
CALIFORNIA. RURAL SHOWING
OPPOSES SPELLERS AMEND.
MY NAME IS MARRIAGE HAS GONZALES
I'M A HOMESCHOOLING PARENT FOR
FOR CHILDREN IN A. PREVIOUS
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JUDY GERONIMO I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER FROM. AMERICAN
CANYON AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. I'M ALMOST EIGHTY TRONG
TOMORROW. I'M A HOME SCHOOLER.
AND.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER KUNA HOME
SCHOOL MOM AND I HAVE A CHILD
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS ALSO AND I'M
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIAN I POSE
THIS BILL.
I AM AN IMMENSELY SIXTY SEVEN
I'M A FORMER PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER. CURRENT CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHER HOMESCHOOL MAMA AND A
PRESIDENT OF FREEDOM CHRISTIAN
COOPER CORPORATION AND ON BEHALF
OF FIFTY FAMILIES WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
OUR MAIN MEANS CAN SEE.
AND PER.
MY NAME IS KATIE EVER FROM
CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND OUR
ENTIRE FAMILY OPPOSES THE SPELL.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE COLDER
AND THE PARENTS AND WITH
EXPERIENCE PUBLIC SCHOOL AND
HOME SCHOOLING. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL WHERE FROM
FRESNO.
MY NAME IS GABRIEL CAN TELL A IN
A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RON CONTOH A FROM
FRESNO AND MY FAMILY OPPOSES
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RACHEL MAINLAND AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JESSICA AMY LYNN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS REBECCA MAITLAND WERE
FROM AISLE TO CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARTHA CARAMANDI
AGAIN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS ADAM BEACH OF A HOME
SCHOOLING PARENT FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M AARON KING FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOES HE MEAN
PEACH OPPOSE COOLER FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIAN YOUR CARTOONS I
STRONGLY OPPOSES PILSEN AND.
HELLO MY NAME IS CARLA MIRA I'M
FROM PENN VALLEY CALIFORNIA I AM
A STEAM EDUCATOR IN HOME
SCHOOLING THIRTEEN YEARS AND I
HOME SCHOOLED BOTH MY SONS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. THINK YOU HELLO I AM
SKYLER MIRA I'M A HOME SCHOOLER
FROM PENN VALLEY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALYSSA HASKIN I'M
TWELVE ALMOST THIRTEEN AND. A.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FINALLY I HAVE SKIN IN MY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
KILL MY NAME IS RACHEL HASKIN
I'M FROM FREMONT CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOLING MY CHILDREN ABOUT
SEVEN OF THEM WITH ME TODAY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSES DEL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JUST ASKING AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M REBEKAH HOSKIN OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED. I AM WILLIAM
ASKING I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS MARY ARAGON FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. AS A HOME EDUCATOR
OF SIX CHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M KIMBERLY BLACK OF HOME
EDUCATOR FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS HEIDI I'M FROM
DISCOVERY BAY AND I AM A MOTHER
OF FIVE WE HOME SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SUNDAY I AM FROM
THAT. AND CAL.
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPAM.
MY NAME IS NOT STEEPER I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THINKING.
I'M ROSE KILLIAN FROM CASTRO
VALLEY IN HOME SCHOOL PARENT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EFFORT FROM MARTINEZ
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BRIANNA FROM.
CASTRO VALLEY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BLAKE KILLIAN FROM
CASTRO VALLEY I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL TRAVIS
KILLIAN A HOMESCHOOLING PARENTS
WHO CASTRO VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTY DESE AND LEAD
A HOME SCHOOL NETWORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
OKAY NAM. AND REALLY KEEPS. A
PERSON'S PARA.
HELLO MY NAME IS JERICHO BEATS.
I AM SCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO LADIES LA KIA.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ASH WRONG WE.
HAVE.
OPPOSES HIM.
MY NAME IS CARTER KEEL I AM HOME
SCHOOLED IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. HELLO
MY NAME IS MAKING BEATS AND I AM
SCHOOL HOME SCHOOLED IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS GREG KAREN
AGAIN.
AND I'M HERE WITH MY YOUNGEST
SON TIMOTHY WHOM. I HIS MOTHER
AND I HOME SCHOOL HE'S A FUTURE
VOTER AND JUST ABOUT A DECADE
AND A LITTLE BIT OF CHANGE.
WE ARE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX EVEN AS AMENDED.
AND IN THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
NEXT.
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
HI MY NAME IS KATHY CRAMPS FROM
GILROY CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THIS DIVERSE STATE.
HI MY NAME IS SAVANNAH SHARP AND
I LIVE IN BRENT WOODS CALIFORNIA
AND I'M A HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KARINA AND AE
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS KIANA.
SHARP.
.
NPR CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
TODAY. MY NAME IS A AND ALSO AND
I'M FROM DIXON CALIFORNIA AND I
AM A HOME SCHOOL MOM THAT
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL AS
AMENDED. THANK YOU.
.
I'M RYAN JIM.
IS I'M BRIAN NELSON FROM DICK'S
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE NELSON FROM
DICK'S THING CALIFORNIA I'M THE
HOME SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE IN MUSIC I
AM.
HOME EDUCATING MOM OF SIX
FROM SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
WHEN YEARS ON LA MUSIC I HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH STERRETT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED. BY
NAME IS JULIA DAVIS QUARTER I
HAVE BEEN A HOME SCHOOL STUDENT
FOR EIGHT YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS AUDREY STARE AT A
PREVIOUS CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED
TEACHER AND HOME SCHOOL TEACHER
FOR TEN YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL AS AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
MANY OF SCOTT GOT FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND THE HOME SCHOOL
DAN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LYDIA RIVERA I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M HOME SCHOOL LAW
AND I. PROPOSES FILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS JULIE CAST DATA AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF THREE
FROM OROVILLE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
I AM DENISE BIRD I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND A
HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I'M KIM I'M FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA I'M A HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR AND A UNIVERSITY
ADJUNCT FACULTY MEMBER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN IS
CURRENTLY AMENDED.
I'M KENNEDY BURDEN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
GARY CHEN CONCORD CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL MECHANICAL ENGINEER
WAS THE PRIMARY HOME SCHOOL
EDUCATOR FOR SIXTEEN YEARS OF
RIGHT NOW THREE YOUNG ADULT
CHILDREN I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HOLLY ONE FADING FROM DICK'S IN
CALIFORNIA. AYE WE SCHOOL
THROUGH INDEPENDENT STUDY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MORGANWG LADEN FROM DICK'S IN
CALIFORNIA.
.
INDEPENDENT STUDY.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JEANINE DEROSE CANDIDATE FOR
STATE SENATE DISTRICT SIX WHERE
WE'RE STANDING AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HI I AM ROBERT LOUIS EXTRA I AM
A FORTY YEAR OLD HOME SCHOOLER I
AM HURTING MYSELF AND MY TO
PARENTS SO THEY CAN MAKE IT. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MANY.
MY NAME IS NOLAN PRIOR AND FROM
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I WENT THE ECHLIN FROM ORANGE
COUNTY WE CURRENTLY HOMESCHOOL
THROUGH A PUBLIC CHARTER THAT WE
SUPPORT SCHOOL CHOICE AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS NIKKI PRIOR FROM
BRITAIN CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL
CREASED THREE CHILDREN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS WIDE ALLEN AND FROM
LA COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY AIM IS EVAN CAR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL EVEN
AS AMENDED.
HI I'M THE GALLON FROM LA COUNTY
AND I PUT A SPELL FOR NOW I'M A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS AMENDED.
I AM RUN A GALLON FROM ST PETER
CALIFORNIA AND I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM THROUGH A
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
SUPPORT SCHOOL CHOICE I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY AMENDED
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S GRANT LOOSEN I
STRONGLY.
.
CLOSE THE SPELLS AMENDED.
HI MAY NAME'S HEATHER FRIENDS I
MET DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC
PERSONALIZED LEARNING CHARTER
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY A HOME
SCHOOL MOM AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY SLOW US I
AM FROM ORANGE COUNTY A FORMER
FORTUNE ONE HUNDRED EXECUTIVE
WHO RETIRED TO HOME SCHOOL MY
CHILD.
I AM CURRENTLY HOMESCHOOLING
THROUGH A PUBLIC CHARTER BUT I
AM MOVING BACK TO A PSA. AND I
AM ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL EVEN AS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS IN FRANCE I'M A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD HOME A GAP
FROM SCHOOL.
AT.
SANTA ANA CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE FIGURE TURNED.
HE MY MEANS LEVER. INTERIM LOST
INTEREST.
I PERSIST PAIR WELCOMING.
MY NAME'S AMANDA SHUT I'M A
CREDENTIALED TEACHER IN LOS
ANGELES AND THEY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME'S MARSHA.
ANY OF LOS ANGELES.
THE PERSON SPOKE.
MY NAME IS ERIC FRAME I AM A
SACRAMENTO CITIZEN AND A
CANDIDATE FOR STATE SENATE
DISTRICT SIX OH STRONGLY OPPOSE
PLEASE NO WE'RE NOT GONNA
POLITICKING HERE NEXT THANK YOU.
I'M HEATHER OBERNOLTE BIG BEAR
LAKE CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL MOM
FOR NINE YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KHIMETRICS INFOMERCIAL
CALIFORNIA.
PERSIST PERSON AND.
HEY MY NAME IS AMANDA MEDFORD
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOL MAMA FIVE IN A LOCAL
AND DIRECTOR OF THE COUNCIL
COMMUNITY I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
I'M JUST NOT HEARD FROM US WILL
CALIFORNIA HOMESCHOOL FATHER AND
I SUPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DALTON METRIC FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA.
IN A STRONGLY OPPOSES.
I'M LOU THIS THE BARREN AND I'M
A HOME SCHOOLER FROM HELL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE AND I'M A
HOME SCHOOLER AND I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS AMENDED.
HELLO I'M ALISON THE BARREN IN
MY HOME SCHOOL MOM OF FOUR FROM
LOS ANGELES. AND A PER OF
PRIVATE SCHOOL TEACHER I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS LARA NAME OFF I'M
FROM PASADENA CALIFORNIA I'M A
BOARD MEMBER OF A SIXTY FIVE
FAMILY COOP CALLED WISH. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED.
HI I AM CASSIDY IMHOFF. O. HOME
SCHOOLER FROM PASADENA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL DOESN'T.
I'M A HOME SCHOOLER FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI AM KATHRYN QUICK I'M EDUCATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HIGHER AND LOWER QUICK I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED. HI I'M
HERE IDEA GRAY HOMESCHOOLING
PASCOE COVERS SEASON ST WINDSOR
AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
HI MY NAME IS EARLY ON TO ME IS
FROM HERE TO CALIFORNIA AND I
GOT A CLASSICAL CONVERSATIONS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NOAH. AND I
STRONGLY IN TRULY APPROACH.
OPPOSED TO SPILL.
HI MY NAME IS KIM ID THEY A AND
THE HOMES COOLEY AND BECAUSE
THEY SPEND.
HI MY NAME IS KAYLA DO VERY AND
I OPPOSE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MADRID MONES FROM
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SHE CATIA DO BARRY AND
THE PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR
FROM HAYWARD CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
DIRECTOR OVER CLASSICAL
CONVERSATIONS OF SAN LORENZO.
HOME SCHOOL COMMUNITY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX AND AS IT IS AMENDED
THEY KILL.
MY NAME IS US HUNDRED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED. PENNILESS GABRIELA
HELEN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL IS.
MY NAME IS ELAINE HEALTH FROM
VALLEY SPRINGS I'M A HOME
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
HI MY NAME IS SHAUNA GARVIN I AM
A HOMESCHOOL MOM AND THEY ALSO
REPRESENT. ON US AS A BOARD
MEMBER A HUNDRED PLUS FAMILY
GROUP A SUPPORT GROUP FOR HOME
SCHOOLERS CALLED HOME BUILDER
HOME BUILDERS. OUT OF THE EAST
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AREA.
HI MY NAME IS KAYLA BARB AND I
SUPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STEVEN GARVIN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND SO THIS IS
MOM.
MY NAME IS DANIEL BARB WITH
AMERICAN HERITAGE SCHOOL IN
JACKSON CALIFORNIA. I'M A
HOMESCHOOL GRADUATE HOMESCHOOL
PARENT A DEPUTY SHERIFF AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S ANGELA BAR I AM AS
STAY HOME MOM. AND I'M FROM
JACKSON CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMELIA BUYER
AND I AM FROM JACKSON CALIFORNIA
AND AYE OPPOSES. THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MADELINE BARB AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M SANDRA KELLER IN THE
HOMESCHOOL MOM FROM ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S UNIQUE POWER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JEREMIAH KELLER AND I
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY SNOWBALL IN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY WITH
PACIFIC LEGAL FOUNDATION I STAND
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BERNIE GIPSON REDPATH
I'M WITH A SECULAR. RESOURCE
CENTER FOR.
HOMESCHOOLING FAMILIES IN LOS
ANGELES AND I POST THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANNA SMITH FROM
LOS ANGELES LEONE SECULAR
HOMESCHOOLING RESOURCE AND URBAN
HOMESCHOOLERS IN LOS ANGELES AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSHUA TEXEIRA
I'M HOME SCHOOLER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME THIS CASE TO SHARE.
AND FEB CLASSICAL COME THE
STATIONS AND I OPPOSE THIS
THERE.
HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH TEXEIRA
I'M FROM BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA
AND A PRIVATE HOME EDUCATOR I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI ANTI DANIELSON I STRONGLY
HI I'M CAROLYN SAPP DANIEL I'M A
PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
HI I'M TINA CAMP I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES AM A HOME EDUCATOR AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED
THINKING.
IN THE VAN LANG CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY I REPRESENTED GRASS ROOTS
COLLECTIVE PARA COLLECTIVE REAL
CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOL AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AMENDED CAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO.
I'M MICHELLE TRAINER A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND HOME SCHOOL
MOM FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND
AND THE DIRECTOR OF A LOCAL HOME
SCHOOL GROUP EAST CONTRA COSTA
EXPLORERS. AND AS A GROUP WE DO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
AS AMENDED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
BURGER BARNES REAL HOME SCHOOL
CALIFORNIA.
I PUT.
HI I'M THE LAST PERSON FROM THE
HALLWAY.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA SONUS I
HAVE BEEN FILING OF PRIVATE
SCHOOL AFFIDAVIT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWO I STILL I'M FILING
IT NOW FOR MY TWELVE YEAR OLD I
REPRESENT TRI VALLEY EXPLORERS.
IN ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
CALIFORNIA AND SIX HUNDRED FORTY
FAMILIES STRONG AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
.
I'VE HEARD SO.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A SPORTS
EVENT.
.
BUT WITH THAT.
ANY COMMENTS
FOR MANY THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD MISTER KILEY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
I WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF
THE EDUCATORS
AND PARENTS.
ESPECIALLY STUDENTS.
YOU CAME FROM ALL AROUND THE
STATE TO THE CAPITAL THE EIGHT
REMIND US THAT WE ARE A
GOVERNMENT OF. FOR AND BY THE
PEOPLE.
VERY IMPORTANT.
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR EXPERIENCES I WANNA THANK.
ALL OF THE THOUSANDS OF HOME
SCHOOL FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WHO HAVE MADE CALLS
WHO HAVE WRITTEN LETTERS WHO
ORGANIZED
TO MAKE YOUR VOICE HEARD AND TO
FIGHT FOR YOUR RIGHTS?
IT'S BEEN TRULY INSPIRING TO
SEE.
AND WE HAVE SUCH WONDERFUL HOME
SCHOOL FAMILIES JUST THIS LAST
WEEKEND AYE JUDGED AYE. PUBLIC
SPEAKING AND DEBATING TOURNAMENT
FOR AYE FOR HOME SCHOOL STUDENTS
AND MAN WITH THESE KIDS ARE
IMPRESSIVE.
I GOTTA SAY.
I SO I AM.
AND MR MEDINA I JUST HAD A FEW
QUESTIONS ON THIS AND I.
I APPRECIATE THE YOU'VE AMENDED
YOUR BILL AND THANK GOODNESS.
THAT OTHER BILL THAT WAS OUT
THERE.
IS GONE.
.
AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE SOMEONE THAT
I I RESPECT AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN THE TIME TO. TO
LISTEN TO ALL THE PEOPLE.
WHO ARE OPPOSED HERE I'M SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS SORT OF WHAT YOU'VE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WHAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING IS AS TO WHY YOU
THINK? OF ALL OF THE FOLKS WHO
SHOWED UP TODAY FEEL SO STRONGLY
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
I DID I STOOD HERE I LISTEN TO
EVERY SINGLE COMMENT.
I I'M GRATEFUL.
.
TO HEAR.
I I DO NOT BELIEVE IT IS
POSSIBLE.
FOR GOVERNMENT.
TO.
.
LEGISLATE.
AWAY
PROBLEMS OF OUR SOCIETY.
BUT.
WHEN THE TURBINE CASE HAPPENED.
IN AND IN THE IN THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT IN THE SIXTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
A IN THE CITY OF PARIS.
I LIKE MANY OTHERS.
IN MY DISTRICT LOOK FOR.
LOOKED IN THE LAW.
LOOKED FOR OUT WHAT MAY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO HAVE BEEN DONE.
TO HAVE AVOIDED THAT INCIDENT.
AND IT WAS THERE THAT WE SAW.
THAT IT HAD BEEN.
BY LAW PUT.
ON FIRE MARSHALS.
THAT THEY WERE TO INSPECT.
PRIVATE SCHOOLS OF SIX OR MORE.
INDIVIDUALS.
AND AND AGAIN I I SAY AND AND
AND AND I THANK AGAIN OF MY
COLLEAGUE. MISTER GALLAGHER.
IN IN IN HELPING ME REALIZE THAT
AS MUCH AS WE MIGHT LIKE TO.
IT IS NOT IN THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY TO LEGISLATE.
.
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE'D
LIKE TO AVOID SOMETIMES.
BUT THAT WAS WHAT LED ME TO
FIRST THE FIRST BILL WHICH YOU
MADE REFERENCE TO.
.
AND SO AGAIN IN CONVERSATION AYE
AYE AS I STAND HERE A IN FRONT.
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE THE PARENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN HERE. I WOULD LOOK AGAIN.
FOR PERHAPS ANOTHER WAY
AND I WOULD IMPLORE.
PEOPLE.
NOT JUST HOME SCHOOL PARENTS
BUT ALL PEOPLE.
TO BE MORE VIGILANT.
TO BE MORE ENGAGED IN WHAT GOES
ON AROUND THEM.
TO REPORT.
WHAT THEY SEE?
TO.
NOT BE SO HESITANT TO JUST
ALLOW.
.
STRANGE OCCURRENCES TO HAPPEN
WITHOUT.
BUT NO TO FIND SOMEONE.
AND AND I THINK IF THAT IT
WOULD'VE HAPPENED IN MY CITY OF
PARIS THAT I REPRESENT PERHAPS.
OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE TURBAN
FAMILY COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED.
SO AYE AYE I WILL IN MY TIME IN
THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
WANT TO. A CONTINUE IN THAT
EFFORT I WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
HOWEVER.
IN THIS BILL.
IN THIS BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX
I WOULD REMIND THIS COMMITTEE
WHAT IT DOES AND WHAT IT DOESN'T
DO.
AND AND IF I MIGHT.
IN CLOSING UNLESS YOU HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS.
WELL WELL OF STUFF THERE THAT.
I THINK THAT EVERYONE HERE ON
IT KNOWLEDGE IS HOW TERRIBLE THE
INCIDENT THAT THAT YOU REFER TO
IS.
.
BUT.
I THINK EVERYONE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THAT'S AN
EXTREME OUT WIRE CASE.
AND ANY DATA SET WILL HAVE
EXTREME OUT WIRE CASES.
AND ITS NOT GENERALLY
RESPONSIBLE POLICY MAKING IN MY
VIEW.
TO CREATE POLICY. ON THE BASIS
OF THE EXTREME OUT LYER CASE AS
OPPOSE TO. A LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE POPULATION SO I I MEAN
WHAT PROBLEM IS IT THAT YOU SEE.
IN THE HOME SCHOOL COMMUNITY AS
A WHOLE.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD SOLVE. AYE
I DO NOT SEE A PROBLEM. IN THE
HOMESCHOOL COMMUNITY AT ALL AS I
SAID IT MY BEGINNING. I RESPECT.
PARENTS AS EDUCATORS.
BEING AN EDUCATOR MYSELF I I DO
NOT SEE A PROBLEM I I WAS TRYING
TO. REMEMBER.
.
GENTLEMAN WHO I.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR AS
VALID AS A COMMENCEMENT.
.
ADDRESS AT LAST YEAR UNIVERSITY
OF A YOUNG MAN. OF HIS NAME IS
JEREMIAH PURDY.
JEREMIAH PURDY WAS HOME
SCHOOLED.
HE THEN WENT ON.
TO PRESTIGIOUS PRIVATE SCHOOL
AFTER THAT
AND.
GRADUATED.
LAW SCHOOL I BELIEVE A DUKW.
AND JEREMIAH PURDY CAME AND GAVE
THE COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS AT LAST
YEAR UNIVERSITY.
I THINK I'VE READ TWO OF HIS
BOOKS NOW.
UP SO I DO NOT SEE A PROBLEM.
WITH HOME SCHOOLING.
AND.
IT THIS BILL IS NOT AN ATTEMPT.
TO.
ANYWAY ATTACK HOME SCHOOLING.
AT ALL.
A IT IS NOT AN INTENT.
SOLVE A PROBLEM WITH HOME
SCHOOLING.
SO I GUESS WHAT IS THAT WHAT IS
THE POINT OF THE BILL THEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE.
COLLECTING MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT.
THE.
THE NATURE.
OF OF EACH INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL ON.
AND WHAT USE IS GOING TO BE MADE
ABOUT INFORMATION.
IN MY EFFORT TO.
TO LOOK AT WHAT WE DO AND WHAT
WE DON'T DO. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I.
WAS LOOKED SOMEWHAT.
.
BUT.
SOMEWHAT SURPRISED BY THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE NO RECORD AT ALL
ACTUALLY.
OF NUMBERS
OF OUR PARENTS
WHO HOME SCHOOL THEIR CHILDREN
I I BELIEVE THAT EVEN IN THE
STAFF ANALYSIS.
IN THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES THE
NUMBER THAT IS PRESENTED THERE
IS IS A NUMBER THAT IN MY
UNDERSTANDING.
IS ONLY.
A SORT OF EXASPERATED IS ONLY
JUST
TAKEN OUT OF THE DATA.
BECAUSE THERE AND I HAVE RIGHT
HERE.
THE AFFIDAVIT FORM.
PARENTS FILL OUT AND NO WHERE ON
THIS FORUM IS THERE ANYWHERE TO
PUT. THAT THEY ARE HOME SCHOOL.
IT ONLY SHOWS THAT THERE ARE.
IN A PRIVATE SCHOOL.
SO WE DO NOT HAVE. ANY.
RELIABLE NUMBER.
AT ALL.
OF HOW MANY.
PARENTS OR HOW MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE HOME SCHOOL.
SO THAT IS WHY I SAID YEAH IN
YOUR IN ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION.
TO BE COGNIZANT OF WHAT THIS
BILL.
TRIES TO DO AND DOESN'T DO.
AND ALL IT IS.
TRYING TO DO ALL THAT IT ASKS
FOR.
IT JUST AGGREGATE.
HOME SCHOOLING FROM OTHER
PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
AND GIVES.
FIVE DIFFERENT A OPTIONS
THE PARENTS.
COULD I READ THOSE OPTIONS.
THOSE OPTIONS.
OUR CONVENTIONAL FOR TRADITIONAL
PRIVATE SCHOOL.
PRIVATE SCHOOLS SATELLITE
PROGRAM.
PRIVATE ONLINE OR VILLAGES OR
VIRTUAL SCHOOL.
PARENT GUARDIAN OR OTHER
INDIVIDUAL OPERATING A PRIVATE
HOME SCHOOL.
CERTIFIED NON PUBLIC NON
SECTARIAN
SCHOOL SO WOULD BROADEN.
GIVE MORE DETAILED INFORMATION
SCHOOL THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING.
MY QUESTION THOUGH IS.
YOU KNOW USUALLY WHEN WE'RE
COLLECTING.
DATA OR INFORMATION WE DO SO
FOR A REASON
SO WHAT IS THE. REASON THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS DISAGGREGATED
DATA WHAT ARE WE PLANNING TO DO
WITH I I I THINK IT WOULD GIVE A
BETTER PICTURE. OF OF THE
EDUCATIONAL A LANDSCAPE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I I'D.
I DISAGREE THAT.
.
THERE'S ANY SINISTER.
PURPOSE FOR IT.
A MATTER OF FACT
A.
EXCEPT REDUCE ABROGATING THAT
INFORMATION UP ALL THAT OTHER
INFORMATION IS ALREADY SHARE. ON
THE AFFIDAVIT.
WELL.
AYE I YOU KNOW I I VERY MUCH DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE NARROWED
YOUR BILL BUT I THINK THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S CONCERNING
FOLKS HERE IS THAT I THINK WE
SAW A LITTLE BIT OF THE INTENSE
WHEN WE HAVE A MUCH BROADER
LEGISLATION.
AND I THINK THAT ALL THE FOLKS
WHO.
TOOK TIME OUT OF THEIR DAY AND
TRAVELED A LONG WAYS TO BE HERE.
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE BEING
TARGETED UNFAIRLY AND.
AND I THINK THE RIGHT AND THAT
YOU KNOW AS I SAID I I REALLY
RESPECT YOUR THINKING A LOT OF
GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS BUT I'M
DEEPLY TROUBLED.
BY THE DIRECTION OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND I THINK COULD
BE.
YOU KNOW A GREAT ACT FOR YOU
THAT TO BE CONSIDERATE AND
ABANDON THE THIS POINT SO I I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO.
AND IF NOT ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE THE BILL DOWN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. A THE SEEING
NINE.
YOU WE WON'T TAKE MOTION RIGHT
NOW BUT YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
I I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AND.
.
AS A THE COMMITTEE CONSIDERS THE
BILL.
I I WANT TO.
.
CLOSE WITH A QUOTE.
AND JAMES MADISON.
FEDERALIST NUMBER FIFTY ONE.
AND HE SAYS FAMOUSLY.
THAT OF MEN WERE ANGELS NO
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE NECESSARY.
SO AS MUCH AS A.
YOU KNOW WE LOOK FOR THE BEST.
SOCIETY.
SOMETIMES IT IS THE DUTY OF
GOVERNMENT. A TO INTERVENE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
FOR AND I'VE.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
AND TO THOSE WHO CAME TODAY
THANK YOU FOR BEING PART OF THE
PROCESS WE'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE
A VOTE HOW BECAUSE WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A QUORUM IN THIS COMMITTEE.
SO THAT VOTE WILL TAKE LATER.
TAKE PLACE LATER THIS EVENING IS
LOOKING LIKE NOW.
WITH THANK YOU FOR ONE OF THE
LONGER HEARINGS HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN.
PERIOD.
EVER.
SO SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MEDINA THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING YOUR BILL AGAIN THAT
VOTE WILL TAKE PLACE LATER. AND
I DON'T THINK THE SERGEANTS WHO
ARE HERE WHO HELPED GUIDE
EVERYBODY AND I'LL HELP KEEP US
VERY EFFICIENT. TODAY I TWO
MICROPHONES I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
BEFORE GO THAT WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE I DON'T KNOW WHO
THOUGHT THAT THAT GREAT
MANEUVER.
SO THANK YOU ARE SERGEANTS OUT
THERE TO.
BUT THAT A. I WILL TURN OVER THE
CHAIRMAN PRESENT A BILL.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER ARAMBULA AFTER THAT
PLEASE KEEP MOVING OUT OF YOUR.
YOU'RE EXITING.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT.
I MISTER AT ALL.
THIS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
A VERY CAPABLE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND CHIEF OF STAFF I GUESS TO.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROJECT FOR
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT USE TASK ORDER
CONTRACTING.
AGAIN THAT'S TASK ORDER
CONTRACTING SIMILAR TO JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING WHICH ALLOWS COME
WHICH IS THE COMMITTEE HAS
PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTED. LA A A LA
U. S. D. WILL BE ALLOWED TO GO
OUT TO BID ON CONTRACTS FOR
SERVICES AND REPAIRS. BEFORE
THEY ARE NEEDED.
FOR EXAMPLE DURING THE HOT
SEASON HVAC SYSTEMS WILL BREAK
DOWN.
GOING OUT OF IT AFTER A QUICK
MINT NAM FUNCTIONS TAKES TIME
AND WILL LIKELY BE COSTLY.
SIMPLE SUPPLY AND DEMAND CONCEPT
APPLIES HERE. DELAY REPAIRS MAY
AFFECT INSTRUCTION AND STUDENTS
ABILITY TO LEARN THAT'S A NO
BRAINER. I BEND A HUNDRED TEN
DEGREE CLASSROOM.
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT A. HEALTHY
SITUATION FOR LEARNING OR.
PEOPLE OUGHT DELAY IN REPAIRS
MAY AFFECT CONSTRUCTION AND
STUDENTS ABILITY TO LEARN OF
COURSE AS I STATED A BY HAVING
CONTRACTS IN PLACE EARLIER.
THIS BILL WILL ENABLE ELITIST
YOU TO RESPOND TO REQUESTS
REPAIRS WHEN THEY ARE NEEDED AND
WILL SAY THE DISTRICT MONEY
BECAUSE THE PRICES ARE PRE.
DETERMINED.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS MARK
HOPING TO HOOK.
WHO BETTER THE CHIEF FACILITIES
EXECUTIVE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WITH
THAT I TURNED OVER AND I HOPE I
SAID YOUR NAME CORRECTLY AND I
DON'T PLEASE CORRECT?
AND I DON'T KNOW.
WELL MARC COOPER WHO WE HAVE AN
EXCELLENT IN HOUSE WORK FORCE
THAT DOES OUR MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR WORK.
BUT THERE ARE SOME SITUATIONS
WHEN WE NEED MORE. THAN THAT TO
MAINTAIN OUR THOUSAND CAMPUSES.
OUR. THIRTEEN THOUSAND BUILDINGS
THIRTY THOUSAND CLASSROOMS.
SOMETIMES.
THE WORKLOAD JUST EXCEEDS OUR
CAPACITY TO WORK WITH OUR IN
HOUSE STAFF IT'S NOT PRACTICAL
TO HAVE WORKERS ON STAFF
ANTICIPATED THE SEASONAL LOADING
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE.
I'M SOMETIMES WE NEED SPECIAL UP
SPECIALIZED SKILLSETS BUT WE
DON'T NEED HIM ON A RECURRING
BASIS OF DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
HAVE THAT STAFF ON BOARD SO WE
HAVE TO. LOOK SEEK OTHER MEANS
IT'S NOT PRACTICAL FOR US TO OWN
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT LIKE
CRANES AND PEOPLE LAUGHS MORE
SPECIALIZED BORING EQUIPMENT.
SO WHEN WE NEED.
TO HAVE THIS
EXTRA HELP FOR OUR WORKFORCE WE
HAVE TO LOOK TO THE INDUSTRY TO
CONTRACT OUT. NOW THERE ARE.
I'M PROVISIONS NOW THAT ALLOW US
TO CONTRACTED OUT BUT IT'S NOT
AS EFFICIENT AS WE COULD HAVE.
COME THERE TIMES WHEN.
IF WE CONTRACT OUT IT MIGHT TAKE
US LONGER TO GO GET THAT WORK
DONE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A BIDDING PROCESS THAT
COULD BE ME CLARIFICATIONS
REQUESTED. USUALLY WHEN WE HAVE
THIS REQUIREMENT WE NEED HELP
IT'S URGENT. AND WE NEED TO HAVE
IT RIGHT AWAY IT COSTS US MORE
BECAUSE IT'S SEASONAL IT WHEN
AIR CONDITIONING GOES OUT
USUALLY LOTS OF OTHER PEOPLES
ARE COMMISSION GOT MORE NOW
COMPETING FOR THE CONTRACT TO
HAVE HIS WORK DONE.
AND IT DOESN'T ALWAYS GIVE US
THE HIGHEST QUALITIES I'M
SOMETIMES WE SPECIFY WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS THE BEST PRODUCT FOR
MATERIAL. BUT CONTRACTORS CAN
COME IN AND REQUEST A
SUBSTITUTION OF THAT MATERIAL
WEALTH IT'S URGENT FOR US WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO THROUGH
THAT EVALUATION PROCESS AND WE
HAVE TO JUST ACCEPT.
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE
BEST.
I'M THIS BILL WE WOULD STILL BE
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE.
WE ACTUALLY LIKE THE PROCESS
WHERE WE AWARD THE LOWEST
RESPONSIVE RESPONSIBLE BETTER.
WE JUST BELIEVE IT WOULD BE NICE
IF WE COULD DO ALL OF THAT
PRELIMINARY WORK TO ESTABLISH.
WHO THAT CONTRACTORS GONNA BE
PRIOR TO US NEEDING THE URGENT
WORK?
WE GOT ENOUGH HISTORICAL DATA
NOW TO KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A COUPLE DOZEN COMPRESSORS
THAT ARE GONNA GO OUT. WE KNOW
TREES ARE GONNA FALL DOWN WE
KNOW PLUMBING IS GONNA BREAK
WHICH DON'T KNOW WHICH OF OUR
ONE THOUSAND CAMPUSES IT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN ON WE DON'T KNOW
NGUYEN.
BUT WITH THIS LEGISLATION WE CAN
HAVE ALL THAT WORK DONE IN
ADVANCE WERE PREPARED TO IT
IMMEDIATELY AND URGENTLY DO
THAT.
AND WE WOULD WE BELIEVE OTHER
PEOPLE COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
AS WELL AND WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE TO THIS LEGISLATION
THAT WE CAN DO IT. FASTER WE CAN
DO IT MORE COSTLY EFFECTIVELY
AND WE CAN DO WITH BETTER
QUALITY. THANK YOU.
I WOULDN'T TAKE A MOMENT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
HERE. O'DONNELL HERE KILEY THEIR
FAMILY HERE KALRA.
PARDEE
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE THURMOND.
WEBER.
I HEAR.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION OP
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER O'DONNELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE BY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS.
BILL IS VERY SIMPLE.
WHEN ONE ROOF LEAKS IN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT MANY ROOFS LEAK.
ONE ONE AIR CONDITIONER BREAKS
DOWN ON ONE SIDE MANY AIR
CONDITIONERS BREAKDOWN SO THIS
IS AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THAT
MORE CREATIVE MANNER. THAN WE
HAVE IN THE PAST AYE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND.
AND I WOULD SAY BEFORE ACTUALLY
OUT WE GET TO THE VOWED THAT I I
THINK THIS IS. A GOOD IDEA
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT BE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE OF THE
REQUIREMENT FOR A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT I THINK THAT IT'S TIME
WHEN A LOT OF OUR DISTRICTS ARE
STRUGGLING.
FINANCIALLY IT'S NOT GOOD TO
IMPOSE EXTRA COST IT'LL JUST
BENEFIT ONE SPECIAL INTEREST
GROUP BUT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SECOND. WE HAVE A SECOND OUT OF
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
NUMBER.
KILEY NOT VOTING. KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH AYE STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND. WEBER. AYE WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS ON HALL I HAD THIS.
ARE YOU COME BACK MISTER
O'DONNELL
.
THANK YOU WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO MISTER. ARAMBULA FEW.
COME UP.
AGAIN WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
AND MR RAMBO THE.
I HAVE NO IDEA. WHERE WE?
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B..
TWO THOUSAND TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWO THOUSAND AND TWO DIRECTS
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION AND THE STATE BOARD
TO DEVELOP MODEL CURRICULUM FOR
MY LONG HISTORY AND CULTURAL
STUDIES.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ENCOURAGED
INSTRUCTION IN SOCIAL SCIENCES
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT INCLUDE
CONSTRUCTION ON THE VIETNAM WAR.
INCLUDING THE SECRET WAR IN LAOS
AND THE ROLE OF THE SOUTHEAST
ASIANS IN THIS WAR.
AS A RESULT TEXTBOOK PUBLISHERS.
HAVE NOT INCLUDED AMONG
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE SECRET WAR
IN LAOS. LEAVING STUDENTS
LARGELY UNAWARE.
OF THIS PART OF OUR AMERICAN
HISTORY.
I BELIEVE IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT AND TO DEVELOP A
DEEPER UNDERSTANDING AND
APPRECIATION OF THE SACRIFICES
AND SERVICE OF THEM LONG AND
LOUD VETERANS. AND THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE UNITED
STATES MOVE THE BILL ACCORDING
TO THE TWENTY TEN CENSUS
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST MON
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES.
WITH OVER APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
FRESNO IS HOME TO APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MOAN AND HAS
THE SECOND LARGEST LONG
POPULATION IN OUR COUNTRY AFTER
MINNEAPOLIS.
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY HAS
OVER FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND MON.
THE MONEY PEOPLE HAVE A STORY OF
COURAGE AND SUFFERING THAT
SHOULD BE INCORPORATED INTO OUR
CURRICULUM AND TAUGHT TO
STUDENTS.
MOST STUDENTS KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
MY OWN HISTORY OR CULTURE AND I
BELIEVE MODEL CURRICULUM WILL
HELP STUDENTS APPRECIATE LONG
HISTORY AND CULTURE. ESPECIALLY
IN REGIONS WITH LARGE MUNG
POPULATIONS.
THE MONK PEOPLE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT SACRIFICES AND ARE A
RICH PART OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR STATE.
AB TWO THOUSAND TWO WILL PROVIDE
EDUCATORS WITH THE TOOLS TO HELP
EDUCATE CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE
MONEY PEOPLE SO THEIR SACRIFICES
ARE NOT FORGOTTEN.
TODAY I HAVE CHURCH I. BANG
PRESIDENT OF THE LAO VETERANS OF
AMERICA WHO ALSO SERVED AS
LIEUTENANT IN THE SECRET WAR IN
LAOS. AND MILLENNIAL YANG THE
STUDENTS FROM CLOVIS EAST HIGH
SCHOOL TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HONORABLE CHAIRMAN.
O'DONNELL AND.
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS.
MY MANAGER TYPE BANG.
PRESIDENT. NATIONAL HEADQUARTERS
ODD DE LA VETERAN UP BY AMERICA
INCORPORATION.
WE ARE BASED IN FRESNO.
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON TO BE
HAVE OUR BASIC THOUSAND MON.
VETERANS
SUPPORTING AB TWO THOUSAND TWO.
THIS BILL IS.
IMPORTANT TO THE MONK COMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF THE LOS.
I RECOGNIZE ALL VETERAN WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED THEIR LIFE.
FOR THE SAKE OF FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT AMERICA AND
NO FOOD AMONG PEOPLE ARE.
AND THAT OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
SOLDIER LOST THEIR LIFE.
DURING THEIR SECRET WAR IN LAOS
FIGHTING AS OUR ALLY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I MYSELF HAVE SERVING A SECRET
WALL.
FROM NOT IN FACT DIFFERENT I
THINK THEM DEFY.
I WAS RECRUITED IT IS SEVENTEEN.
BIASED DATES HERE A AND SERVE
AND THE SECOND ON ME. REGION
UNDER COMMENDED JOE KNOWING
POWER.
I WAS CAPTURED TOYS BY COMMITTEE
TROPES.
AT ANY ONE TIME WAS TIE UP FOR
NINE DAYS.
WHERE I HAVE TO CHIU BRITAIN
LIFE AND THAT?
I WAS BLESSED TO ESCAPE FROM
CAPTIVITY AND SADLY HAVE TO
LEAVE MY HOME COUNTRY.
BEHIND TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES WHEN MY WIDOW MARTHA.
AND FOUR BROTHERS.
MY FATHER WAS ALSO A SOLDIER.
IN THE WALL AND WAS KILLED WHEN
I WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD.
AS OF TODAY THERE IS STATE OWNED
NO CURRICULUM BEING POLL.
REGARDING AMONGST IN ROMAN AND
IT'S A GREAT WAR IN LAOS.
WELL THE VIETNAM WAR CONFLICT.
ADDRESS.
ADDRESS AND ADEQUATELY AND
PRESIDENT.
US HISTORY CLASS.
AB TWO THOUSAND TOWER.
HOW OH CHILDREN AND CALIFORNIA?
TO HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THEIR MOMS CONTRIBUTION FAKE
TOUR DE SICA Y. SUMMARIZE.
LOW AND MORE AND I'M A COMPLETE
VOTE YES IN SUPPORT OF AB
PROPELLANT TO. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
THANK YOU WELL DONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS
OF THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MELANIE YEAH I'M A
SENIOR CLOVIS THESE HIGH SCHOOL
AS A STUDENT AND THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF AMONG BETTER
AND I WANT TO EXPRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING IN LONG
HISTORY CURRICULUM. TIE INDICATE
TO TWELVE CLASSROOMS GROWING UP
I KNEW LITTLE OF MY HERITAGE AND
WAS NOT FUND OF MY ETHNICITY I
FELT OUT OF PLACE AND DISLIKE
BEING MOVED AMONG MY AMERICAN
PAIRS. IT WAS UNTIL RECENTLY
THAT I BECAME MORE AWARE OF MY
HISTORY THROUGH INVOLVEMENT IN
THE MALL COMMUNITY THINKING GEE
APPRECIATED IT IS A UNIQUE
CULTURE AND ONE WITH INTERESTING
STORIES. JUST LAST MONTH IN MY
ENGLISH CLASS YOU WERE GIVEN THE
TASK CONSTRUCTED PROFILE ESSAY
ON ANY INDIVIDUAL I DECIDED TO
HIGHLIGHT MY MATERNAL
GRANDMOTHER WHO REMAINS A FACE A
LITTLE TO THIS DAY BECAUSE SHE
STILL YEARNS FOR. AND AWAITS THE
RETURN OF HER BELOVED HUSBAND.
MY GRANDPA HE WAS A FIGHTER
PILOT IN THE WAR AND HIS PLANE
WAS SHOT DOWN BUT HIS BODY NEVER
RECOVERED.
MY GRANDMOTHER'S LIVING STORY IS
ONE OF REMARKABLE STRING TRUE
LOVE AND TREMENDOUS SACRIFICES
AS A SINGLE MOTHER IN THE MIDST
OF A LONG REGION MORE. COVER
STORY IS ONLY ONE OF MANY MORE
RIVETING STORIES DEAR TO EACH
MONTH FAMILIES HEART. IN DOING
RESEARCH FOR MY ASSIGNMENT I WAS
DISAPPOINTED IN A POTS FINE NO
SINGLE SOURCES AVAILABLE IN MY
SCHOOL LIBRARY ON THE SECRET WAR
IN LAOS. IF I'VE EGGMAN CHILD'S
AND NOT KNOW ABOUT MY PEOPLE'S
HISTORY DUE TO LACK OF WERE IN
TAX ON THIS TYPE AT.
I KNOW THERE ARE MANY MORE OUT
THERE WHO HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
THE MOON AND ARE JUST AS
CLUELESS I WANT THE STORIES OF
MY GRANDPARENTS AND THE MORE
PEOPLE TO BE TOLD I WANT THE
WORLD TO KNOW THE CORRECT
SACRIFICES. LIMON PEOPLE MADE TO
UPLOAD AMERICAN IDEALS AND
INCREDIBLE JOURNEY THEY TOOK TO
REACH A NEW LAND WHILE LEAVING
BEHIND ALL THEIR VALUABLES.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS
YOU HAVE THE POWER AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT HAVE LASTING IMPACT ON
STUDENT LEARNING AND ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF AMERICA I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES. IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THOUSAND TWO TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU WELL DONE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT MAKE A MONTHLY THEIR
NAME AND BECAUSE
POSITION. YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION IMPOSITION OF THE
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CLEARED ALLOW I
AM I I SIT ON THE BOARD FOR MO
INNOVATING POLITICS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND.
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
SUPPORT LABEL WE ARE HERE
SUPPORT AND BELIEVE THIS IS PART
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S COMMITTEE
OUR COMMITMENT TO ETHNIC STUDIES
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY HANG I'M ON
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF PROJECT
PREVENTION COALITION FROM MERCED
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO WROTE A
LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR A THE TWO
THOUSAND TWO AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S NUCCI HER I AM
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF PROJECT
PREVENTION COALITION FOR MERCED
CALIFORNIA AND A STRONG
SUPPORTER AB TWO THOUSAND TWO
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOABLE I'M A
MOTHER AND A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR IN FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWO THOUSAND TWO.
HELLO MY NAME'S LA WASHOE BANG.
AND.
LA MOMENT RIGHT THERE ON
CHAPTER IN SACRAMENTO I SUPPORT
THESE BEAR.
ERIKA OFTEN A BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS GREGORY BARNES I
WORKED WITH LA VETERANS OF
AMERICA THEY'RE ONE OF MY
CLIENTS AND WHEN I LIVED IN
FRESNO ASK THIS KIND YOU
RECOGNIZE THE MAS CONTRIBUTION
WHICH IS VERY STRONG.
THANK YOU AT ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEN OPPOSITION IS FOR YOU
BEHIND THE RAIL HERE. I'M I'LL
JUST THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR THE AMONG
CONTRIBUTIONS TO AMERICA. YOU
YOU MAKE THIS COUNTRY A BETTER
PLACE FOR SURE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AND A ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS MORE ABOUT
YOUR HISTORY REALLY OUR HISTORY.
I THINK ISA GOOD THING SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
ADVOCATING I DON'T SEE ANY
COMMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE. ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION DOCTOR WEBER
MOVES.
SHE SIGNED HER SECONDS.
YOU MAY CLOSE AND THE MOTION IS
A TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
CULTURAL DIVERSITY.
AND HOW MUCH STRONGERMY
COMMUNITY IS FOR THE LONG PEOPLE
BEING A PART OF IT.
IT IS A PROUD MOMENT FOR ME TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT THIS BILL AND
I'M GRACIOUS THAT YOU HAVE
ALLOWED US THIS TIME. I HUMBLY
ASK FOR A NIGHT OF.
DO PASSED DO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH AYE STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND WEBER. WEBER AYE THREE
VOTES.
SO THE BILL'S ON BECAUSE THREE
VOTES MORE MEMBERS WILL COME AND
I'M I'M VERY CONFIDENT THEY'LL
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS ITEM. IS
OVER THERE OUT THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMITTEES GOING ON RIGHT NOW
AND I'M SURE THEY'LL COME BACK
AND THEY'LL BE VERY SUPPORTIVE
THIS ITEM SO THANK THANK YOU
AGAIN TODAY. FOR PRESENTING
LESS.
OUR NEXT AUTHOR IS.
MISS RUBIO SHE US.
THREE ITEMS SHE IS ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY THREE IN
NUMBER TWELVE SO WHEN WE START
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE.
AB TWO SIX NINE EIGHT YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READING.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT MY ASSEMBLY BILL
A TWENTY SIX NINETY EIGHT WHICH
IS ALSO A WOMAN'S CAUCUS PARITY.
BILL THAT ENABLES CHILDREN IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO BENEFIT FROM EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION. I ACCEPT THE A A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO FURTHER
THE INTENT OF OUR BILL BY
INCLUDING CHILDREN SERVING A
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME SETTING.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT GETTING
RESOURCES TO CHILDREN AND
HELPING TO ADDRESS CHALLENGING
BEHAVIORS AS WELL AS PREVENTING
FUTURE ACADEMIC EXPULSION. WHERE
SIMPLY AUTHORIZING PROVIDERS TO
UTILIZE EXISTING SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE FUNDING TO PROVIDE
THESE VALUABLE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHICH RESEARCH SHOWS
WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN?
NATIONALLY THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS ENROLLED IN PRE K. X. ARE
EXPELLED THREE POINT TWO TIMES
MORE FREQUENTLY THAN K. TWELVE
STUDENTS WHILE CALIFORNIANS FOR
PRESCHOOL.
I'VE PREFIX ALSO RATES ARE EVEN
HIGHER THEM THOUGH THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FROM THIS DATA BECAUSE
CLUED AT THAT PRE CAKES POTIONS
DISPROPORTIONATELY A FRET.
CHILDREN OF COLOR THIS BILL WILL
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR PROVIDERS
TO PURSUE EFFECTIVE EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION MODELS WHICH WE
KNOW IN ADDITION TO THE
BENEFICIAL OUTCOMES. CAN HELP
WITH REDUCING EXPULSIONS WITH
EXISTING.
CONTACT FINDS HERE WITH ME TODAY
IS ADDRESS PARTICULATE CAN
BATTLE THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
TO TALK MORE ABOUT EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH SIR.
HELD CONSULTATIONS
AND PEP PIPPING THAN I WOULD
HAVE A HARD TIME MEN HOW LINCOLN
BANGLES RESEARCH SPECIALIST TO
PROVIDE.
TECHNICAL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND CHAIR MY
NAME'S ON THE OF CNN THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND ORGANIZATIONAL
LEADERSHIP BACK THEN GO. OVERSEE
BOTH THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES
DEPARTMENT.
KENGO IS A NONPROFIT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROVIDER
WITHIN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA SERVING NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN. NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE RECEIVED FREE OR LOW COST
CARE.
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION IS
IMPORTANT AND WE MUST DO WHAT WE
CAN TO INCREASE AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO THIS.
INCREDIBLE RESOURCE FOR THE
ULTIMATE BENEFIT OF ALL
CHILDREN.
THIS MODEL PROVIDES CRUCIAL
SUPPORT FOR EFFECTIVE CLASSROOM
MANAGEMENT AND POSITIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS WHICH INCLUDE.
STRATEGIES FOR SUPPORTING
CHILDREN WITH CHALLENGING
BEHAVIORS AS WELL AS OTHER
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
THIS IS A TRUE COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH BETWEEN TEACHERS
CONSULTANTS AND PARENTS OF TO
PARTNER AND IMPROVING THE
OUTCOMES OF ALL CHILDREN.
SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE ONE
QUICK STORY WITH YOU IT'S A
TRANSFER OF ITS A TRANSFORMATIVE
CONSULTATION OUTCOME FOR THE
CHILD THE CLASSROOM AND IS
TEACHERS.
SO JACKSON CAME TO SCHOOL ON THE
FIRST DAY WITH THE HISTORY THAT
REALLY NO FOUR YEAR OLD SHOULD
EVER HAVE.
IN MOMENTS OF DISTRESS HE WAS
KICKING HITTING SCREAMING. AND
THAT REALLY HAD BECOME HIS NORM.
A CLIMATE OF STRESS AND
OVERWHELM HAD BEGUN TO
OVERSHADOW AND CLOUD THIS
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
STUDENTS.
HIS EXPERIENCED TEAM OF TEACHERS
HAVE FELT STRETCH TO THE EDGE OF
THEIR ABILIY AND BE NEEDS ABLE
TO SUPPORT JACKSON.
SO WE PARTNERED UP WITH THE
CONSULTANT THE TEACHER AND THE
PARENTS AND WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY JACKSON'S A SPECIFIC
NEEDS IN THE CLASSROOM. WHICH
THEN LED TO A JOINT CREATION OF
A BAIT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ENHANCED SUPPORT PROGRAM OR PLAN
FOR JACKSON.
SO WITH OF COURSE THE
PERSISTENCE AND A COLLABORATION
OF THE TEACHERS THE CONSULTANTS
AND THE PARENTS.
JACKSON TO COUNT BEGAN BEING
MORE CALM IN THE CLASSROOM WAS
ABLE TO LEARN AND HAVE MORE
POSITIVE INTERACTIONS WITH BOTH
HIS PEERS AND HIS TEACHERS.
SO. JACKSON WAS REALLY ON THE
PATH TOWARDS EXPELLED EXPULSION.
AND MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION
REALLY TRENT MADE THIS OUTCOME.
DIFFERENCE AND TRANSFORMED IT
FOR HIM THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR
O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STOCKS ARE
PINE FROM HOUSING AND.
DEVICE PRESENT OF RESEARCH AND
POLICY AT CAN DANGLE I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT BILL IF YOU HAVE ANY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MONIQUE ALSO BEHALF OF FOR SUCH
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
PATTING HER ON BEHALF OF EARLY
AGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORT SEEN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
SAY NO OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NO.
BECAUSE RARE THE COMMANDER
TWENTY MEMBERS I'D DO WE HAVE A
MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MISTER STEINORTH MOVES.
YOU KILEY SECONDS.
WELL OKAY I'M GOING CLOSE.
THANK YOU AS A MOTHER TO AND A
FORMER TEACHER I CAN'T TELL YOU
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS I
BELIEVE THAT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS GOING TO HAVE. HELP
EDUCATION AND STARTED IN PRES
PRE K..
HOPEFULLY WITH THIS BILL WE CAN.
HOPE TO PUT INTO THE KEY TWELVE
SYSTEM AS WELL THANK YOU BUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
MCCARTY
STEINORTH AYE STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND WEBER. WEBER AYE.
CORD. CARE THIS FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THAT UP I'M SORRY THAT IS OUT
FOUR ZERO SO THEY THAT BILL IS
HOW WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM NUMBER
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE WAS AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX.
AND THAT HAS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
SO HE BE AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE.
ABSOLUTELY YOUR PASSPORT.
THANK YOU.
.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A WORKING GROUP
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A
CREDENTIALING REPORT FOR
OCCUPATIONAL AND PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS. TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ON OR BEFORE JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL. THAT'S IT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY THAT ADDS A
PROVISION NOT LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF PERSONS IN THE WORKING
GROUP AS WELL AS ADDING THE
WORKING GROUP.
SHALL CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT
THE SERVICE OF THE SERVICES
CREDENTIAL IS WARRANTED.
I THOUGHT SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVEN THESE BOTH OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS AND PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS HAVE.
PROVIDED THERAPY SERVICES TO
STUDENTS IN PUBLIC SETTINGS
THE FEDERAL AND IT.
THE FEDERAL INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES I EDUCATION ACT.
ASSURES THAT CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS WILL RECEIVE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TAILORED TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL CHILD PRIOR TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
FEDERAL ACT. O. T. AND PT
SERVICES WERE TYPICALLY PROVIDED
BY TAKING CHOI AYE CHILDREN OUT
OF SCHOOL.
TO GO TO AN O. T. OR P. T.
APPOINTMENT.
UNDER THE ACT THE BECAME MORE
SENSIBLE TO HAVE.
TEASE IMPEACHES PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO STUDENTS ON SCHOOL
SITES WORKING AS SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES NAY JOINED OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS SUCH
AS SPEECH AND LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST. SCHOOL NURSES
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS AND OTHERS
HOWEVER THESE OTHER PROVIDERS.
.
PROVIDER PROFESSIONS WERE IN THE
SCHOOLS PRIOR TO THE INCLUSION
OF THE SCHOOL BASED O. T. MPT
SERVICES AND BY THAT TIME THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING HAD ALREADY
ESTABLISHED CREDENTIALS FOR
THOSE OTHER HEALTHCARE.
PROFESSIONS
A CREDENTIAL POSITION IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT WHICH COMES
TO MANAGEMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
CAREER ADVANCEMENT ADVANCEMENTS.
THESE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
TYPICALLY TYPICALLY ONLY OPEN TO
THESE WHIPPED UP TO THOSE WITH
CREDENTIALS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX ASKED
THE CDC TO STUDY THE ISSUE FOR
EACH PROFESSION THROUGH THE
FORMATION OF A WORKING GROUP.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS LISTED
UNDER THE BILL HERE WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE TO RE ADVOCATES
THAT HAD BEEN APPROVED BY THE
CHAIR. OUGHT TO PRESENT I HAVE
DONE JAMES A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
FROM PASADENA LISA TESTS
OCCUPATIONAL THEIR FOR
THERAPISTS FROM LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND ERIN DOLAN
AND OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST FROM
THE CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THANK YOU.
I AM.
LISA TEST TIME LICENSE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS FROM
BOTH REPRESENTING THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. AND LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THAT
CAPACITY ON THE COORDINATING
THERAPISTS.
WE SERVICE OVER NINE THOUSAND
CHILDREN FOR OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY.
PRESENTLY AND OZ WAS ARTICULATED
I'M I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX.
OCCUPATIONAL DOES PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS ARE EXCLUDED FROM A
CREWING THAT A SERVICES
CREDENTIAL WHICH MEANS IN.
CERTAINLY IN MY POSITION AND WE
HAVE OVER TWO AND A FIFTY STOP
BY MY COLLEAGUE MY DIRECT
ADMINISTRATOR IS A COUNSELOR. ON
EVEN THOUGH WE PROVIDE A LOT OF
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
I'M NOT AFFORD IT THOUGHT
OPPORTUNITY TO UP BE AT THE
TABLE AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
BROADER DECISION MAKING THAT
WOULD IMPACT POSITIF WILLIE
IMPACT OUR CHILDREN. IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND ESPECIALLY
OUR CHILDREN WITH.
IDENTIFIED SPECIAL EDUCATION
NEEDS.
AND FOR THIS REASON BY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT AN
AYE VOTE FOR TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS
DON JAMES AND I'M A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST AND MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SIX. AS A FORMER SCHOOL PHYSICAL
THERAPIST I CAN SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO THE NEED FOR THIS BILL. ONE
OF THE PRIMARY REASONS SCHOOL
PHYSICAL THERAPIST LEAVE THE
POSITION AS LACK OF A CAREER
LADDER.
IN FACT THAT'S THE REASON THAT I
LEFT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AFTER
SIXTEEN YEARS DESPITE THE GREAT
BENEFITS AND RETIREMENT PACKAGE.
I WAS ASKED BY ADMINISTRATORS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN TO APPLY FOR
SPECIALS POSITIONS AND SERVE ON
COMMITTEES HOWEVER. BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF A CREDENTIAL I COULDN'T
EVEN APPLY FOR THAT POSITION.
BUT DESPITE THE.
SKILLS AND BACKGROUND THAT I
COULD. BENEFIT STUDENTS I'M AYE
LACK THAT CREDENTIALING COULDN'T
APPLY AND THE SECOND REASON IS
THERE PERSONALLY THE POSITION AS
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
UNIQUE ROLES IN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM. OTIS AMPUTEES ARE THE
ONLY LICENSED NON CREDENTIALED
RELATED SERVICE PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS. THE ENTRY LEVEL THE
GRIEF OF PHYSICAL THERAPISTS IS
A DOCTORATE DEGREE.
HOWEVER IN SOME CASES ARE
REPRESENTED BY THE CLASSIFIED
UNION THIS IMPORTANT UNION
REPRESENTS THE VITAL NEEDS OF
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION SECURITY AND FOOD
SERVICES. HOWEVER OUR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORT MEANS DIFFER
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THESE
ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES.
ADDITIONALLY OUR ADMINISTRATORS
ARE OFTEN FORMER CLASSROOM
TEACHERS OUR PRINCIPALS WHO MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES
OF OUR DOCUMENTATION.
REQUIREMENTS CONTINUING
EDUCATION NEEDS ARE PRACTICE
ACTS
WITHOUT THE WITHOUT THE ABILITY
FOR VOICES TO BE HEARD AT AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL WITHOUT
ADMINISTRATORS WHO TRULY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE DO. SCHOOL
OG'S AMPUTEES LACK THE
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT NEEDED TO
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEX WORLD OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION EDUCATION.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE EQUITY FOR SCHOOL BASED
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND ASSIST
DISTRICTS IN THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF AUTISM PT'S BY
BRINGING OUR UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES
TO THE EDUCATION TEAM. AN
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US BE HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS DOCTOR AARON
DOLAN AND I'M HERE TO SHARE MY
PERSONAL STORY. I AM AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST CLOVIS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH
OVER SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AND THROUGH MY. TIME
WORKING IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT I
WAS DRIVEN TO PURSUE MY
DOCTORATE IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP AND SYSTEMS WE BRING
SUCH A DEPTH AND BREADTH OF
KNOWLEDGE WITH NO MOTOR
DEVELOPMENT AND LEARNING. AND A
MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL PURSUING
MY DOCTORATE AS WELL AS
COMPLETING CHO AT THE CLASSES
FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE
CREDENTIAL. I ARRIVED AND
THOUGHT THIS IS GREAT I CAN SIT
AT THE TABLE AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IN AN EQUITABLE FASHION. WHEN I
SOON LEARNED WAS THAT I DIDN'T
HAVE A BASS CREDENTIAL SO I
COULD USE MY DEGREE FOR NOTHING
MORE THAN I CURRENTLY AM AS AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST WHICH
WHILE THAT HAS VALUE. THERE SUCH
AN IMPACT THAT I CAN HAVE SO I
AM HERE TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX AND HOPEFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU HAVE.
AND I VOTE FOR THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YES. MY NAME IS DOCTOR JULIE
BISSELL I'M AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST WITH THE ANAHEIM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS.
AND I AM A RETIRED.
ASSOCIATE.
RETIRED ADJUNCT ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE PAST
TEN YEARS AND THE CO CHAIR OF
THE. OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION SCHOOL BASED
PRACTICE COMMITTEE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF FORMING A WORKGROUP
THROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX TO. ALLOW FORD
I THINK YOUR ATTENTION FOR A
JOHN ET.
AND VERY WELL DONE THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARE AND OTHERS JUST COME
UP SEE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY THANK
YOU.
HELLO I'M AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST MY NAME IS ANDRE CERT
I'VE BEEN IN THE FIELD FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. I LIVE IN THE
EAST BAY AND I WORKED IN OUR
SCHOOLS FOR NINE YEARS SERVING
OUR STUDENTS AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF I DON'T.
I'M TIM COULD HEAR FROM MONTEREY
COUNTY I SERVICE
A. VARIETY OF STUDENTS ACROSS OF
THE WHOLE COUNTY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MORE
IN LOVE HAS AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION.
TO THE BILL COME FORWARD PLEASE.
AT THEM WE NEED HIM WE MAY NEED
TO MAKE ROOM FOR THE OPPOSITION.
SHE NEEDS SOME SO MANY TO GIVE
UP THEIR CHAIR ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
STILL ARE STRAND FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
WE THOUGHT WE HAD AN AGREEMENT
ON AMENDMENTS AS OF YESTERDAY WE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE SPONSORS AND
WE THOUGHT THE AUTHOR WAS
AGREEABLE TO THE AMENDMENTS BUT
WE LEARNED TODAY. THAT THAT IS
NOT THE CASE.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE WANT.
WOULD HAVE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFF RECOMMENDED AS WELL AS PUT
TO CSEA.
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE WORK
GROUP INCLUDING ONE OF OUR OWN
SCHOOL BASED.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST BUT THE
BIGGEST ONE.
WAS THAT IF THIS WORKGROUP DOES
DETERMINED THAT THE CREDENTIALS
WARRANTED THAT MY.
TEASE THAT DO NOT WANT TO GET A
CREDENTIAL ARE NOT FORCED TO GET
ONE WE WANTED AN OPTIONAL PATH
FOR THAT.
WE HAVE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS
THEIR WORK FOR DECADES IN OUR
SCHOOLS WITHOUT A CREDENTIAL AND
WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT. I HAVE TO
CSEA OCT OF MEMBERS HERE TODAY
THERE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST
SAID. A YIELD THE REST OF MY
TIME TO THEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHERYL
DOMINO ON OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS IN THE ST ONE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
DIRECT THE WORK GROUP TO DEVELOP
AN OPTION FOR SCHOOL BASED PT'S
AND.
TEASE LIKE ME WHO DO NOT NEED A
CREDENTIAL.
I HAVE WORKED AS A PEDIATRIC
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS WITHOUT A
CREDENTIAL. I AM LICENSED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA QUALIFIED TO
WORK IN SCHOOLS
I SERVE ON TEAMS THAT DEVELOPED
BY A PIECE AND COLLABORATE WITH
CLASSROOM TEACHERS AS WELL AS
WORK DIRECTLY WITH STUDENTS WHO
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH THE VARIETY.
OF SPECIAL NEEDS INCLUDING
AUTISM NEUROLOGICAL IMPAIRMENTS
AND CHILDREN WHO SUFFER
EMOTIONALLY.
I SUPPORT THE STUDENTS IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS INCLUDING
ADDRESSING MOTOR SKILLS ARE
ADAPTING THEIR ENVIRONMENT WAS
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT AS WELL AS
HELPING THEM TO TOLERATE THE
CENTURY ENVIRONMENTS OF THE BUSY
CLASSROOM.
THE MANDATORY CREDENTIAL WILL
MAKE ME UNQUALIFIED TO DO A JOB
I HAD DONE FOR DECADES IT WILL
ALSO FORCE ME TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
CLASSES INCUR MORE COSTS TO KEEP
MY JOB. THIS PLUS THE FACT THAT
I AM ALREADY OBLIGATED TO
MAINTAIN TWENTY FOUR UNITS
CONTINUING EDUCATIONS FOR MY
LICENSE WILL MAKE EXPENSIVE FOR
ME TO REMAIN IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I MAY BE FORCED TO LEAVE A JOB I
TRULY LOVE.
THE VACANCY I CREATE WILL FORCE
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CONTRACT
WITH EXPENSIVE VENDORS THAT ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A
CREDENTIAL.
FOR ALL THESE REASONS I ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE UNLESS THE BILL AS
AMENDED TO ALLOW AN OPTION. FOR
SCHOOL BASED O. TEAS AND PT'S TO
WORK IN THE SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS BETSY
GRAY AND I'M AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST ATTACK IN CSE A
MEMBER.
AND I WORK FOR SAN JUAN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I WORKED IN SCHOOL B. THIRTY FOR
SIX YEARS AND I LOVE MY JOB AND
THE STUDENTS I WORK WITH.
I AM HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX BECAUSE
THIS WORKGROUP COULD DEVELOP ARE
ACQUIRED CREDENTIALS. FOR SCHOOL
BASED IN POTEET AND PT'S THIS
BILL IS ABOUT ME. IT'S ABOUT MY
CAREER AND IT'S ABOUT MY PAY AND
MY BENEFITS.
MOVING TOWARD A MANDATORY
CREDENTIAL WOULD PUT US INTO THE
CERTIFICATED SALARY UNION AND ON
THAT SALARY SCHEDULE.
ON THE CURRENT CERTIFICATED
PAYSCALE WHICH ENCOMPASSES
TEACHERS SPEECH THERAPISTS
NURSES ETCETERA I HAVING A
MASTER'S DEGREE WOULD BE BUMPED
BACK TO THIS STEPPED HILL AND I
WOULD MAKE FIFTY FOUR PERCENT
LAST. THAN I CURRENTLY DO NOW.
MY TEAM MEMBERS WHO A BACHELOR'S
DEGREES WILL BE PUMPED FURTHER
BACK MAKING FIFTY FIVE PERCENT
LESS THAN THEIR CURRENT SALARY.
ALL OF THEM HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE
THAN I.
I PERSONALLY DON'T WANT AS
SERVICE CREDENTIAL. I DON'T WANT
TO BE AN ADMINISTRATOR AND HAVE
TO SUPERVISE OTHER DISCIPLINES
DEAL WITH ANGRY PARENTS DEVELOP
CURRICULUM AND WORK ON PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT. I WANT TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS AS I HAVE BEEN TRAINED
TO DEAL.
WE HAD.
TEASE HAVE OUR SPECIALTY AND I
BELIEVE TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE THEIRS WE
CAN LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER BUT
WE ARE EDUCATED IN DIFFERENT AND
SPECIFIC TOPICS.
WELL I SUPPORT ALLOWING.
TEASING PT'S WHO WANT A SERVICE
CREDENTIAL TO GET ONE AYE
OPPOSER OF ACQUIRING ALL OF US
TO GET A SERVICE CREDENTIAL TO
WORK IN THE SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY
WHEN PRIVATE CONTRACTED AGENCIES
ARE EXAMS.
I BELIEVE THIS CREDENTIAL WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR PROFESSION
AND WE WILL LOSE OUT ON OH TEAS
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN FAVOR
OF THESE CONTRACTORS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHY THIS GROUP
WANTED.
THE CREDENTIALING IN THE FIRST
PLACE I ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL YA
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WERE ALSO PULLS LISTA MINUTES
WITH GOOD OPTION.
HI JEANETTE THEM OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST OPPOSED.
CARRIE BAUMGARTNER LICENSE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS WITH THE
SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I OPPOSE.
HI MICHELLE PEELER OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
A FROM ISRAEL OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GREAT THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK HERE OF MY JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU I WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS TODAY.
BUT II I I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
FIND A PLACE THAT WHERE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS CAN BE COMFORTABLE
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE TODAY.
I IT'S OBVIOUS TO ME SELL THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I'M SURE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THAT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS MANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING THEM DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
YEAH.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
OKAY.
I'M IN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MAKE
CLONES LIKE YEAH. YEAH YOU YOU
YOU DIDN'T THERE WERE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE NOT TAKEN IS THAT
CORRECT.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL WAS
TO ESTABLISH A WORKING GROUP'S
ALL OF THE THE OPPOSITION FROM
WHAT I I HEARD IS.
ABOUT.
ACTUALLY AFTER THE WORKING
GROUP HAS HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
THAT WE INCLUDED.
WE DON'T LIMIT THE NUMBER OF OF.
MEMBERS I CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THE WORKING GROUP SO THIS IS NOT
ESTABLISHING A CREDENTIAL RIGHT
NOW IT'S ESTABLISHING A WORK
GROUP SO THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THE CREDENTIAL. AND TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT NOT BEING THERE
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE OF THE
WORKING GROUP SO THAT WE CAN
COME TO AN AGREEMENT AS TO HOW
THIS WOULD WORK. AND SO.
.
SO SO.
THE.
THE END BUT I THINK THE REYES
ISSUE ABOUT REPRESENTATION ON
THE COMMITTEE.
AND SO THERE HASN'T BEEN AN AN
IDENTIFIABLE.
NUMBER BUT THERE IS A DISCUSSION
THAT THERE WILL BE AMENDMENTS TO
THE WORKING GROUP I'M NOT
MEMBERS OF THE VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WILL BE ON
THE COMMITTEE YES SO SO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK.
IT DIDN'T LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE THAT
COULD BECOME WE CAN DECIDE WHO
CAN PARTICIPATE IN THAT AND ARE
WORKING.
COUNTY WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE INCLUDED IN A WORKING
OUTSIDE AS IT DIRECTLY AFFECTS
THEIR PROFESSION
ABSOLUTELY AND I'M.
OBVIOUSLY I WAS A FORMER
TEACHER SO I'M IF SOMETHING WAS
HAPPENING TO MY JOB I WOULD BE.
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
SO I I HAVE NEVER BEEN OPPOSED
TO THAT I THINK THAT'S THAT WAS
THE PURPOSE OF NOT LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF OF MEMBERS IN THE
WORKING GROUP. AND ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
ASSIMILATE AMENDMENTS WHERE IT
SITS BEHIND. THE AD IN THE
TIMELINE SO THAT. WE HAVE A LOT
OF BILLS TODAY.
NEXT AND YOU'RE NOT DONE YET.
I DO AS WELL GOING TO CLOSE
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO FOR
OPERATIONS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND.
WEBER AYE WEBER AYE.
GLOBAL.
FOUR VOTES THE BILL IS OUT. OF
THANK YOU.
WELL IF. I WAS EVER GOING TO
MOVE A FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE WHICH IS AB THREE ZERO
NINE SIX THIS IS YOUR LAST EVERY
THREE BILLS.
THAT I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
DOCTOR WEBER THEN I'M MR CHU
PATIENTLY AND THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OFFERS I'D LIKE
TO THINK THAT CHAIR IN HIS
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE TO IMPROVE THE
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL. I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AYE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
INTERESTED IN THIS LEGISLATION
TODAY I AM PRESENTING A. B.
THIRTY NINETY SIX. A BILL THAT
STREAMLINES ACCESS TO THE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT CARD FOR
STARK.
BY MAKING THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ONLINE AND AVAILABLE
TO BE PRINTED IF DESIRED.
CURRENTLY SCHOOL AND DISTRICT
LEVEL STAFF ANNUAL TO COMPLETE
THE STARK THE FINGER PLAN FOR
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT S. P. S. A
LOCAL EDUCATION.
AGENCY LDA PLAN TO THE AND THE
LOCAL CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN THE EL CAP.
FEDERAL TITLE ONE REPORTS CIVIL
RIGHTS DATA COLLECTION AMONG
THOUSANDS OF OTHER REPORTS
REQUIRED FOR STATE AND FEDERAL
PURPOSES. A. B. THIRTY NINETY
SIX CREATES A MORE ALIGNED
REPORTING SYSTEM FOR THE START
AS WELL AS THE ONE STOP RESOURCE
FOR PARENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
ACCESS INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
SCHOOLS.
THE BILL WILL STREAMLINED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BY
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
TO DEVELOPING ANNUALLY COMPLETE
A STARK FOR EACH SCHOOL AND MAKE
THE STARK AVAILABLE ONLINE%
INSTEAD OF REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ANNUALLY COMPLETE
THE STARK AS A SEPARATE REPORT.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE THE
SPONSORS REPRESENTATIVES FOR MY
BILL ELIZABETH SHEPARD
COORDINATOR OF COMPLIANCE FOR
THE FOLSOM CORDOVA UNIFIED.
SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE.
AND THE HERE REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND SOOTHING AND
BECAUSE ON THESE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL. QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF AYE MELISSA SHEPHARD AND
SERVICE THE COURT DATE OF
COMPLAINTS IN A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINETY SIX.
IN NINETEEN NINETY WHEN I
STARTED MY CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
FORTY TO BECOME A TEACHER I
NEVER IMAGINED THAT WE WOULD BE
SITTING HERE TODAY TO IMPROVE
THE TRANSPARENCY TO PROVIDE
STUDENT INFORMATION TO PARENTS.
AND COMMUNITIES WE SERVE BASED
ON THE PROFOUND WORK THE VARIOUS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LIKE YOURSELF
HAVE DONE IN THE PAST OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS.
TODAY I AM HERE TO EXPRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF WORKING WITH ALL
OF OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS TO
BE TO BE BETTER COLLECT TO
BETTER COLLABORATE. IN
COOPERATION FOR STUDENT AND
SCHOOL DATA TWO MORE
MEANINGFULLY PASSED TO PARENTS
TEACHERS AND OTHER. COMMITTEE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA HAS PREVIOUSLY
ENGAGED IN A SIMILAR EFFORT WHEN
OUR STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WAS ABLE TO.
TO WORK WITH.
I EP INDIVIDUALS WITH EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
TO.
TO UPLOAD INFORMATION FROM OUR
STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEMS
AS A RESULT THIS ALLOWED SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND OTHER
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO SPEND MORE
TIME WORKING WITH STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND INSTEAD OF DUPLICATING DATA
TO PAPERWORK.
THIS BILL IF PASSED WOULD DO THE
SAME THING FOR DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS SITE ADMINISTRATORS SUCH
AS OUR PRINCIPLES. IT WOULD
ALLOW US MORE TIME TO BETTER
SUPPORT TEACHERS AND STAFF
MEMBERS IN THE IMPROVEMENT OF
OUR INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES. AND
DIRECT START SERVICES TO
STUDENTS.
THIS BILL IS ALSO GREAT FOR
STUDENTS BECAUSE IN.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS AMERICA CALIFORNIA IS TO
INCREASE PARENT ENGAGEMENT.
AN ACTIVE. AND INCREASE ACTIVE
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
PARENTS
AND TRANSPARENCY INCONSISTENCY
OF INFORMATION IS THE FIRST
MOVEMENT TO BUILD TRUST AND
TRUST BUILDS.
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION FROM
PARENTS.
THIS ENHANCEMENT OF AN ONLINE
STARK WILL FACILITATE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AS THERE
WOULD BE COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION EXCEPT ACCESSIBLE IN
ONE PLACE.
PLEASE AUTONOMOUS.
COMPLEMENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD FOR QUICK
ONLINE ACCESS TO ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR BOTH SCHOOL DISTRICT
REPORTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUE BANG ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TRUCKS
AND CO SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
THE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT
CARD WITH ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AS PART OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
THE LAST DECADE AND ESPECIALLY
SINCE THE ADOPTION OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IN THE
SCHOOL DASHBOARD. STARK HAS
BECOME A RELIC OF THE PAST
PERSONAL LONGER REFERRING TO
START TO SEE OTHER SCHOOLS ARE
DOING.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND HAS UPDATED THE
SITE TEMPLATE WHICH I'VE HANDED
OUT TO YOU ABOUT SEVENTEEN PAGES
LONG. TOLD CLIMATE TO LCF HAVE
HOWEVER DUE TO OUTDATED
REQUIREMENTS TO START REMAINS.
ARM A PAPER COPY OR CAN BE
UPLOADED ONLINE AS A PDF
COMPOSING OF SEVENTEEN PAGES OR
MORE.
AND IS NOT USER FRIENDLY AS IT
WAS INTENDED A FOR ITS AUDIENCE
PARTICULARLY PARENTS.
AB THIRTY NINETY SIX WITH
STREAMLINED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE START BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO ANNUALLY
COMPLETISTS ARC FOR EVERY PUBLIC
SCHOOL. AND MAKE THE STARK'S
AVAILABLE ONLINE I'VE ALSO
HANDED OUT.
A MOCKUP OF THE STARK ONLINE
BUT WHAT THE* WOULD LOOK
ONLINE. AND PARENTS WOULD BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT ONE DATA ELEMENT
AT A TIME OR EXPAND ALSO ACTED
ON WOMEN'S.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THEM TO SEE
THE ENTIRE SOCK REPORT IN ONE
LUCK.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD ALSO MAKE
STARK AVAILABLE AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS APPLICATION
AND WHICH HAS FIVE THOUSAND
CURRENT USERS SO PARENTS CAN
ACCESS OUR. FROM THEIR
SMARTPHONES AND THEIR TABLETS.
UNDER A A. B. THIRTY NINETY SIX
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD
CONTINUE TO ANNUALLY PUBLICIZED
AVAILABILITY OF SPARKS AND
PROVIDE HARD COPIES TO PARENTS.
AB THIRTY NINETY SIX LEVERAGES
EXISTING DATA COLLECTION SYSTEMS
TO UPDATE IN STREAMLINED THE
START AND BRING IT INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AS MENTIONED CITY BECAUSE
ON IS. THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
ANALYSIS AND MEASUREMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORTING
DIVISION IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL PROGRAM QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
BUT.
MY DAD DOESN'T HAVE TO BE HAVE
ACCESS ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR TO STRONG
SUPPORT.
INDICATE A WATCH ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED IN SUPPORT.
LIKE ANY OTHER SPORTS SEEN ON
ANY OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M WHISKEY AND WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE TOOK IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THE CIRCUS REQUIRED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION AS YOU HEARD BY
PROP NINETY EIGHT AND ONLY
LEGISLATION THAT FURTHERS THE
PURPOSE.
A PROP NINETY EIGHT MAYBE
ENACTED
DELETING CRITICAL WILLIAMS
SCHOOL LEVEL INFORMATION THAT IS
AVAILABLE NO WHERE ELSE WOULD
DETRACT FROM NOT FURTHER THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PURPOSES.
OF NINETY EIGHT THAT WOULD MAKE
THE SPELL UNCONSTITUTIONAL OUR
OPPOSITION STEMS FROM OUR
REPRESENTATION OF A MILLION PLUS
CHILDREN THAT WERE IN SCHOOLS
ONLY IN THE LAST DECADE WITHOUT
THE BARE NECESSITIES FOR AN
EDUCATION.
THAT THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
EQUAL FULLY CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS PROPERLY ASSIGNED
IMPERMANENT SUFFICIENT
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS CURRENT
AND ALIGNED TO STANDARDS AND
FACILITIES THAT ARE SAFE
FUNCTIONAL AND NOT A THREAT TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
THE STATE ADMITTED THAT IT HAD
NO SYSTEM TO INSPECT
DETECT AND MONITOR ON A SYSTEMIC
LEVEL WHETHER IT PROVIDES THESE
VERY BASIC NECESSITIES AND ALL
ITS SCHOOLS. THE CHOSEN
MECHANISM FOR COLLECTING AND
REPORTING THIS DATA IN THE
WILLIAM SETTLEMENT LEGISLATION
WAS THE SLORC WHILE WE SUPPORT
THIS.
DIRECTION OF ELIMINATING
REDUNDANT ACTIVITIES REMOVING
WILLIAMS THE SCHOOL LEVEL
INFORMATION IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
NOW MORE THAN EVER THE STATE IS
RELYING ON THIS INFORMATION FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY UNDER LC FF THE
DASHBOARD REPORTS ON THE
WILLIAMS CONDITIONS. AND THE
GUIDANCE THAT DEPARTMENT PUTS
OUT DIRECTS DISTRICTS TO USE THE
STARK FOR GATHERING AND
REPORTING THIS INFORMATION TO
THE PUBLIC.
WITHOUT THIS CRITICAL DATA WHICH
AFFECTS EVERY SCHOOL AND EVERY
PUBLIC SCHOOL FAMILY WE EXPOSE
OURSELVES AGAIN TO A PRE
WILLIAMS ERA. WITH ALL DISTRICTS
CHECKING THE BOXES IN THE
DASHBOARD THAT THEY HAVE MET THE
STANDARDS FOR DECENT SCHOOLS BUT
WITH NO ACTUAL SCHOOL LEVEL
INFORMATION AT ALL. AND
WIDESPREAD INEQUALITIES
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS BUT THESE ARE THE
REASONS FOR OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA A LEAD TOGETHER
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES FOR ONE OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT BROUGHT
THE WILLIAMS LITIGATION.
TO ADDRESS.
SEVERE INEQUITIES AND AND.
.
LACKING FACILITIES AND
TEXTBOOKS OF FOR MANY OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CHILDREN.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THAT
THE INFORMATION THAT'S REQUIRED
UNDER THE WILLIAM SETTLEMENT IS
NOT SOME KIND OF ADD ON TO
WHAT'S IN THE STARK. IT'S
INFORMATION THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO
ASSESSING HOW WELL SCHOOL IS
DOING ITS JOB.
TO GIVE SOME EXAMPLES IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS BEFORE THE
WILLIAM SETTLEMENT THERE WERE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION SCHOOL
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THE
BOOKS THEY NEEDED FOR HOMEWORK.
ONE POINT NINE MILLION WERE IN
CLASSROOMS THAT WERE TOO HOT OR
COLD.
I ONE POINT SIX MILLION WERE IN
SCHOOLS INFESTED WITH ROACHES
RATS OR MICE AND ONE MILLION
WERE IN SCHOOLS WITH NON WORKING
BATHROOMS ARE CLOSE BATHROOMS.
KIDS CANNOT LEARN UNDER THESE
CONDITIONS THEY ARE EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO THEIR EDUCATION AS
OUR.
TEACHERS OR ANYTHING ELSE YOU
MIGHT THINK OF AS ESSENTIAL TO
EDUCATION.
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
SINCE THEN BECAUSE OF WILLIAM'S
AND BECAUSE OF THE INFORMATION
THAT IS NOW AVAILABLE.
THROUGH.
.
THROUGH THE WILLIAM SETTLEMENT.
AND IN THE STARK IT ALLOWS
FAMILIES AND ADVOCATES TO
MONITOR HOW DISTRICTS ARE DOING
IN MAKING SURE THAT FACILITIES
ARE MAINTAINED AND AND BOOKS AND
MATERIALS ARE AVAILABLE.
WE ARE OPEN TO DISCUSSION AND
HAVE BEGUN DISCUSSIONS.
WITH THE SPONSORS AND THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AS TO HOW THE
INFORMATION GETS PUT INTO THE
SAR. BUT IT NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO
BE IN THE SAR SO THAT PARENTS
AND COMMUNITIES KNOW WHAT THEY
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS OF THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOLS IT CANNOT SIMPLY BE
ELIMINATED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHORS AND SPONSORS ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
OTHER IS NOT AN APPRENTICE
STRONG SENIOR DIRECTOR CHILDREN
NOW.
WE LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE LISTEN
AND THINK.
THANK YOU I DON'T BRING IT BACK.
.
LET ME ASK WHAT ARE YOUR ONLY
CONCERNS THE WILLIAMS LAWSUIT.
YEAH.
THE DETAILS OF THAT ARE REPORTED
AT THE SCHOOL SITE LEVEL AS A
RESULT OF THE WILLIAM SETTLEMENT
AND BETTER AND THE LEGISLATION
MORE DIFFERENT FROM WHAT'S IN
THE.
IN IN THE DASHBOARD SO YES AND
THOSE ARE THE ONLY.
.
THE ONLY THINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT.
CURRENTLY CAN'T POPULATE BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION AT THE STATE LEVEL.
SO I'M SORRY. WHAT INFORMATION
DO THEY NOT COLLECT THEY DON'T
COLLECT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ACTUAL TEXT AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS WHETHER THEY ARE
ALIGNED TO STANDARDS AND WHETHER
THEY ARE CURRENT? LAW THEY DON'T
COLLECT THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEKING.
THAT'S PART OF IT THERE'S OTHER
FACILITIES LIKE IS THE BATHROOMS
OF AND YET RIGHT FACILITY
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THAT'S RIGHT
WELL. IN THE FACILITIES A AREA.
EACH SCHOOL GOES THROUGH BY.
FACILITIES INSPECTION REVIEW OR
SOMETHING. RIGHT. AND SOMETIMES
UP WELL THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
REPORT WHETHER FACILITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN INSPECTED ARE IN FAIR
GOOD OR POOR CONDITION. WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT DOESN'T MATCH
UP TO WHAT THE REPORT IN THE
DASHBOARD AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
IT IS MY STATE HERE COMPORTS
WITH WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT BY
THINK YOU OUGHT TO BE CAREFUL
SOME OF THIS BECAUSE?
I KNOW IN MY OWN CLASSROOM
SETTING.
EVERY CHILD HAD A TEXT BOOK TO
TAKE HOME THAT WE DID BUT IT WAS
A DIFFERENT TEXTBOOK THAT WE
ASSIGN WORK OUT OF A HOME. SO WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE THOSE TEXTBOOKS
AVAILABLE CLASSROOM.
SO I JUST.
BE CAREFUL AYE NICE HOPE WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE CAREFUL ABOUT HOW
THIS IMPACTS LOGISTICS ON THE
GROUND.
ON THE MIGHT OF TO TEXT FOR
CLASS THEY MIGHT KNOW ONLY.
NOT NOT HAVE ENOUGH IN THE
SCHOOLS DISTRICT MIGHT NOT BY
ENOUGH I HAVE TO HAVE AN IN
CLASS AT THAT'S WHERE I REALLY.
BECAME FRUSTRATED IN MY OWN
EXPERIENCE THEY HAD A HOME. YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T BRING YOUR CLUB
BRING YOUR TEXTBOOK TO AYE WELL
YOU KNOW YOU'RE AN EIGHTH GRADE
YOU MIGHT. OKAY SO. IN OUR
CONFERENCE I JUST HOPE WE'RE NOT
GETTING TO PARTICULAR AND
AND WALKING OUT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS TO LEARN RATHER
THAN UNLOCKING THE MEN.
YOU KNOW A ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIR
O'DONNELL WE LOOKED WE TALKED
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES IN THE
SETTLEMENT DISCUSSIONS.
AND SO THE LEGISLATION SAYS A
TEXTBOOK TO USE IN CLASS AND TO
TAKE HOME BUT IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE TWO SETS.
ALL IT WAS A BUT IT WAS ABOUT
ENSURE AND OR. IF IT GOT THAT OR
WORDS PRETTY IMPORTANT.
IT IT WAS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
STUDENTS IN THE LOWEST RESOURCE
SCHOOLS.
HAD MATERIALS TOO USED TO REFER
TO FOR HOMEWORK BECAUSE WE FOUND
THAT THEY COULD NOT. REALLY
ACCEPTABLE POSITION EYES THAT
WERE OR MIGHT BE SOME MEDIA
THINK ABOUT BECAUSE.
ANDERSON AT HOME THAT CAN USE IN
THE CLASSROOM AND YOU NEED TO
USE IN THE CLASSROOM RIGHT. YOU
KNOW.
THAT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OR THAT MR GRAHAM DID ANY OF THE
FOLKS AND SUPPORTS ONE.
RESPOND TO THIS NOTION THAT
THEY'LL BE LASTS A USABLE.
DATA AVAILABLE WITH THIS WITH
THIS CHANGE ARE SEEKING.
I HAVE MY NERVES UNDER CONTROL
YES IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
UNDER PRIORITY ONE IN THE LC F.
F. WE ARE ABLE TO DOCUMENT IN A
NARRATIVE THE EXACT AMOUNT OF.
AFFORD THAT WE PUT IN OUR START
AT THIS TIME.
AND IT WOULD NOT IT WOULD JUST
BE DAY CLEAR INSTRUCTIONS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS AS TO HOW WE DO
THAT WITH OUR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT'S IN THE DISTRICT
LOADED AREA THAT THEY UPLOAD.
SKINNER JEWISH TO COME.
YES I.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE DIRECTION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT IN ITS
TECHNICAL MANUAL.
GUIDANCE ON THE LOCAL
INDICATORS IS TO USE THE STARK
INFORMATION.
SO THE LOCAL INDICATORS WOULD BE
AT THIS POINT ARE DISTRICT LEVEL
REPORTS.
AND THEY'RE NOT SCHOOL LEVEL
DATA WHICH IS WHAT THE WILLIAMS
SETTLEMENT REQUIRES
REMEMBER THE STATE SAID WE DON'T
HAVE SCHOOL LEVEL INFORMATION.
EXCEPT FOR THE STARK AND THAT'S
WHY.
THESE.
METRICS THESE INDICATORS WERE
PUT INTO THE STARK.
SO LET ME ASK YOU QUESTIONS ACT
LIKE. SO SO SHE'S TALKING ABOUT
DISTRICT LEVEL I THINK YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SCHOOL LEVEL.
BONTA IOWA PLASTER OF COSTUMES.
THAT HAD IT BEEN A MONOPOLY HAS
AN IMPACT DOES OKAY.
TO ME THAT'S MY BECAUSE I'M I'M
I'M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT AND
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO BE WRONG.
BUT I WANNA KNOW WHAT TOOLS I
HAVE WHEN I WALK IN THE
CLASSROOM IN THE MORNING.
AND EVEN FOR MY OWN CHILDREN AND
OUTSIDE OF MOSCOW UNDER WILLIAMS
TEACHERS AND STAFF ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE LEARNING
AND TEACHING CONDITIONS. AND
THAT WAS MADE VERY CLEAR IN THE
LEGISLATION AROUND THE UNIFORM
COMPLAINT PROCEDURE.
THANK YOU AYE SO I HOPE YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
IT'S OUR COMMITMENT THANK YOU
KNOW YES I JUST I JUST WANTED TO
OF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
TO OUR ATTENTION.
WE SHOULD NEVER MINIMIZE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WILLIAMS CASE.
IT IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
CASE AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE AT
THE STATE LEVEL OR EVEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WANT TO HAVE TO OPEN
IT UP AGAIN.
BECAUSE IT IS VERY SERIOUS AND
IT REALLY GETS DOWN TO THE MOST
BASIC LEVELS OF INEQUALITY THAT
EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
THAT AND THE OUTCOMES OF THAT.
SO THOSE OF US WHO LIVED THROUGH
THE WILLIAMS CASE AT ONE LEVEL
OF THE OTHER REALIZED JUST HOW
IMPORTANT IS AND.
AND SARK IS REALLY THE ONLY
PLACE WHERE THE DATA IS FOUND.
AND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
SOME I KNOW THAT.
OF OUR BROUGH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILL WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T ELIMINATE WHAT IS
SO EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ABSOLUTELY ABDUCTOR WHERE BUT
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION I KNOW
THAT BOTH OF US ARE EDUCATORS I
SPENT SIXTEEN YEARS IN THE
CLASSROOM. UNDERSTAND THE
WILLIAMS ACT ON THE WILLIAMS AND
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO ELIMINATE
THOUGH THOUGH WILLIAMS
INSPECTIONS THAT THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR.
WHEN I WAS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
WE HAD.
SCHEDULED VISITS AND WE ALSO
HAD I'M I'M SCHEDULED IT'S
VISITS WHEN THEY SO THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ELIMINATED THIS IS
ABOUT THE DATA THAT'S COLLECTED
SO. SO SO WE'RE WORKING ON THE
DATA BUT THE THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE WILLIAMS IS NOT GOING TO
BE ELIMINATED AND THE WILLIAMS
VISIT THAT'S
VERY SEPARATE. SO WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO GET RID OF THE
WILLIAMS.
ACT.
WE'RE STILL VISITING SCHOOLS WE
HAVE GROUPS TEAMS THAT WILL
VISIT THE SCHOOLS AND THE
REPORTING WILL BE DONE IT'S
STILL REQUIRED BY THE COUNTIES
IS STILL REQUIRED BY ALL CFF. SO
WE HAVE ALL THIS REQUIREMENT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILLS TO
STREAMLINE THE INFORMATION AND I
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS WORK
BUT THIS IS ABOUT STREAMLINING
NOT ELIMINATING THE WILLIAMS.
LAWSUIT WHICH IS TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS YEAH I I THINK THE
CONCERN WAS WITH AN UP THE DATA
WOULD BE REFLECTED IN THE STOCK
REPORT RIGHT THAT EVEN THOUGH
THE VISITS OCCUR THE DATA IS
COLLECTED IS IT GOING TO BE ALL
SOLD. OUT REPORTED IN THAT
BECAUSE THERE REALLY IS. VERY
FEW OTHER PLACES ARE NOT PLEASE
REALLY WHERE YOU CAN FIND THE
REPORT FROM THE FROM THE
WILLIAMS INVESTIGATIONS AT THE
CURRENT SCHOOLS SO I KNOW YOU
WORK ON IT SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR WEBER GREAT UP THANK
YOU YOU KNOW LAWSUITS DATA ALL
YOU KNOW I GET AT THE SAME TIME
STILL REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THIS REFLECTS WHAT'S GOING ON ON
THE GROUND.
IN THE CLASSROOM THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE THE CLASS AND THE
TEACHER EXPERIENCE THE CLASSROOM
SO THAT WE CAN ALL CAN SUCCEED.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I SEE NO FURTHER COMMENTS I DO
WE HAVE A MOTION THAT WE DID.
SO MOVE.
IF THE MOVE AND SECONDED BY
MISTER STEINORTH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AS THE
MOTION.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE JEFF
AND MATT DOCTOR WEBER IS
GOING TO GO AND THEN.
CHIU.
LOOK SO HAPPY OUT THERE IS NEXT
AFTER DOCTOR WEBER.
OF FOR ALLOWING US TO GO WE HAVE
SOME INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE BEEN
HERE ALL DAY. AND UP TO THE LONG
HEARING AND THEY HAVE A FLIGHT
TO CATCH SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY. DON'T MISS THAT MOMMY
JUST WERE UP THIS IS A FILE
ITEM.
BALONEY.
S. HERE.
FILE I'M TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
YES TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN AND
I'M TWENTY TWO A. B..
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SEVEN. RIGHT OKAY.
BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANK BOTH CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK TO
IMPROVE THE BILL. AMENDMENTS
WERE LARGELY TECHNICAL IN A
CLARIFY SEVERAL DEFINITIONS AND
WILL MAKE IMPLEMENTATION MUCH
EASIER. UMP AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON HOW
TO KEEP CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHILDREN SAFE
IN SCHOOLS. OF YOUR HAVING A TWO
DOCUMENTS TWO HANDS OUT THE
HANDOUTS PAST YOU AT THIS TIME
OF THAT COME FROM THE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. BUT DECADE
SAW EDUCATORS ADVOCATES AND
LEGISLATORS HAVE WORK TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS WITH WITH
CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS. ARE
EDUCATED WITH DIGNITY AND
SUPPORTIVE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
IN FACT CALIFORNIA WAS ONCE THE
LEADER IN ADDRESSING STUDENTS
WITH CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS
ENACTING LEGISLATION IN NINETEEN
NINETY THE HUGHES APP AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX.
THAT ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
WITH SEVERE BEHAVIOR CHALLENGES
HOWEVER AS A RESPONSE TO THE
RECESSION THE LEGISLATURE'S PART
OF THE TWENTY THIRTEEN BUDGET.
REPEALED A LONG STANDING
REGULATIONS IMPLEMENTING THE
HUGE REAL AND CODIFIED A LIST OF
EMERGENCY INTERVENTIONS
PREVIOUSLY PROHIBITED UNDER THE
HUGHES BILL INCLUDING LOCKED
OCCLUSION AND MECHANICAL
RESTRAINING. FOR ALL LIAM
SCIENCE SIMULTANEOUSLY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BEST
AGAINST REPORTS AND PARENTS
REPORTS DOCUMENT THAT CURRENT
LAW FAILS TO CONTROL THE USE OF
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION IN
SCHOOL. STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
SUFFER TRAUMA AND EMOTIONAL AND
PHYSICAL HARM.
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS TEND
TO BE TARGETED MORE FOR
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION JUST
REPORTS ON A PACK CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
BOYS. AS ANALYSIS POINTS OUT IN
THE LAST MONTH THE US GENERAL
ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE CONFIRMS
THAT THESE TWO POPULATIONS OF
TARGET FISCAL DISCIPLINE.
WE HAVE PASSED OUT TO DOCUMENTS
TO HELP YOU UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT. CALIFORNIA
USED TO BE A LEADER AS I POINTED
OUT.
IN THE BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS
OF THE FIRSTSIDE OF TRIED ONE
HANDED OUT DESCRIBES ELEVEN
POLICIES TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION IN
SCHOOLS. CALIFORNIA SCORED A
THREE OUT OF ELEVEN
DEMONSTRATING THAT WE ARE NO
LONGER A LEADER IN POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTION.
THE OTHER HAND OUT PROVIDES A
BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF ACTIVITIES
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN SCHOOLS
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. THESE
ALL COME FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA INVESTIGATIONS
ALTHOUGH THE NAMES HAVE BEEN
CHANGED.
pBEHAVIOR INTERVENTION OVER
DANGEROUS DISCIPLINARY
TECHNIQUES FOR PROVIDE THE
SCHOOL PROTOCOLS ON THE USE OF
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION IN
SCHOOLS. I WANT TO STRESS THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MINIMUM SAFEGUARDS
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE A
STUDENT AS WELL AND YOU KNOW THE
STUDENT HAS ASTHMA. YOU SHOULD
NOT PUSH THE STUDENT DOWN ON THE
FLOOR IN A PROMO STRAIGHT
RESTRAINT THAT WILL RESTRICT
BREATHING. IF THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY WERE STUDENT BEHAVIOR
PRESENTS AN IMMINENT DANGER OF
SCHOOL PHYSICAL HARM TO IS TO
SELF OR OTHERS THEN THE USE OF
RESTRAINTS PERMISSIBLE. FOR MOST
STUDENTS ARE OTHER WAYS TO
IMPROVE BEHAVIOR AND YOU WILL
HEAR TESTIMONY TO TO CONFIRM
THAT. THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA TO
TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN IS LESLIE
MORRISON THE DIRECTOR OF
INVESTIGATIONS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. AND EDUARDO
MIGUEL MIGUEL FROM PORT FEEL
ACADEMY.
YOU CAN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M LESLIE
MORRISON I'M DIRECTOR OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
AND WE THANK DOCTOR WEBER FOR
AUTHORING AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN.
I STARTED MY CAREER AS A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I HAVE A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN PSYCHIATRIC
NURSING IN A USED TO RUN IN
PATIENT ACUTE PSYCH PROGRAMS
THAT USE RESTRAINT AND
SECLUSION.
I SAW FIRST HAND THE DANGERS AND
TRAUMA THAT RESULTED FROM THESE
PRACTICES.
I NOW ON THE DIVISION OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THAT CONDUCTS INVESTIGATIONS
INTO ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE
NEGLECT AND WE HAVE DONE DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF CASES INVOLVING
INJURIES AND DEATHS. RESULTING
FROM RESTRAIN SECLUSION
INCLUDING INJURIES TO CHILDREN
IN SCHOOLS THEY HAND OUT THE
DOCTOR WEBER MENTION IS JUST A
HANDFUL WE COUNTED ON NEARLY A
THIRTY FIVE CASES THAT WE'VE
DONE. IT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA ALONE. THESE ARE
DANGEROUS PRACTICES THAT CAN
CAUSE INJURY AND DEATH.
AS DOCTOR WEBER SAID THIS BILL
DOES NOT PROHIBIT THE USE OF
RESTRAINTS SECLUSION WE WANT TO
KEEP CHILDREN SAFE AND NOTHING
IN THIS BILL LIMITS ARE
PROHIBITS STAFF FROM USING
RESTRAINT SECLUSION TO STOP
IMMINENTLY DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR.
IT PROVIDES PROTOCOLS TO HELP
GUIDE THE SAFE USE OF RESTRAINTS
SECLUSION IN THE RARE INSTANCE
WHERE IT IS REQUIRED.
IT APPLIES THE SAME STATUTORY
LANGUAGE THAT WE SEE IN OTHER
CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT EXTEND TO
OTHER PLACES WERE RESTRAINED
SECLUSION IS USED INCLUDING
HOSPITALS NURSING HOMES GROUP
HOMES COMMUNITY CENTERS. MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITIES AND STATE
FACILITIES.
IT SETS MINUTE THE BILL SETS
MINIMUM SAFEGUARDS AND
PROTECTIONS FOR WATER KNOWN
DANGEROUS TECHNIQUES BUT IT
DOES-NOT STOP TEACHERS FROM
INTERVENE
TO KEEP A CHILD SAFE.
CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS SERVE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THAT OTHER
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE WHEN THEY'RE
SUBJECTED TO RESTRAIN SECLUSION
AND IT'S ESPECIALLY IN FOR
IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY'RE A PARTICULAR RISK OF
INJURY AND DEATH FROM THE THESE
PRACTICES.
AS DOCTOR WEBER MENTION
CALIFORNIA HAS FALLEN BEHIND
WHERE WE WILL ONCE A LEADER AND
HOW TO HANDLE CHILDREN WITH
CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS. THIS BILL
WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA LAW UP TO
DATE WITH THE REFORMS ENACTED BY
DOZENS OF OTHER STATES AND THAT
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
GUIDELINES. AND THAT'S THE OTHER
HAND OF THE DOCTOR WEBER.
PROVIDED YOU.
IT'S TIME TO MEET THESE MINIMUM
NATIONAL STANDARDS AND BRING
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH
STANDARDS ADOPTED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. IT'S TIME TO PROVIDE
CHILDREN WITH THE SAME
PROTECTIONS EVERYONE ELSE.
EXPOSED TO THESE POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS PRACTICES RECEIVE
LIKELY CERTAINLY SUMMERS I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'M AVAILABLE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU AND KEEP IT TWO MINUTES
PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MINERS DOCTOR
EVER MIGUEL AND I'M BOARD
CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS IN A
DOCTOR OF EDUCATION. HOW THE
FOODS OF SERVING QUE TO TWENTY
TWO STUDENTS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AS A FOUNDER AND PRINCIPAL FOR
FEW PREPARATORY?
A NONPUBLIC SCHOOL WITH CAMPUSES
AN ORANGE AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTIES.
WE SERVE OVER THIRTY DIFFERENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO RELY ON US
TO EDUCATE UP TO HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE STUDENTS AT A TIME. WAS
SEVERE CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS.
MY NATIONAL TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE INCLUDED USING
SECLUSION ROOM DEMONSTRATES AS
PART OF A STRATEGY.
I SAW FIRST HAND HOW DANGEROUS
AND TERM DRAMATIC THESE
TECHNIQUES ARE IN BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS. AND KEEPING KIDS
SAFE.
NOW HAVING EDUCATED STUDENTS
WITHOUT THE USE OF SUCH
EMOTIONALLY AND PHYSICALLY
HARMFUL TECHNIQUES FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AND PROVING IT WORKS I CAN
CONFIDENTLY SAY THAT THERE'S A
BETTER WAY. A MORE HUMANE WAY
FOR STUDENTS TO THRIVE BEYOND
RESTRAINT.
THE BEHAVIOR THAT WE SEE A POOR
BUREAU WHO STUDENT BITING
THEMSELVES UNTIL SEVERE BLEEDING
OCCURS RECLINED SUTURES.
PUNCHING THEMSELVES IN THE PLACE
UNTIL THEY BLEED OR BONES ARE
BROKEN.
PULLING THEIR HAIR OUT OF THEIR
HEAD SMEARING FECES ATTEMPTED
HE'D HARMFUL ITEMS INCLUDING
FECES.
PROPERTY DESTRUCTION URINATING
STRIPPING NAKED JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
THERE'S ALMOST ALWAYS REPEAT
BEHAVIORS AT A PREDICTABLE AND
CAN BE ANTICIPATED AS A STUDENTS
REACTION TO CERTAIN STIMULI.
THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS THAT
ARE REFERRED TO US HAVE
HISTORIES OF BEING RESTRAINED.
IN SOME CASES SEVERAL TIMES PER
DAY AND OVER THIRTY TIMES PER
MONTH.
OUR FOCUS IS TO ALLOW OUR
STUDENTS TO LEARN AND GROW.
WE DO THIS WITHOUT RESTRAINT OR
SECLUSION BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
WORK IT DOESN'T TEACH BUT IT
DOES INJURE AND IT DOES KILL.
THIS BILL TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
WHAT NO STUDENT SHOULD HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE IN A LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. WHICH INCLUDES
STUDENTS BEING RESTRAINED OR
SECLUDED WHERE THE RISK OF
INJURY OR DEATH IS SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASED. AB TWO SIX FIVE SEVEN
PROMOTES POSITIVE ACCOUNTABLE
LEARNING AND PROHIBITS STUDENTS
FROM BEING HELD DOWN AND
DANGEROUS POSITIONS BEING
ISOLATED AND UNOBSERVED.
RESTRAINED BY MULTIPLE PEOPLE
AND FOR LONG PERIODS IN AN
EFFORT TO PUNISH CHILDREN COLORS
CHILDREN EXTORT CHILDREN OR AS A
MEANS OF CONVENIENCE.
THE BILL RECOGNIZES EMERGENCY
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS RESTRAINT
AND SECLUSION MAY BE NEEDED AND
DOES NOT PREVENT STAFF FROM
USING STRAIGHT OR SECLUSION WHEN
THE RISK OF INJURY OR DEATH IS
IMMINENT.
EMERGENCY INTERVENTION SHOULD
ONLY BE UTILIZED ALL
INTERVENTION SPILL AND ONLY IN
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION IS MY HOPE
THAT YOU'LL SUPPORT THANK YOU
OTHERS IS FOR ME COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE GOOD EVENING
MARRIED THERE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS AND
WHERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION.
GOOD EVENING TERRACE A MUCH OUT
OF HER COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CRITICS CALIFORNIA'S A
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN MENTAL
HEALTH CLIENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GEN JAHMAL A CALIFORNIA LAND TO
JOHN FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
AS AMENDED.
JOURNALISTS MEMBER CALIFORNIA'S
US STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
LONGTIME TEACHER AND PARENT OF
YOUNG ADULT WITH AUTISM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERIC RATHER STAY COUNSELING
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
COUNCILS IN SUPPORT.
CRISES ABOVE AVERAGE THAT WITH
EDUCATE ADVOCATE EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIA AND A PARENT OF A
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD IN SUPPORT.
WENDY KIEDY PARENT OF A CHILD
WITH AUTISM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
GOV OR.
US CENTER BORRERO CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THIS BILL A
WE HAVE CONCERNS AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
WE ONLY RECENTLY RAISE THE
SCOOBIES CONCERNS SO ALL I
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WILLING TO
ADDRESS THEM.
OUR CONCERNS INVOLVED A STAFF
PERSON THAT'S FORM BEHAVIOR
RESTRAINTBEING PRESIDENT THE
MEETING THANK YOU THANK YOU
GREAT. OTHER SPREE BOXING NO
OTHER OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND THIS
BILL BECAUSE I'M.
YOU KNOW ME DOCTOR WEBER I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THINGS LIKE THIS
MY CONCERN IS THAT WE TRY AND
MICROMANAGE SCHOOL SITES.
FROM SACRAMENTO DOES ME THAT
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET STAFF TRAIN.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IS.
BE PROACTIVE.
AND NOT REACT TO NOT PUNISH KIDS
BY RESTRAINT PUNISHED BUT I
DON'T WANT TO.
TIED DOWN ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
BUT I COME FROM THE REAL WORLD
QUOTE UNQUOTE WHERE I SEE KIDS
GET IN FIGHTS.
RIGHT AT LUNCH TIME GIRLS OF THE
WORST BY THE WAY RAMEN LEGAL AND
IT MAY HAVE A GO AT IT.
THEM THIS ADVICE IS TRUE.
AND THE THE MOTIONS ARE
AND RIGHT AND.
AND SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND FROM
FROM SOMEONE WHO WORKS AT A
SCHOOL WHY THIS IS A GOOD IDEA
TO GET. I GET THAT I DON'T WANT
SOMEONE.
GIVE A HAND CUPPED ANYTHING FOR
FOR HOURS FOR PUNISHMENT I MEAN
LIKE THAT. I'M MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
COOL SAYS SOME AT A SCHOOL SITES
ABILITY TO INTERVENE. AND
CONTROL SITUATION
THEN THE PUNISHMENT'S ON THE
PUNISH SITE PICKED UP IS THAT
NOT WHAT ABOUT. I'M MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INTERVENTION
YOU GOT TWO KIDS GOING AT IT.
YOU KNOW YOU GOT.
SEVERAL THOUSAND KIDS OUT THERE
AND LUNCH TIME YOU'VE GOTTA STOP
THE SITUATION QUICKLY BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO GROW IF YOU DON'T.
IF YOU DON'T REACT.
THAT MAYBE A BIGGER PROBLEM
HERE YOU JUST CAN'T SIT THERE
WATCH KIDS FIGHT AND IS THIS
GOING TO HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT.
ON OUR STEPS WILLINGNESS AND
ABILITY TO INTERACT WITH KIDS
INTO CONTROL SITUATIONS THAT
MIGHT ALREADY. BE OUT OF HAND.
I'M NOT SURE IF WE'RE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT FIGHTS AND AT THE
PLAYGROUND AT LUNCH TIME THOSE
THINGS MAY HAPPEN IN AND
OFTENTIMES THERE OF SECURITY
FOLKS THAT IT THERE. TO HANDLE
THOSE PARTICULAR ISSUES AND TO
AND TO AND TO ENGAGE IT WE'RE
PROBABLY TALKING MORE IN TERMS
OF STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
WEBER. OF WHO BASICALLY ARE A
AND CLASSROOMS WHO NEED VARIOUS
KINDS OF ACTIVITIES DONE TO KEEP
THEM FROM.
BASICALLY HURTING THEMSELVES OR
HURTING SOMEONE ELSE AND SO IT'S
A BUT AS POINTED OUT. BUT WE'RE
NOT TAKING AWAY THE ABILITY TO
DO RESTRAINTS IF THAT'S
NECESSARY OUGHT TO BASICALLY
ENGAGE AT THAT LEVEL BUT WE'RE
SAYING THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
AS A. EDUCATOR IN A CLASSROOM
AND ANNA SCHOOL SIDE IF YOU'RE
OUT IN THE SCHOOL SITE THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
THAT YOU CAN USE TO NOT HAVE TO
RESTRAIN CHILDREN. TO TIE THEM
DOWN INTO TO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND I THINK OUR EXPERT
WITNESS HERE WHO HAS A SCHOOL
WHO'S DEALT WITH THOSE. CHILDREN
AND IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO
THE QUESTION OF HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS THAT
WE NEED TO DO IT. YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE SAD THINGS OFTEN TO
HAPPENINGS IS AS WE SAY DO WE
REALLY NEED TO DO THIS WHAT WE
REALLY DO BECAUSE.
IF OFTENTIMES WE HAVE BECOME LAX
IN IT WHEN WE MOVED AWAY FROM
THE ONE WE DID HAVE RESOURCES
HOPEFULLY TO PROBABLY TO TRAIN
PEOPLE. AND AS A RESULT WHEN YOU
DON'T SAY THINGS AND YOU HAVE
NEW POPULATION THE PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE SCHOOLS TO WORK.
YOU HAVEN'T GIVEN THEM THE
INFORMATION AND THE AND THE
GUIDELINES IN THE THINGS THAT
THEY NEED. SO THEREFORE THINGS
GO AWRY.
THEN WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH THE
SITUATION SOMETHING HORRIBLE
HAPPENS.
THEN PEOPLE COME UP TO US AND
ASK US WHY IS IT SOME CHILD DIED
ON A CAMPUS WIDE TO SOME KID WAS
HOSPITALIZED Y. THE SOME. HERE
HAVE THEIR BACK BROKEN OR
SOMETHING FROM PEOPLE SITTING ON
THEM AND TRYING TO HOLD THEM ON
THE GROUND I MEAN WIPE Y.
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT PROVIDED A
POSITIVE. APPROACH TO IT AFFRONT
PREVENTING RATHER THAN WAITING
TO AFTER THE FACT OF TRY TO CURE
SOMETHING.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT.
AND HELL IF YOU WILL BE VERY
WHEN HIS COMMENTS BECAUSE YOU IN
A SAVINGS DON'T DON'T YOU HAVE A
PARTICULAR.
DO CHIU SYRUP PARTICULAR.
A PARTICULAR PART OUR STUDENT
POPULATION AT YOUR SCHOOL SITE
OR YOU HAVE.
ALL TYPES OF STUDENTS IN YOUR
SCHOOL. WE SERVE ARM ALL THE WAY
FROM SEVERELY DISABLED TO MODERN
DESIGN SO SIMILAR QUESTION REACH
ON I'M GONNA I'M GONNA GET THAT
YOU TALK WITH. THAT'S MY CONCERN
IS I I THINK.
IT SEEMS THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENT IP SIX ADDRESS.
AND I GET I GET THAT.
BUT I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
STUDENTS WITHOUT IP STUDENTS
THAT ARE NOT SPECIAL NEEDS IT
SEEMS PRETTY BROAD. AND I DON'T
WANT AGAIN ANY STUDENT TO BE
RESTRAINED.
ESPECIALLY FOR PUNISHMENT. OF
MY CONCERNS WERE TALKING WE SEEM
TO BE FOCUSING ON. A YOU KNOW
STE JUST SOME OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION AND YET IF THE BILL
APPLIES TO ALL OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION.
IF I COULD JUST JUMP IN THIS
BILL REALLY DOES NOT ALLOW A
DOES NOT PROHIBIT A TEACHERS
FROM JUMPING IN TO BREAK UP THE
KIND OF A FIGHT THAT YOU WOULD.
YOU'RE DESCRIBING IT DOESN'T
STOP A TEACHER FROM GRABBING A
FIVE YEAR OLD IS RUNNING INTO
TRAFFIC WHAT IT DOES STOP IS
USING PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS
TECHNIQUES THAT WE KNOW ENSURING
KILL THAT ARE PROHIBITED
EVERYPLACE ALL TO RESTRAIN
SECLUSION ARE USED.
SO.
IT DOESN'T PROHIBIT THE KIND OF.
JUST IT YOU KNOW INCIDENTS THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING.
.
PART OF THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
AN AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF CASES WHERE KIDS TO
RESTRAIN SECLUDED NOT BECAUSE
THEY POSE AN IMAGE IMMINENT RISK
BECAUSE. THEY WOULDN'T STAY
SEATED IN THEIR CHAIR FOR AN
HOUR DURING.
A CLASSROOM EXERCISE ON THAT
THAT THAT'S WHAT I GET I GET I
GET THAT COMPONENT I'M JUST
WORRIED BOUT THE MUCH BROADER
PICTURE APPROACHED THIS BILL HAS
TODAY. SO THIS BILL AGAIN DOES
NOT PREVENT TEACHERS FROM
INTERVENING ON IT JUST PROHIBITS
PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS PRACTICES
AND IT REQUIRES THAT THE CHILD'S
BEHAVIOR POSE A RISK BEFORE. A
TEACHER INTERVENE.
AND THE REASON WHY IT'S NOT JUST
A SPECIAL EDUCATION BILL AS WE
THINK THAT THESE PROTECTIONS
SHOULD APPLY TO ALL STUDENTS. ON
DATA COLLECTED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SHOWS
THAT GENERAL ED STUDENTS ARE
EXPOSED TO THESE PRACTICES JUST
AS MUCH AS SPECIAL ED STUDENTS
ARE LEAST EXPOSED.
WE CERTAINLY KNOW SOME OF THE
DATA SHOWS THAT SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS ARE EXPOSED MUCH MORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ART DOT
CONTINUED SAYS I JUST TODAY I'M
NOT CONVINCED.
THAT I'M WORRIED THAT THIS IS
TOO BROAD.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHEN IS AN IEP
AND YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT ONLY
STUDENTS OF A YOU KNOW. OF UP
ONLY A SPECIFIC PART ARE STERN
POPULATION OR SCHOOL I THINK.
THIS IS A BETTER FIT. I WONDER
IF IT'S THE BEST FIT.
FOR FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION AND AGAIN.
LET ME CLARIFY I DON'T WANT
ANYONE RESTRAINT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME. AND WHEN YOU HAVE STUDENTS
THAT ARE VIOLENT VIOLENT
SITUATION INTERACTIONS SAID YOU
JUST HAVE TO HAVE SOME ABILITY.
TO TO TO AND THAT.
THAT.
INTERACTION.
THAT THANK YOU. AND I THINK THE
IN THE BILL ALLOWS THAT TO
HAPPEN YOU KNOW BUT OFTENTIMES A
RESTRAINT TO USE NOT BECAUSE A
PERSON IS OF A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR SOMEONE ELSE. YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN ITS SCHOOLS WENT
BITES OF OCCURRED AND AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER ACTUALLY GOT
HIM STOP THE FIGHT.
ó I DIDN'T KNOW ANYBODY YES
I'D NEVER GO ANYBODY ON THE
GROUND. LOW BUT THEY WERE
FIGHTING IN NEARBY ACT LIKE THEY
WAS SCARED SO I WENT BROKE THEM
UP.
YOU KNOW OF.
YOU KNOW BUT OUT AT THE SAME
TIME.
YOU KNOW I'VE ALSO SEEN PEOPLE
TAKE KIDS IMPLEMENTED BROWN
BECAUSE A KID KEPT TOPONYMIC
COULDN'T STOP HIM FROM TALKING.
YOU KNOW THEY HAD TO GET THE
LAST WORD IN AND THEY WERE
RUNNING THEIR MOUTH AND THE
TEACHER GOT UPSET TO INCLUDE KID
AGAINST A WALL AND THURMOND
GROUNDED SAT ON A. AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS OFTENTIMES OF
THE PERSON TO STUDENT WASN'T A
DANGER TO.
BUT ANYBODY ELSE AND THEY JUST
RUN INTO MY HOUSE AND SOMETIMES
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY THEY KNOW
HOW TO STOP OF ONE RESTRAIN
WHATEVER IT WAS. SO IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE FACT THAT THE PERSON
IS THAT IS IS.
ALL IS IS HURTING THEMSELVES OF
SOMEONE ELSE'S THAT THIS IS A
STRATEGY THAT SHOULD NOT BE USED
UNLESS THERE IS A SITUATION OF
DANGER. AND YOU'RE TO PREVENT
SOMETHING FROM HER HAPPENING
THAT'S THEIR.
YOU KNOW WE AS A SOCIETY HAVE
TO BEGIN TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT IT'S
OFTENTIMES THERE'S
DISPROPORTIONATE TREATMENT AND
WE RECOGNIZE THAT IN THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
FEDERAL REPORTS HAVE SHOWN THAT
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE THROWN ON THE
GROUND AND TO BE. THE ONLY GETS
WALL SO IT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE US
WHEN WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY BECOME ADULTS.
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
THOSE LEVELS OF RESTRAINTS AND
AND ACTIVITIES THAT IT THERE AND
OFFICE ALSO THERE MORE OFTEN
LIKELY TO BE CLASSIFIED A
SPECIAL LIVE WHY BECAUSE
BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS. NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE OF ACADEMIC
PROBLEMS BUT BECAUSE OF BEHAVIOR
PROBLEMS SO IF WE'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THAT BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THIS EARLY IN LIFE WE HAVE TO
START IN THE SCHOOLS AND MAKE
THIS A PART OF IT. AND THE
HUGHES BILL THAT PASSED IN
NINETEEN NINETY WAS REALLY ONE
OF THE FIRST STEPS TOWARD US
RECOGNIZING THE FACT THAT WE
COULD DO SOMETHING BETTER.
IN THE STATE AND YOU LOOK AT
THE LIST AND YOU SEE WHERE ALL
THE STATES ARE WHO USING THE
VARIOUS KINDS OF RESTRAINTS AND
WHO HAVE CERTAIN POLICIES IN
PLACE. CALIFORNIA'S AT THE
BOTTOM OF WE HAVE GIVEN UP OUR
PLACE WHAT WE ONCE WERE THE
PREMIER PLACE IN TERMS OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND MEETING
THE NEEDS OF KIDS AND WE HAVE TO
BEGIN TO ONCE AGAIN. GO BACK TO
THAT AND REBUILD IT AND
DISABILITY RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
RECOGNIZES OF.
CLEARLY THAT IT HAPPENED
SIGNIFICANTLY BUT KIDS WOULD
SPECIALLY BUT ALSO SOMETIMES FOR
OTHERS BUT IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
THE RIGHT TO DO RESTRAINTS IF IT
SMELLS LIKE YOU ANY ANY OTHERS
FROM THE COMMITTEE WISH TO CALL.
TO KILEY OUT SO I'M STRUGGLING
WITH THE CHILD LIKE CHARM FROM
THIS A LITTLE BIT TOO I IT IT
SEEMS THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS A
GENERAL PRINCIPLE HERE THAT
WE'RE ALL. AGREEING ON AND
THAT'S THE RESTRAINTS ARE
SECLUSION.
SHOULD NOT BE USED EXCEPT.
YOU KNOW IN IN EXIT
HE'S OVER THERE IS AN EMERGENCY
I DON'T HAVE A FAIRLY
COMPREHENSIVE SORT OF MENU OF.
POLICY LIMITATIONS
THAT.
APPEAR TO BE A COMEDY VARYING
DEGREES IN DIFFERENT STATES I'M
SPENT WONDERING WHERE THESE
PARTICULAR.
POLICY LIMITATIONS
COME FROM AND WHY I'M HAVING
TROUBLE CAN IT JUDGING OKAY I
DID ARE THESE
DOZEN OR HOWEVER MANY THERE ARE
IN THIS BILL.
THE RIGHT ONES THAT WE WON'T
HAVE IN PLACE IN ORDER TO.
CHANGE PRACTICE IN A POSITIVE
WAY SO THIS POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS CAME THAT FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THEY ISSUED A GUIDANCE A FIFTEEN
RECOMMENDED.
GUIDELINES THAT STATES SHOULD
IMPLEMENT AND SO WE.
THEN LOOKED AT THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
ANALYSIS OF HOW EVERY STATE IS
DOING AND PUT IT TOGETHER A
CHART FORM SAID THESE ARE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ABOUT
WHAT SCHOOLS. A STATE SHOULD
ADOPT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT.
MR THEM.
CLAIMS CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE.
.
CONSTERNATION AND AND PEOPLE
WHO'VE RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
BALANCE I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS MOVING
IN THE DIRECTION OF WHERE REALLY
THE SECTORS HAVE BEEN GOING TO
SAY THAT.
WE SHOULD BE USING RESTRAINT ON
THEIR KIDS.
EVEN FOR KIDS WHO HAVE SEVERE
NEEDS THAT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
TO REDIRECT BEHAVIOR.
AND AND THAT UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
OUT RESTRAINT HAS BEEN RELIED
UPON THERE HAVE BEEN SERIOUS
INCIDENTS AND THAT HAVE LED TO
SERIOUS HERE INJURY. AND TRAUMA.
FOR ME AND SO WHILE WE ALWAYS
STRUGGLE HOW TO INTERVENE IN AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION I THINK WE
HAVE TO SAY. THAT.
WE WANT TO LIMIT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE ASKING
SOMEONE TO PUT THEIR HANDS ON
SOME.
AS A WAY OF REDIRECTING.
BEHAVIOR THAT IS EITHER TYPICAL
BEHAVIOR FOR THAT STUDENT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THAT STUDENTS
LEVEL OF.
PRACTICE BEHAVIOR FUNCTION IS
BUT WE WE WHEN WE PUT OUR HANDS
ON KIDS AND
I IF THERE ISN'T ONE ALREADY
MISS CHARO MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE
THIS.
THANK YOU.
TO MOVE TO SECOND IT UP PLEASE
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS
AND YOUR CONCERNS AND AS POINTED
OUT THESE ARE. YOU KNOW THESE
ARE GUIDELINES THAT HAVE COME
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS
TO HOW WE SHOULD BE ACTING IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND WHAT STATES HAVE
ADOPTED. AND WHERE WE STAND YOU
KNOW IN THIS IN THIS BUILDING WE
HAVE PASSED AN AWFUL LOT OF.
BILLS TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND HELP LOOK IT WOULD JUST PASS
ONE A DAY IN TERMS OF COUNSELING
IN MENTAL HEALTH AND ALL THE
THINGS WE WANT TO DO IN OUR
SCHOOLS. AND HOW OUR KIDS ARE
SUFFERING FROM TRAUMA AND THAT'S
SO TRUE THE LAST THING WE WANT
TO DO IS TO CREATE MORE TRAUMA
OR DIDN'T ACCENTUATE THE TRAUMA
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AYE VOTE. OF FOR IT AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SEVEN.
RETHINKING THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL NO.
O'DONNELL NO KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING. KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE WEBER
AYE.
BILLS THREE VOTES IT IS ON CALL.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO.
.
MISTER CHIU. THAT'S AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
.
SEE.
PLEASE PROCEED TOOK A VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE. REQUIRES
ALL HIGH SCHOOL TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON COLLEGE OPTIONS
CREEK SCHOOL OPTIONS AND PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE FINANCIAL AID. TO
EVERY STUDENT AT LEAST ONCE TO
INTEGRATE NIGHT TO TWELVE. IT
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY TO SCHOOLS
ON HOW THIS INFORMATION COULD BE
PROVIDED. AS STUDY SHOWS THAT.
EDUCATED WORKER EARNS MORE THAN
SEVENTY PERCENT MORE DAN DOES
WAS ONLY A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE.
AND THIS IS ALSO AN INCREASED
DEMAND AND SKILLED WORKERS
A BIG OF VOCATIONAL SCHOOL IS
JUST AN IMPORTANT S. COLLEGE.
BECAUSE COLLEGE IS NOT FOR
EVERYONE LETTING KIDS KNOW THE
OPTION THAT THEY ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM COULDHELP THEM MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS REGARDING TO
YOUR. CAREER PATH HERE WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS ESERVER
THOUGH GUS GARCIA WAS WHO
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
AND DURING THE US GERMISTON US
WAS JUST A BUILDINGS AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M ISABEL GARCIA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE. CTA US SUPPORTS THE
CRITICAL A RULE A CERTIFICATED
COUNSELORSAS THEY PROVIDE
ACADEMIC AND CAREER COUNSELLING
TO GUIDE OUR STUDENTS FOR THEIR
COURSE TAKING TO GRADUATE AND
FOR THEIR POST GRADUATION
INTERESTS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY SCHOOL SITES
LACK THE SUFFICIENT FINDING.
I FOR THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF
COUNSELORS FOR THEIR STUDENT
RATIOS.
SO THIS BILL HELPS FILL IN THE
GAPS OF INFORMATION FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
THE BILL UNDERSCORES.
THE IMPORTANCE OF KNOWLEDGE OF
OF CAREER AND COLLEGE
PREPAREDNESS FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM BUT BUT
ESPECIALLY. IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL.
IN SHORT CTA SUPPORTS THE BILL'S
FOCUS FOR INCREASED ACCESS
TO ACADEMIC CONCURRENT FORMATION
TO BETTER PREPARE STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED AND OUR STATE AND
NATIONAL ECONOMY.
SO WE URGE ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. WE
ARE OUT HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY.
WE WE WE WE'VE BEEN TALKING FOR
MANY MANY YEARS.
THAT.
HIGH SCHOOLS NEED TO GET BACK
TO WHAT THEY USED TO DO. WHICH
WAS PREPARE KIDS FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER.
EVERYTHING FROM THE HOME EC
CLASSES.
TO THE AYE MEMBER OF MY LEARN
TO WRITE WELL BALANCED CHECKBOOK
IN HIGH SCHOOL TO THEIR CTE
COURSES THAT LET YOU WORK WITH
YOUR HANDS AND AND AND REALIZE
THE WORLD OF WORK OUT THERE THAT
THAT DOES INVOLVING UNIVERSITY
SELF. UNHAPPY IS FOR THE BILL
TODAY AND I WOULD URGE
EVERYBODY.
ON THIS COMMITTEE TO ALSO
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS YOU.
INCREASE MORE.
RIDICULOUS EDUCATION CENTER
GRANT FUNDING TO THE KIDS
CONNECTION OF CLASSES.
THAT THIS BILL AIMS TO OUT TO
TELL ABOUT THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES ON SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
THEY WERE HOME.
CAMPBELL IN THEM.
QUESTION THE COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION THE.
CHIU SO IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS
ALREADY IN THE EDUCATION CODE.
A SIMILAR.
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES.
THIS SORT OF INFORMATION BE
SENT OUT ACTUALLY EVERY YEAR.
THIS IS EDUCATION CODE.
FIVE ONE TWO TWO NINE ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS AND WHAT IS
YES I THINK THAT.
REQUIRED
SCHOOL TO SEND OUT A NOTICE TO
THE PARENT.
AND I'D INFORMATION DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
THREE POSSIBLE PORT FORWARD TO
FINANCIAL EIGHT. SO DOES BILL
WILL OF WOULD REQUIRED TO SCHOOL
TO SEND IT DIRECTLY TO THE
STUDENT.
AND ALSO PROVIDES HOME FOR NAY
IF OF FINANCIAL AID ASSISTANCE
INFORMATION.
THANKS ART WE WILL HAVE REAL
GOOD CONTROL. OF WHAT DID
MOVEMENT.
IT HAPPENED IN THEIR HOME SO I
WANT TO STUDENT WHO RECEIVED
THE.
THE STYLE OF THEIR PARENTS TO
RECEIVE.
I SEE SO GOES TO STUDENT RATHER
THAN THE PARENTS AND I HAVE TWO
YOUNG.
NOTICE TO THE PARENTS EVERY
ARTIST KNOWS TO STUDENTS AT
LEAST ONCE.
RIGHT AND THAT AND ALSO WE ADDED
THOUGH DO YOU GET FINANCIAL AID.
THE INFORMATION A SMALL.
OKAY WE DON'T BECAUSE. OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IDEA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
MONTHS OF TRYING TO MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO PROCREATION SPLITS
CULTURAL.
O'DONNELL
KILEY NO KILEY NO KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THREE WISHES.
OLD WE NEED IT IF. WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO DO A REVIEW ON THAT WHAT
I DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
NOW WE DO ALRIGHT LET'S TRY THAT
AGAIN.
O'DONNELL KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND THURMOND YE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD NIGHT.
THE BILL IS ON COME
.
MS ARLEN
EUROPE.
IS.
ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY THIRTY FORTY
EIGHT.
THANKS TO.
MISTER CHAIR AND MR THURMAN FOR
LETTING ME GO IN FRONT AB THIRTY
FORTY EIGHT IN ITS SIMPLEST FORM
SEEKS TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
TO MONITORS TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
CURRENTLY THE MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MUST PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT TEACHER
CREDENTIALS AND COURSE
ASSIGNMENTS TO THEIR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION EVERY FOUR
YEARS.
THROUGH A MANUAL PROCESS IN
THREE SEPARATE DATABASES THIS
INFORMATION IS USED TO IDENTIFY
MISS ASSIGNMENTS OR TEACHERS
WITH THE CREDENTIAL OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASS THAT THEY TEACH.
UNDER THIS BILL THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WOULD BE
ABLE TO SHARE THE DATA THEY
ALREADY HAVE TO FIND POTENTIAL
MISS ASSIGNMENTS.
THEY CAN THEN SEND THESE
POTENTIAL THIS ASSIGNMENTS TO
COUNTIES TO REVIEW WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SINCE THIS PROCESS WOULD BE
AUTOMATED THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR
YEARLY TEACHER MONITORING
INSTEAD OF EVERY FOUR YEARS.
THIS WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO RUN
MORE EFFICIENTLY LEE AND PROVIDE
GREATER OVERSIGHT OF OUR TEACHER
ASSIGNMENTS.
HOWEVER THIS IS A BIG CHANGE
FROM THE CURRENT PROCESS AND
REQUIRES INPUT FROM MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE HELD
MULTIPLE MEETINGS WITH THE
COMMISSION COUNTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TEACHERS. AND MANY
OTHERS TO CREATE A NEW SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND THERE IS STILL WORK
TO BE DONE I'D RITUAL I HAD
ORIGINALLY SET OUT TO STREAMLINE
AND ONEROUS AN OUTDATED PROCESS.
WE HAD A NUMBER OF UP
PRODUCTIVE.
MEETINGS WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO RECREATE THIS.
COMPLICATES THIS PROCESS AS I
UNDERSTAND CERTAIN CHARTER
SCHOOL TEACHERS ARE REQUIRED TO
HOLD CREDENTIALS ARE READY BUT
THEIR INCLUSION IN THIS KNEW
MONITORING PROCESS IS SOMETHING
WE COULD OF CONSIDERED ONCE THE
NEW. SYSTEM WISE AND PLACE
HOWEVER I WILL ACCEPT THIS AND
OTHER AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY
THE COMMITTEE AND WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR ALL THEIR WORK.
ON THIS BILL I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL THOSE INVOLVED
TO CONSOLIDATE THE CREDENTIAL
MONITORING INTO ONE SYSTEM AND I
HAVE WITH ME HERE IN SUPPORT
JOSH WHAT SPARKS FROM THE
COMMISSION ON. TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS MAYBE STRUCTURE SPEAKS
AND I REPRESENT THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
I WILL TRAVESTY BRIEF THIS IS
AN EQUITY ISSUE.
EFFECTIVE AND TRANSPARENT
ASSIGNMENT MONITORING HELPS
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS GET AN
EFFECTIVE IN QUALIFY TEACHER.
SO I'LL ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
OTHER ISN'T SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HOPE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ISABEL
GARCIA.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
WE ARE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
IN RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORED THE
SPONSOR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING DATA PRIVACY
FOR TEACHERS. AND INCLUDING
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THINK.
SO COUNTY WAS A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT NOW IS IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH I WAS TO CARRY MEMBERS JOHN
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OTHER THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL SAYS
HE ASIAN.
RESPECTFULLY HERE IN OPPOSITION
WITH THE.
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
WE BELIEVE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING FLEXIBILITY AS A
CORE TENET OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND ALLOWS CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
INNOVATE IN AREAS SUCH AS BLOCK
SCHEDULING. INTEGRATED
CURRICULUM AND BLENDED LEARNING.
CONFINING CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHERS TO STATE DEFINED
CLASSIFICATIONS INHIBITS THE
VERY TENTATIVE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
CURRENTLY CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED TO RETAIN ALL
CREDENTIALS IN THE CHARTER
SCHOOL AUTHORIZED HER IS
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
MONITORING COMPLAINTS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
AB THIRTY FORTY EIGHT INCLUDES
A STATEWIDE DEFINITION OF CORE
COURSES IN CHARTER SCHOOLS THIS
BROAD APPLICATION IS PROBLEMATIC
WITHIN THE UNIQUE.
CHARTER SCHOOL STRUCTURE WITH
WHICH RETAINS LOCAL FLEXIBILITY
BETWEEN THE CHARTER SCHOOL AND
IT'S AUTHORIZED OR IN
DETERMINING THE APPROPRIATE
DESIGNATION OF SPECIFIC COURSES.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS MUST MAINTAIN
AUTONOMY AND FLEXIBILITY.
BETTER REMAIN SUCCESSFUL IN
PRODUCING POSITIVE RESULTS
TOWARD STUDENTS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
AB THIRTY FORTY EIGHT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOCTOR WHAT.
WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES OF I'M
TRYING TO FIND OUT IN THIS IN
THIS BILL WHAT DOWN?
FOR MISS ASSIGNMENTS OF.
WHAT HAPPENS?
BUT WE ACTUALLY ARE.
WITH THIS NEW PROCESS TRYING TO
FOCUS MORE ON PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
PROVIDING SUPPORTS.
TO DISTRICTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THAT HOWEVER IF
THE BILL DOES HAVE LANGUAGE IN
IT THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS.
.
THAT WOULD CREATE A SET OF
CONSEQUENCE
BUT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO FOCUS
MORE.
I THINK IN.
.
IN HARMONY WITH THE STATE'S
OVERALL FOCUS ON TRYING TO
SUPPORT AND TRYING TO.
YOU KNOW IMPROVE SCHOOLS RATHER
THAN SORT OF YOU KNOW HOLD OUT
THE THREAT OF PUNISHMENT TO THEM
SO THAT'S OR FOCUSING ON
INITIALLY.
WHAT DO YOU WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU
WHAT ARE YOU DOING IN TERMS OF
OF WHAT HAS BEEN ASKED TO?
RESPONSIVE SCHOOLS IT MAY NOT
BE TRADITIONAL.
THE NUMBER OF SCHOOLS THAT ARE
NOT TRADITIONAL IN TERMS OF.
.
CERTIFICATION IN TERMS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE HAVING
CURRICULUM THAT GOES ACROSS
SEVERAL DISCIPLINES IN THE
APPLIED CURRICULUM IN ALL KINDS
OF INNOVATIVE THINGS HOW ARE YOU
RESPONDING TO THAT.
IT BECAUSE IT MAY NOT FIT INTO
THE. YOU KNOW THE THE CATEGORY
THAT THIS PERSON IS TEACHING
HISTORY I'VE BEEN TO SOME OF
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT HAVE. YOU
KNOW WITH THEIR HISTORY AND
LITERATURE AND SCIENCE IS ALL
BLENDED INTO ONE.
BECAUSE HUGE O. KIND OF LOW
CURRICULUM OF LOVE. THAT SO I
THINK LONG BEACH DOES SOME OF
THAT IN SOME OF THE PLACES HOW
DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT. RIGHT
ARE YOU SPECIFICALLY TALK ABOUT
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS NO THIS THIS
IS SOME OF THE TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS I ATTENDED.
THEY HAVE I'M BLACK AND I CAN
THINK OF THE NAME OF THE TERM
BUT YOU DO A LOT OF LONG BEACH.
.
WOULD YOU CALL IT.
WELL I MEAN I QUE AT SCHOOL
SOMETIMES YOU'LL HAVE SOMEONE
TEACHING HUMANITIES WHICH OFTEN
HELLO I'M JUST GOING TO HAVE A
HISTORY WAS ON SIGNS FOCUSES ON
SOME ROCKETRY.
BUT WHAT THE LITERATURE THE
HISTORY AND THE MATH AND SCIENCE
WAS ALL IN ONE.
HUGE COULD KIND OF CURRICULUM
DOUBLE DIDN'T THE AMERICAN
IDENTIFIED AS IT'S BEEN UP THE
MATTER THINGS YET BUT IT IT'S
SOMETHING IT'S AN A IF TO SPELL
PATENTS LIKE THIS PAST AUGUST
SO.
I'M I'M SORRY PLEASE NO NO GO
AHEAD NOW I KNOW THAT YEAH IF
YOU'RE CAUGHT UP THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS READY THERE'S OR. THIS
REQUIREMENT IS ALREADY IN PLACE
THIS IS JUST STREAMLINING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF WHATEVER THEY
WERE DOING. BEFORE AND WHAT WAS
ACCEPT ACCEPTABLE FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN CREDENTIALING IS
STILL GOING TO BE DONE THIS IS
JUST REALLY AUTOMATING.
THAT PROCESS SO WOULD IT THEN
HOW DOES THIS APPLY TO CHARTER
SAYS WELL THAT'S THAT THE
CHARTERS.
WE INITIALLY HAD NOT A.
APPLIED THIS BILL TO CHARTERS
DISK THERE WAS A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT INCLUDED THE
CHARTER SO WE HAVE NOT WORKED
WITH.
ON THE FLEXIBILITY GET ON THE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY THAT
THEY'RE CLAIMING THEY NEED THEY
SAY. YOU KNOW WE REALLY HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND.
EXACTLY WHAT IS. WHAT THEY DO
WITH CREDENTIALING BEFORE WE CAN
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW TO
INCLUDE THEM IN THIS YEAR I
THINK? IT IF I COULD JUST ADD TO
THAT SO.
CURRENT AD CODE.
REGARDING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
SAYS THAT A.
TEACHER TO CHARTER SCHOOL
DIDN'T NEEDS TO HOLD A
CERTIFICATE PERMIT OR OTHER
DOCUMENT THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO
THAT WHICH A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER WOULD HAVE. IF THEY ARE
WORKING AND.
IN CORE OR COLLEGE PREP COURSES.
ARBIL ACTUALLY DOES NOT.
AT ANY DEFINITION OF OF WHAT
CORE SUBJECTS ARE BUT THERE ARE
DEFINITIONS OF THAT ALREADY
EXISTING IN STATE LAW.
AWAY IF THEY'RE NOT IN A CORE.
SUBJECT OR IF THEY'RE NOT IN A
COLLEGE PREP COURSE THAN THEY DO
YOU HAVE. A PRETTY WIDE
DISCRETION ARE BILL DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT THAT'S ALL EXISTING
LAW. ALL THIS.
THE ASSIGNMENT MONEY MONITORING
PROCESS DOES
IS.
IT IT GIVES US A A MORE
STREAMLINED WAY OF CHECKING UP
ON WHETHER OR NOT SCHOOLS BOTH
TRADITIONAL AND CHARTER. ARE.
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ALREADY CURRENTLY EXIST IN
STATE.
AND ADD TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN PEOPLE ARE
COMING UP WITH BLENDED COURSES
OR TRY NEW AND INNOVATIVE
THINGS.
.
THE COMMISSION AS WELL AS A
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
SCHOOLS.
IN IN POSITIONS LIKE THAT.
AND WE WE TRY TO HELP ADVISE
THEM TO REMAIN WITHIN THE
CONSTRAINTS OF EXISTING
EDUCATION CODE. WHILE ALSO.
ALLOWING THEM TO BE INNOVATIVE
AND AND COME UP WITH NEW WAYS TO
DELIVER.
TRADING STOOD.
SO MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT. AS A
AS SINCE THIS IS SOMETHING ADDED
ON IT BEGIN THAT.
.
THAT THERE ARE GOING TO BE SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IF YOU IF
THEY HAVE TO BE CLIP INCLUDED IN
THIS LIST?
I ASSUME THAT THIS THIS THAT
MUCH WORK STILL LEFT TO BE DONE
AND NOT JUST.
OFTENTIMES WE PUT IT ON SOMEBODY
WITHOUT REALLY DOING THE WORK
THE INTERNAL WORK AS YOU SAY YOU
HADN'T GIVEN IT ANY THOUGHT
UNTIL SOMEONE RECOMMENDED IT.
ALL SO I ASSUME THAT THERE WILL
BE SOME EFFORT TO.
.
DISCUSS HOW THEY'RE TO BE
INCORPORATED IN THIS WELL DIRT
DOES LIKE I MENTIONED BEFORE
THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS AND THE
CHARTERS WERE NOT STAKEHOLDERS
UNTIL VERY RECENTLY SO WE HAVE
EVERY INTENTION TO.
TO WORK WITH THEM AND AND AND.
.
YOU KNOW FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
INTO THE BILL.
OKAY. ARE AYE I DON'T. HAVE TO
DECIDE IF I'M GOING TO VOTE ON
IT UNTIL IT'S DONE OKAY THANK
YOU.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE THE TEACHERS ARE SIGN
CORRECTLY IS THAT TRUE. CRACKED
OKAY AND THIS REALLY JUST MERELY
SET UP AN AUTOMATED PROCESS.
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA MUCH EASIER FASHION
AND CHARTERS
TO IDENTIFY WHETHER THEIR
TEACHERS ARE SON CORRECTLY.
SO I DON'T KNOW FROM THE CHARTER
SIGN WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT AYE
I FAIL TO SEE WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THAT. OTHER THEN YO'VE GOT SOME
YOU DON'T TELL US I MEAN IT'S
PRETTY I MEAN YOU DO HAVE MORE
LEEWAY.
AND THE TRADITIONAL IS ALREADY
WE'RE NOT ATTEMPTING TO CHANGE
THAT TODAY SO I'M I'M I'M STILL
CONFUSED AND WHERE THIS ARGUMENT
COMES THAT THEY DON'T WANT IT TO
ARTISTS AND AUTOMATED PROCESS.
KIND HELPS EVERYBODY IDENTIFY
WHETHER OR NOT TEACHERS ARE SITE
CORRECTLY.
AND I THINK I SHOULD WRITE
BECAUSE I WILL GO UP NOT WHERE
WE HAVE NOT.
WE ARE NOT CONSIDERING THEM
STAKEHOLDERS YET BECAUSE I'M
INITIALLY WILL BRING THEM INTO
THE CONVERSATION SO YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO THAT THANK YOU YEAH
THE SKIN YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
JUMPING BACK THERE YOU WANT TO
TALK SO GO FOR IT.
WHISKEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES I MISSED THE IN A IN
SUPPORT.
OF LINE THINK YOU.
OKAY.
OKAY AND AGAIN YOU KNOW BE MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS GOING
ON DOWN THE ROAD.
THANKS SO WITH THAT THANK YOU. I
JUST WANT TO GIVE THAT UP THERE
A FEW TIMES CLOSE DECISION A
CHANCE TO RESPOND.
SHARES CONCERNS ARE AYE
QUESTION I SHOULD SAY AYE AYES
TO YOU KNOW WHY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS HE TRYING TO
ACTUALLY CLOSES UP BECAUSE I
THINK SHE'S COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH THEM SO I DON'T.
DEBATE ON IF I SAY SOMETHING YOU
SAY YOU WANT TO IT IS JUST ABOUT
OVER SO LET'S NOT SAY QUICKLY
AND I TRUST THAT BRADLEY WILL
BE.
YOU DON'T LEASE I HAD.
I THINK I THINK JUST FROM FROM A
HIGH LEVEL PERSPECTIVE WE JUST
HAVE A ISSUE WITH HAVING A
STATEWIDE DEFINITION OF.
OF COURSE IS THAT INTERFERES
WITH
THE LOCAL FLEXIBILITY WITH OUR
AUTHORIZED USERS.
WILL WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE AUTHOR BUT.
FROM IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE'VE NEVER BEEN INCLUDED IN
THIS MONITORING SYSTEM BUT.
SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS A SEAT
SO THANK YOU THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
ANY DEFINITION OF ANY COURSE
THIS BILL DOES NOT DO THAT.
WE'VE STATED THAT FOR
EMPHATICALLY TODAY SO I DON'T
KNOW WHERE THAT CONCERNS COMING
FROM BUT THAT WILL BE PART OF
YOUR CONVERSATION.
WITH THAT DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
ALL MOVEMENT TO HAVE A SECOND
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
YOU THE MOTION IS SUPPORT AS
AMENDED.
PLEASE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS.
I'M SORRY. DO PASS AS AMENDED
DO PASS AS MEDICAL.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY NO KALRA.
CALLER I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
THEY'RE MEANT. THURMOND AYE
WEBER.
.
LOCAL FOR NOW AND WE.
OKAY WHETHER I.
BOB.
THERE'S FIVE DOES. THE US FIVE
VOTES IT IS OUT NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO.
.
MISTER CHOOSE COMES IRWIN IS
GONE MISS WALDRON.
ALMOST I'M SORRY MISS WALDRON.
MR THURMAN I MADE A PREVIOUS
ARRANGEMENT GO RIGHT BEFORE YOU
SAYS HE'LL BE OFFICIAL AT THE
TIME.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND UNDERSTANDING APOLOGIES TO
MISS WALDRON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I HAVE A WITNESS USE ON A TIGHT
SCHEDULE HAS TO LEAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BUT THANK YOU. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THAT IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SOME FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT SEEKS
TO HELP US ADDRESS OUR TEACHER
SHORTAGE. AYE IN THE STATE IS
WELL DOCUMENTED MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS ARE EXPERIENCING
TEACHER SHORTAGE THERE MANY WAYS
TO TO HELP ADDRESS THAT BUT ONE
OF THE.
ISSUES IT HAS BECOME A BARRIER
IS A LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR EDUCATORS A TO LIVE IN THE
DISTRICTS WHERE THEY WORK UP
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CREATE A WAY
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR TEACHERS AND
CLASSIFIED STAFF SO THAT THEY
CAN REMAIN IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY WORK. HISTORICALLY
OUR HOUSING PROGRAMS HAVE NOT A
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
THAT WILL GO UP AS HIGH AS A
HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT A A MIND
WHICH IS. THAT LEVEL WHERE WORK
TEACHERS AND OTHERS IN OUR
WORKFORCE ARE TYPICALLY.
FALL IN THAT RANGE.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A NEW
PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED FOR PRE DEVELOPMENT. AND
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING TO SUPPORT.
AT OF THE BUILDING OF HOUSING
FOR TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIEDS
THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT IN MANY
DISTRICTS INCLUDING RURAL
DISTRICTS ARE RECRUITING AND
RETAINING TEACHERS HAS BEEN A
DIFFICULT CHALLENGE. I'M AWARE
OF DISTRICTS THAT HAVE REPORTED.
THAT FOUR YEARS RUNNING THEY
HAVE TO REPLACE AS MANY AS TWO
HUNDRED OR MORE TEACHERS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR WE KNOW THAT'S A
THREAT TO CLOSING ARCHIE ME GAP
OF SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS. AND
SO WE THINK THIS IS A CREATIVE
WAY. TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL EMPHASIS IS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION KARAMANA
ROW.
AND REPRESENTING WEST CONTRA
COSTA UNIFIED IS DOMINIC DUTRA
FROM DCG STRATEGIES WHO WAS
ASSISTING THAT DISTRICT WITH
THEIR EFFORTS TO BUILD EMPLOYEE
HOUSING I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
AYE VOTE.
WHAT DOES?
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR O'DONNELL
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE BEFORE
YOU AGAIN. THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
I AM SURE YOUR QUITE FAMILIAR
WITH THE.
TEACHER SHORTAGE WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS NOW. A WHAT WERE
CERTAINLY FINING IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY IS THAT.
WE HAVE EMPLOYED STRATEGIES
HONOR SUPPORTING LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD SUPPORT STRATEGIES.
TO ATTRACT TEACHERS TO THE
PROFESSION TO.
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE TEACHING
FORCE IN THE FIELDS WHERE WE
KNOW IT'S NEEDED MOST IN THE
SCIENCES AND IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. ARE HOWEVER WITHOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT PROBLEM
IS COMPOUNDED SO WE DO A GREAT
JOB OF HAVING SOME TEACHERS COME
TO PLACES LIKE OAKLAND ARE
BERKELEY. AND THEN THEY FIND OUT
WHAT IT'S GOING TO COST ACTUALLY
LIVES THERE. OUGHT AND CANNOT
SIGN THE CONTRACT.
CHOOSE TO GO ELSEWHERE AND
QUITE FRANKLY A LOT OF THEM ARE
DISILLUSIONED OF BY.
THIS PROFESSION THAT THEY'VE
CHOSEN TO GO INTO.
THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
REMAINING IN IN A LOT OF CASES
SO.
I FOR ONE AM ARE QUITE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE PLACES FOR OUR.
TEACHERS AND MORE BROADLY OUR
WORKFORCE IN EDUCATION TO LIVE
ARE THE ONLY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAS BEEN WORKING TO
ACTUALLY USE SOME OF THE LAND
THAT IT HOUSE FOR THIS PURPOSE.
ON WE'RE LOOKING AT CREATIVE
WAYS OF OF FUNDING SUCH A THING
WE HAVE.
OF THE LAND THAT WE COULD INVEST
IN THIS AND REALLY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO US SERVE OUR DISTRICTS
BY PROVIDING MORE HOUSING FOR
THEIR WORK FORCE I BELIEVE THIS
IS A. CRITICAL ISSUE AND I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NOT DOMINICK DO TRY.
OF FROM THE CITY OF FREMONT I
JUST WANT A BRIEF I KNOW YOU'VE
HAD A LONG DAYS I WANT TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY FROM A POLICY A
PROFESSIONAL IN THE AND A
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE. FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
MY FAMILY GOES BACK THIRTY
YEARS MY DAD WAS IN THE
TWENTIETH I REPRESENTED THE
TWENTY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND I
WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL IN THE
CITY OF FREMONT.
SO WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OPPORTUNITIES AND PROJECTS
WITHIN THE REGION AND
LEGISLATION JUST HAS SIMPLY NOT
CAUGHT UP WITH WHAT WE NOW CALL
THE MISSING MIDDLE THE V. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN AS
NOTED.
THE THE GAP FUNDING AND THE PRE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING IS SIMPLY
NOT THERE LEGISLATIVELY TO ALLOW
US TO EFFECTIVELY. BUILD THESE
SORT OF PROJECTS I KNOW THAT
FROM A PROFESSIONAL PERSPECTIVE
TO THEIR FAMILY'S BEEN IN THE
REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY. FOR THIRTY
PLUS YEARS I'VE STARTED TO FIRM
IDC YOU STRATEGIES THAT FOCUSES
SINCE I LEFT THE CITY COUNCIL
EXCLUSIVELY ON WORK BY PUBLIC
ENTITIES AND FAITH BATES
ENTITIES. AYE USING STE SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE PURPOSES FOR THE
LAND THIS IS ONE OF THEM. NOW
JUST CLOSE OF THE PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE AND THAT IS MY
DAUGHTER.
MY DAUGHTER IS A TEACHER SEES A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER. AYE SHE IS
NOT ONLY A GRADUATE OF CAL
BERKELEY BUT AL WENT ON AND GOT
HER MASTER'S DEGREE SHE'S A
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
TEACHERS IS IN HER THIRD YEAR
HE DID FOUR YEARS NATIONAL
SERVICE TWO YEARS WITH CITY YEAR
IN TWO YEARS WITH TEACH FOR
AMERICA.
SHE NOW I DOES A FANTASTIC JOB
BUT LIVES IN A FOUR HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT STUDIO IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND SPENDS FIFTY
PERCENT EFFORT GROSS. WAGES
SHE'LL BE MOVING HOME IN MAY.
NOT THAT SHE'S THRILLED ABOUT
THAT MY WIFE AND I HAVE TO HAVE
BEEN THE EMPTY NESTERS ARE TOO
THRILLED ABOUT THAT EITHER BUT.
I SHE REALLY DOESN'T HAVE MUCH
OF A CHOICE A BECAUSE OF THE
DEBT THAT SHE IS TAKING ON.
SO REALLY DID IT THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I'M SO THANKFUL FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMOND TAKING
THIS UP. I REALLY DO BELIEVE IT
WILL PROVIDE SOME OF THE GAP OF
P. DEVELOPMENT FUND THAT WE
NEED.
TO MAKE THESE PROJECTS NOT ONLY
VIABLE PUT POSSIBLE IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING US TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON
RAPIDLY HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND%
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING PATTING HER RARE
REPRESENTING OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
KAI JACKSON WITH SENDING A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN FULL
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CANADA BECAUSE OUR ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN FULL SUPPORT.
THE ANGELA REED ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION STROKES.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATIONOF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AIR POCKETS THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SING OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THANK SUMMER THURMOND FOR THE
PERSISTENCE OF THE THIRTY YEAR
OPENING THIS FORWARD BUT
SOMETIMES IT TAKES TIME. TO GET
TO GET THINGS DONE THE SPECIAL
ON THE RIGHT THINGS INTO.
AND ALTHOUGH I DO SYMPATHIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR'S
POSITION.
IN THAT THE LOT IS MAYES INCOME
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND THEY
CAN DECIDE WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
THE REALITY IS THAT I DON'T LOSE
ANY ONE OF OUR DISTRICTS THAT
DOESN'T HAVE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
OF THE NEED FOR MORE HOUSING FOR
SCHOOL TEACHERS AND STAFF I AND
I I THINK THAT BECAUSE OF THE
WORK. THAT OUR EDUCATORS AND THE
STAFF DO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO PRIORITIZE THOSE FUNDS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
TEACH AND SERVE OUR CHILDREN.
SO I'M I'M HAPPY ABOUT THIS
FORWARD AGAIN I'M OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED AND MR
MCCARTY DO YOU SUCK.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CLOSE.
THINGS CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA FOR YOUR REFERENCE TO.
CONTEST THE GOVERNOR'S MADE ME
YOU KNOW I LOVE OUR GOVERNOR.
BUT HE HAD MAKES AN ASSERTION
THAT JUST ISN'T SUPPORTED THAT
BECAUSE WE FINALLY HAVE DONE
SOMETHING TO HELP CITIES BUILT
SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THAT
CITIES HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO ALSO
HELP OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT IS NOT AN ASSERTION THAT
HAS ANY EVIDENCE NOT A FACT
WE'VE REACHED OUT TO CITIES AND.
QUITE FRANKLY HAVE SAID THEY CAN
BARELY TAKE CARE OF THEIR OWN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS WE HAVE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO
HAVE A TEACHER SHORTAGE. THAT WE
THINK THAT THIS IS A GREAT WAY
TO HELP US CLOSE THAT GAP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU UP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA IM MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH.
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THOSE VOTE FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU I'LL YIELD MY OTHER
TWO BILLS FROM MISS WALDRON
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU.
I MISS WALDRON THANKS YOU.
COME FORWARD.
MISS WALDRON.
WE'RE NOW ON A FILE ITEM.
NEVER FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. AND THE
M. ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AND THE GOAL OF THE BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN ARE
SAFER AT SCHOOL.
CURRENTLY THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I SEE ARE VULNERABLE.
WHAT THE TIMES ARE WIDE OPEN
GATES OR WIDE OPEN?
AS A MOM THAT'S OF CONCERN TO
ME AND THAT'S WHY A PARTICULAR
THIS BILL.
RECENT CHAT TRAGEDIES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES NECESSITATE THE NEED
FOR SCHOOLS TO REASSESS THEIR
FACILITIES AND SECURITY FOR
PREVENTION OF THREATS.
AND THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT A
SAFETY PLAN BUT OF FULL SECURITY
PHYSICAL AND OPERATIONAL
ASSESSMENT.
THE BILL REQUIRES LOCAL SCHOOLS
TO COLLABORATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
FOR THREAT ASSESSMENT EVALUATION
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE A FULL
SECURITY ASSESSMENT OF THE
CAMPUS PERIMETER.
FENCING WALLS GATEWAYS PARKING
LOTS LIGHTING SECURITY CAMERAS
ENTRYWAY SECURITY SCHOOL
BUILDING LAYOUTS DIAGRAMS.
THINGS LIKE THAT VISIBILITY
BLIND SPOTS OR.
THEY HAVE THE WEAPONS DETECTION
ABILITY OR ANY KIND OF FOAM.
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S AVAILABLE.
SMART STUDENT ID'S UTILIZATION
OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT MIGHT
BE CONSIDERED.
OF COMMUNICATION PROTOCOL
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL PUBLIC LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF THE EMERGENCY PLAN IF.
THEY HAVE ONE IN AFFECT.
THREAT ASSESSMENT FACILITY
PROTOCOLS ENSURE THAT ALL
SCHOOLS HAVE FEASIBLE
PROTECTIONS.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TECHNOLOGIES
AND STRATEGIES IN PLACE TO
PREVENT THREATS THREATS
THAT'S THE GOAL OF THIS PREVENT
THEM. UP FROM HAPPENING.
AND AS WE KNOW WHEN SOMETHING
DOES HAPPEN.
IT'S IN A CRISIS.
IT'S VITAL FOR SCHOOLS TO KNOW
HOW TO REACT AND RESPOND TO EACH
CRISIS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE
KNOWLEDGEABLE OF THE FACILITY.
AND THE TECHNOLOGIES THE
MECHANISMS THAT ARE IN PLACE ON
THE CAMPUS.
WHICH WILL HELP THEM IN
RESPONDING TO AN EMERGENCY
INCIDENT.
HIGHER CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESS
ISN'T SUPPORT SEEN NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEE NO
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
SORRY OF ANY OPPOSITION.
NO ONE'S GOING TO OPPOSE THIS.
SO WITH THAT.
SEEMED OPPOSITION NO CONSERVE I
URGE AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THE BILL PLEASE CHI CALL
THE ROLL TO PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
SIX ZERO.
OTHER THE BILL'S OUT SIX ZERO
NEXT WE HAVE A.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
MISTER GIBSON.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY THREE.
WAIT HOLD ON I LIED.
I DID.
GOING.
COMING.
TWENTY TWENTY THINK SO NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY.
AB TWENTY SIX OH NINE MISTER
O'DONNELL PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO INCREASE OUR
SUPPLY OF CREDENTIALED STEM
TEACHERS BY RECRUITING
SCIENTISTS.
WHO WANT TO BECOME K. TWELVE
TEACHERS?
CALIFORNIA IS THE MIDDLE OF A
CHRONIC AND SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
STEM TEACHERS WHICH MEANS THAT
TOO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. TO HIGH QUALITY
STEM EDUCATION BOTH IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AT THE SAME TIME MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY CAREER
SCIENTISTS CAN'T FIND SECURE
EMPLOYMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION
BECAUSE THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
FACULTY JOBS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
TEACH THIS BILL HELPS THEM MOVE
INTO SECURE REWARDING CAREERS AS
TEACHERS AND GIVES OUR STUDENTS
DIRECT ACCESS.
TO CALIFORNIA'S CONSIDERABLE
SCIENTIFIC TALENT.
THIS BILL ALSO LAYS OUT A PLAN
FOR SUPPORTING AND RETAINING
THESE NEW TEACHERS
AND RICARDO AS A REPORT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE PROGRAM
WORKS.
TO CONCLUDE WE NEED MULTIPLE
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES FOR
SOLVING STE THE STEM TEACHER
SHORTAGE THIS KID UP THIS BILL
CAN BE A ALUABLE PART OF OUR
TOOL KIT FOR TACKLING. THIS
STATEWIDE ISSUE.
I WOULD BE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE JESSICA
PSYCHO.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND LOTS HERE HAYNES WHO HAS A
PHD IN BIOMEDICAL SCIENCES WHILE
FROM UC SAN DIEGO AND WAS
RECENTLY NAMED LA UNIFIED LISTEN
TO THIS LA UNIFIED'S ROOKIE
TEACHER OF THE YEAR.
SUB GO HEAD MASSAD MASAKO.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JESSICA SOCK ON I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TODAY TO
ASK FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY
SIX OH NINE. THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
MISSION IS TO PROVIDE A HIGH
QUALITY SCIENCE EDUCATION FOR
ALL STUDENTS IN ORDER FOR
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE A HIGH
QUALITY SCIENCE EDUCATION. THEY
NEED TO HAVE WELL PREPARED WELL
SUPPORTED AND HIGHLY QUALIFIED
TEACHERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
STATE BOARD ADOPTED THE NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS
THEY ARE DESIGNED TO BE TAUGHT
IN A WAY THAT EMBRACES A YOUNG
PERSON'S INNATE CURIOSITY BY
INTRODUCING SCIENCE. AND
KINDERGARTEN TO ALL STUDENTS AND
CONTINUING THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL
AS STUDENTS PROGRESSED FROM
GRACE TO GRADE THE STANDARDS
BUILT.
IN UNDERSTANDING OF AND COMPLEX
A CONCEPTS OVER TIME.
THE NEW STANDARDS ASK THAT
STUDENTS THINK AND BEHAVE LIKE
SCIENTISTS AND ENGINEERS LIKE
THE LOVELY TEACHER SITTING NEXT
TO ME.
.
BY ASKING QUESTIONS ENGAGING AND
SENSEMAKING AND ENCOURAGING THEM
TO EMPHASIZE.
AND HANDS ON LEARNING AND
DISCOVERY WHEN STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND HOW SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERS DO THEIR WORK AND HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CARRY OUT
INVESTIGATIONS AND DESIGN
SOLUTIONS THEY BECOME MORE
ENGAGED IN THE LEARNING AND
THEIR COMPREHENSION INCREASES.
AS ARTICULATED IN THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL SCIENCE OR
STEM TEACHER SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA'S REAL AB TWENTY SIX
OR NINE WOULD LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDS TO RECRUIT AND SUPPORT
SCIENTISTS WHO WANT TO MOVE FROM
HIGHER EDUCATION WHERE THERE'S A
SURPLUS OF PEOPLE. WANTING AT
COMPETING FOR JOBS
TOWARDS A REWARDING CAREER IN
TEACHING SCIENCE AND K. TWELVE
MAKING THE TRANSITION FROM A
POST SECONDARY CAREER TRACK TO
TEACHING IN K. TWELVE SETTING
REQUIRES INTENTIONAL AND CAREFUL
RECRUITMENT. ACCESS TO AND
PARTICIPATION IN A FULLY
QUALIFIED TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDES CONTENT
SPECIFIC PEDAGOGY IN CLASSROOM
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES. AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
MENTORSHIP OPPORTUNITIES AB
TWENTY SIX OR NINE ADDRESSES
THESE NEEDS AND MORE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LET'S HEAR
HAINES I AM CURRENTLY A BIOLOGY
AND BIOMEDICAL SCIENCES TEACHER
I'M URBAN AND I'M REALLY HIGH
SCHOOL IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
IF YOU'D ASKED ME TEN YEARS AGO
WHETHER OR NOT 'D BE A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER I WOULD HAVE
LAUGHED AT YOU. AND I DEATH WE
NEVER WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT I
WOULD LOVE IT SO MUCH.
I RECEIVED MY PHD IN BIOMEDICAL
SCIENCES AT UC SAN DIEGO I AM
THE FIRST COLLEGE GRADUATE IN MY
ME FAMILY AND I AM ALSO THE ONLY
SCIENTIST IN MY EXTENDED FAMILY.
I WAS ABLE TO MAKE IT TO THIS
PLACE OF EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT
BECAUSE OF AMAZING TEACHERS THAT
A HIGH SCHOOL BIOLOGY TEACHER
WHO ALSO HAD HER PHD.
IN ADDITION I WAS A PART OF LOTS
OF DIFFERENT SUMMER PROGRAMS I
WAS ABLE TO INTERACT WITH
SCIENTISTS AND SO AS I REFLECTED
ON THIS DURING MY GRADUATE
CAREER. I DECIDED THAT I WANTED
TO INSPIRE YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF WHO MAY HAVE NEVER
THOUGHT ABOUT BECOMING A
SCIENTIST BECAUSE OF THEIR
BACKGROUNDS IN BECAUSE OF THEIR
LACK OF EXPOSURE. INFO AFTER
MAKING THIS DECISION I HAD NO
IDEA WHAT TO DO YOU I ONLY HAD
TO PAY FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS TO
BECOME A SCIENTIST AND SO I
FOUND THIS ORGANIZATION CALLED
ENCORE. AN ENCORE HELP ME EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY ON MY ROAD TO
BECOME AN EDUCATOR THEY HELPED
ME FIND TEACHING OPPORTUNITIES
THEY ALSO HELP ME PREPARE FOR
TESTS AND EXAMS AND THEY ALSO
HELP ME FIND THE PERFECT
ADDITIONAL PROGRAM FOR MYSELF.
AND NOW I GET TO SEE ENOUGH A
SCIENTIST THE TEACHER IN FRONT
OF MY TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS EVERY
WEEK. AND MANY OF THEM WOULD NOT
WILL.
SIMILAR TO ME WHERE NOT THE THEN
EXPOSED TO SCIENTISTS IF THEY.
HAD NOT MET ME IT ONE OF MY
STUDENTS TOLD ME SHE SAID THAT.
SHE THOUGHT OFF PLAINTIFFS LOOK
LIKE BILL NYE IS YOU NEVER
THOUGHT THAT SHE WOULD MEET A
SCIENTIST. AND NOW SHE KNOWS
THAT BECAUSE OF MEETING ME SHE
COULD BE A SCIENTIST AS WELL AND
SO I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SO I. AM VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
TESTIMONY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE WILL CUTS FROM THE
ENCORE STEM TEACHERS PROGRAM. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF AND STIR
WITH A CALIFORNIA STEM THAT WORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICK WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
TWENTY MEMBERS.
MISTER O'DONNELL JUST CLOSE OUR
EYES WHEN I THINK MASAKO FOR
BEING HERE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND OF COURSE DOCTOR
HAINES THANK YOU. AND.
YOU KNOW I SHOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL HAS BEEN WORK TO THE
PROCESS BY NO I MEAN WHO IS A
DOCTOR HERSELF IN NEUROSCIENCE
WRITE. SOMETHING LIKE THAT
SOMETHING HIGH AND I AM THIS IS
A SCIENCE FELLOW WORKING YOU'VE
SEEN AROUND SHE IS A SCIENCE
FELLOW.
ASSIGNED TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND DOING A GOOD JOB.
AND BRING YOUR OWN EXPERTISE IN
OUR OWN EXPERIENCE EVEN TO THIS
BILL SO THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I.
I LOVE THIS IDEA OF PUTTING MORE
PATHWAYS FOR OUR SCIENTISTS INTO
THE CLASSROOM VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT WE HAVE A MOTION WE
NEED A SECOND.
SECONDLY WAS A KALRA MOTION IS
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL TRY MADONNA I KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
MCCARTY
MCCARTY I STEINORTH. THURMOND
AYE THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT.
MISTER GIPSON.
AB TWO SIX EIGHT THREE.
QUE HE'S ON OUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR AB TWO SIX EIGHT
THREE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
THREE WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE
LITERACY RATES FOR LOW INCOME
YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. OF FORCE EFFORTS AND
AND MAKING AND OFFERING
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL WE
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS I'M OFFERED BY
THE COMMITTEE ALSO WONDERS
UNDERSCORE THAT MY WITNESS HAD
TO LEAVE.
BACK DUE TO THE OUR.
AND SO WE WON'T BE HAVING TO
HAVE SOMEONE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF FROM THAT PARTICULAR STAMP
WENT. IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S SIX
MILLION STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO
READ ABOVE THE FIFTH GRADE LEVEL
IN ORDER TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
FUNCTIONAL. ILLITERACY WE MUST
FOCUS ON IMPROVING LITERACY
OUTCOMES AT HOME.
RESEARCH SHOWED THAT CHILDREN
ARMED.
READING CAUCUS INST COMPETENCY.
STRONGLY CORRELATES WITH THE
HOME.
LITERACY ENVIRONMENT I'M SENSE
OF LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
LESS ACCESS TO LEARNING
MATERIALS FUNCTIONAL.
LITERACY IS A CHALLENGE THAT IS
VERY SERIOUS IN PUBLIC HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS
CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN PUBLIC
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE EXPERIENCE.
THAT ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF READING SKILLS AS A RESULT OF
THESE CHILDREN ENTER HIGH SCHOOL
WITH AN AVERAGE LITERACY SKILLS
OF FIVE YEARS BEHIND. THOSE OF
HIGH INCOME STUDENTS TO HELP
REVERSE THIS TREND THIS BILL
WILL ENHANCE THE LITERACY SKILLS
OF LOW INCOME.
YOU RESIDING IN PUBLIC HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THROUGH A STUDENT
AUTHOR BOOK PUBLISHING PROGRAM
THIS PROGRAM WILL BE A TWO YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WILL INCLUDE
ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS. THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM STUDENTS WILL LEARN
TO WRITE TO EDIT BRAND AND ALSO
MARKET THEIR OWN PUBLISHING
BOOKS.
THIS TYPE OF THESE TYPES
PROGRAMS WILL HELP OF REYES
LITERACY LEVELS AND BETTER
PREPARE OUR CHILDREN FOR POST
SECONDARY SUCCESS.
I WOULD SAY AT THIS POINT WITH
ME I HAVE.
WITNESS BUT THEY HAVE LEFT BUT
I ALSO WANT TO.
BRING OUT.
THAT THE SOME AMAZING YOUNG
WOMEN YOUNG GIRLS IN HIGH SCHOOL
THAT HAS WRITTEN.
BOOKS.
THESE YOUNG GIRLS WHO.
COME FROM NIXON GARDENS.
IMPERIAL COURTS HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT GOD ZACH.
ALSO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
WHO HAS WRITTEN BOOKS WHO ARE
AUTHORS I'M I TENDED THEIR BOOK
SIGNING?
THE BOOK SIGNING.
TOWN HALL WHERE CLOSE TO A
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO SHOWED UP
AND THIS IS AMAZING IN TERMS OF
BOOSTING ONE'S CONFIDENCE.
TO BE A YOUNG PERSON AND TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT I WROTE MY BOOK
AND IS PUBLISHED IS AN AWESOME
AVENTIS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
SEEING OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THANK YOU.
YOU MAKE CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I BOTH DO.
NOTICE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE
KILEY AYE KALRA.
HOWEVER I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH.
THURMOND THURMOND AND WEBER.
WEAPONS I THINK.
NO SIX VOTES IT IS OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITHOUT
WITH DRUG MOVED TO MISTER HARPER
HRUSKA FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE IN AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY.
IT'S FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
THEY MAY VERY MUCH EVEN READY
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. OF
FIRST I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS I'M HERE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY. ON AN ISSUE I'M SURE ALL
OF US TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY.
THIS BIPARTISAN BILL REQUIRE
GREAT.
CRATES SEVEN EIGHT NINTH TENTH
ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH. PUBLIC
SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE
THE NATIONAL CRISIS TEXT LINE AS
WELL AS THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LINE LINE.
ONE STUDENT IDENTIFICATION
CARDS.
HIGH SCHOOL PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
ADULTHOOD COLLEGE AND THE WORK
FORCE UNFORTUNATELY THERE MORE
SOCIAL PRESSURES THAT ARE PLACED
ON YOUNG ADULTS THAN EVER BEFORE
THE STATUS.
WITH THE PREVALENCE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA APPS SUCH SNAPCHAT. IN
INSTAGRAM AND FACEBOOK TEAMS ARE
FINDING IT INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO ESCAPE FROM
BOWLING.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY BY
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
BETWEEN TWENTY TEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE NUMBER OF TEENS WHO
FELT USELESS JOYLESS.
WHICH ARE TYPICAL SIGNS OF
DEPRESSION ROSE THIRTY THREE
PERCENT IN NATIONAL SURVEYS.
THE NUMBER OF THIRTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS WHO COMMITTED
SUICIDE. INCREASED THIRTY ONE
PERCENT.
THIS RISE IN DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDE CORRELATES WITH THE
GROWING USE OF SMART PHONES AS
WELL SOCIAL MEDIA.
AS THE USAGE OF SMARTPHONES IS
INCREASED WE SHOULD PROVIDE
EMOTIONAL HELP TO TEENS FOR THEM
TO USE. WITH THESE DEVICES.
WHETHER STUDENTS WANT TO TALK TO
SOMEONE OR TEXAS SOMEONE THERE
ARE EFFECTIVE RESOURCE THE
MITIGATE SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND
HELP THEM HANDLE THE PRESSURES
OF MY SCHOOL.
THE NATIONWIDE CRISIS TEXT LINE
IS A FREE CONFIDENTIAL TWENTY
FOUR HOUR SUPPORT SERVICE THAT
STUDENTS CAN CONTACT ANY TIME
VIA TEXT.
SINCE GOING LIVE AUGUST TWENTY
THIRTEEN NEARLY THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION MESSAGES HAVE BEEN
EXCHANGED BETWEEN THE CRISIS
COUNSELORS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN NEED.
FOURTEENTH WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO
SOMEONE OVER THE PHONE THERE'S
OF COURSE THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE.
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE PROVIDES FREE AND
CONFIDENTIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
PEOPLE IN SUICIDAL CRISIS OR
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
PLACING THESE TWO PHONE NUMBERS
ON HIGH SCHOOL ID'S MAY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES.
SOME OF THESE TEENAGERS
CURRENTLY STUDENT ID CARDS
CONTAIN INFORMATION RELATED LAS
REPLACEMENT CARDS. ON HOW TO
ORDER COPIES OF THE PHOTOGRAPH
ON FRONT THIS LAYOUT LEAVE SPACE
AVAILABLE FOR ADDITIONAL TEXT
INFORMATION. SO LITTLE TO NO
DESIGN ELEMENTS WILL NEED TO BE
REMOVED. THIS BILL GIVES
STUDENTS A VALUABLE RESOURCE TO
TURN TO WHEN THEY FEEL THAT THEY
HAVE NO OPTIONS LEFT WITH ME
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE OH TWENTY THREE
NINETY. IS CORDONED AUDI FROM
THE AMERICAN FOUNDATION OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND ERICA
HOFFMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
GOOD EVENING.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GORDON DOWNEY
I AM A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
GREATER SN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
CHAPTER. OF THE. AMERICAN
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION I ALSO SERVE ON TO
THEIR NATIONAL COUNCILS AND THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH POLICY WORK GROUP.
THREE COUNTY SUICIDE PREVENTION
COMMITTEES.
.
THE ADVISORY BOARD OF DEPRESSION
CENTER IS CASF.
BUT.
MOST NOTABLE IS THAT I'M A
FATHER WHO LOST A DAUGHTER WAS
EIGHTEEN.
I CAN UNEQUIVOCALLY SAY THAT BY
HAVING THIS PROPOSED CONTACT
INFORMATION HONOR STUDENT ID
CARD WOULD HAVE SAVED AMANDA'S
LIFE.
BUT IT WOULD HAVE GIVEN HER AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO REACH OUT FOR HELP BETTER
TIME OF CRISIS.
SUICIDE TO THIRD LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR TEN THE TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLDS. AND HASN'T BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
THAT AGE GROUP FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS NOW.
TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNTED FOR NINE POINT FIVE
PERCENT ALMOST TEN PERCENT OF
THE ENTIRE NATION SUICIDES.
RESULTING IN THE US LOSING
SOMEONE EVERY TWO HOURS OF EVERY
DAY.
WE NO THAT UPWARDS OF NINETY
PERCENT OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ULTIMATELY DIED BY SUICIDE. WERE
LIVING WITH A DIAGNOSABLE MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION AT THE TIME OF
THEIR DEATH BUT OFTEN THESE
CONDITIONS WHEN UNDIAGNOSED
UNTREATED.
TO PREVENT SUICIDE WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE AND CRISIS
HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES.
AND THAT THEY TAKE ACTION TO
SAVE THEIR LIVES THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE IT'S
A NATIONAL NETWORK OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ACCREDITED
CRISIS CENTER HOTLINES.
THE CRISIS TEXT LINE IS FREE.
PROVIDES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
SUPPORT FOR THOSE IN CRISIS
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO TAX
FROM ANYWHERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT TAX TO A TRAINED
CRISIS COUNSELOR.
BY OFFERING IMMEDIATE COUNSELING
TO EVERYONE THAT MAY NEED IT.
CRISIS LIVE PROVIDED A VALUABLE
SUPPORT AT CRITICAL TIMES
AND CONNECT INDIVIDUALS WITH
LOCAL SERVICES THAT SAVE THEIR
LIVES I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WHEN SOMEONE CALLS ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED TWO SEVEN THREE TALK. IT
REVERTS BACK TO THE AREA CODE.
AND THE CROWS CLOSES CRISIS
CENTER.
TO THAT AREA CODE. TO MY CASE
ARE LIVING CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND MINERS ANSWERED WALLER
CREEK.
WE NEED TO TAKE EVERY STEP WE
CAN TO CURB THE INCREASING
NUMBER OF SUICIDES. THIS BILL IS
JUST ONE OF THOSE STEPS
I ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
THANK YOU.
THIS YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE ERICA HOFFMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE WAY.
TO GET.
HELP FOR STUDENTS INTO THEIR
HANDS WHEN THEY'RE IN CRISIS
IT'S ON THE BACK OF AN ID CARD.
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL NEVER HAVE TO
USE IT. BUT IF THEY DO.
ESPECIALLY DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
AT EVERY KID'S GOT THEIR ID WITH
THEM.
THIS MIGHT GIVE THEM. A LINE TO
BE ABLE TO REACH OUT FOR SOME
HELP SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
ENERGY RIGHT VOTE ON THE MEASURE
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SIR FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WERE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
EIJI ANDREAS WHAT THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE PLEASED TO SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I ANY OPPOSITION.
SENIOR OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I DO NOT SEE ANY DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
IN YOU A MOTION A SECOND.
SO THE MOTION IS A TO PASS AS
AMENDED YOU APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'D I'D THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
DATA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS HIS
MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AYE. O'DONNELL AYE.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH THURMOND. THURMOND I
WEBER. WEBER AYE.
SIX GO TO THOSE OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
WITHOUT MOVING MOVED OF.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN MISTER
OBERNOLTE IS THE PRESIDENT.
I DON'T SEE HIM SO YOUR OF. YOU
BETTER. WALK UP HERE YOU BETTER
GET UP HERE BEFORE WALKS IN THAT
DOOR. AMISS REYES.
WHY ITEM NUMBER TEN OR NO NOTES
ON A PROTEST BY THE NUMBER SIX
NUMBER SIX?
IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AND
IT'S.
.
A. B..
AT TWO ZERO ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THAT
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS LOCATED
IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE STUFF
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU'VE PUT INTO
THIS BILL.
AS AMENDED TO AB TWO ZERO ONE
FIVE WILL REQUIRE THAT SCHOOLS
OFFER INFORMATION TO STUDENTS ON
HOW TO PROPERLY COMPLETE AND
SUBMIT THE FREE APPLICATION. FOR
FEDERAL STUDENT AID OR THE FAB
SO.
AND THE CALTRAIN DREAM ACT
APPLICATION.
THIS WILL HAPPEN AT LEAST ONCE
BEFORE GRADE TWELVE AND AS
AMENDED. THIS BILL PROVIDES
SCHOOLS WITH THE NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE HOW THEY
WILL PROVIDE THE ASSISTANCE.
THE TRANSITION FROM HIGH SCHOOL
TO COLLEGE IS CRUCIAL TO A
STUDENT'S EDUCATIONAL CAREER.
RESEARCH FROM THE NATIONAL
COLLEGE ACCESS NETWORK.
STATES THAT NINETY PERCENT OF
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS WHO COMPLETE
THE PHELPS ATTEND COLLEGE AFTER
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
COMPARED TO JUST FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF FRAPH SO NON
COMPLETAS.
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE AND
ENCOURAGEMENT TO FILL OUT THE
FLAPS AND DREAM ACT APPLICATIONS
CAN MAKE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHETHER A STUDENT WILL OR WILL
NOT ATTEND COLLEGE. SO WE MUST
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE GIVEN
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS DAVID O'BRIEN
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
YOU.
GOOD EVENING TURNED MEMBERS AYE
DAVID O'BRIEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT COMMISSION I'LL BE BRIEF
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AND I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO SOMEONE MEMORIES
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRUCIAL ISSUE.
AMONG THE TWENTY SIXTEEN HAS
GRADUATING CLASS ABOUT FIFTY SIX
PERCENT OF SENIOR SUBMITTED A
PASSERBY MAC APPLICATION.
LEAVING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND FINANCIALLY GRANT
MONEY ON THE TABLE IF ALL OF THE
STUDENTS ARE HAPPY INSTRUCTION
THAT THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE AN
WORLD WHERE THERE FINANCIALLY
OPTIONS AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
IMAGINE HOW MANY STUDENTS WILL
BE FREE TO PURSUE THEIR DREAM OF
A COLLEGE EDUCATION ABOUT BEEN
HELD BACK BY THE COSTS.
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR STRONG
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND HAPPEN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
FRED JONES ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE SOCIAL STUDIES
WE ARE REGISTERED OPPOSE BUT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WORKED OUT
WITH STAFF AND WITH THE AUTHOR
WE ARE ACTUALLY MOVING TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRIAN
REAVIS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTERN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND.
ANY OPPOSITION SENIOR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU TAKE ANY
NOTES BECAUSE THEY ALLOW THAT
FLEXIBILITY.
IF YOU UNDERSTAND THEY MIGHT NOT
TAKE OUT PHENOMICS TILL THE BACK
HALF OF THEIR SENIOR YEAR YOU
WANT TO DO THAT FASTER AS EARLY
AS POSSIBLE.
SO I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING THOSE OUT YOU WANT TO
ALLOW FOR
ABILITY HAVE BEEN. NOT MY OWN
CLASS KIDS CAME IN AND DID THE
FASTER WE LET THEM GO.
THE COUNSELOR SO I HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE THAT. I BELIEVE
MISTER MARKET MCCARTY WANTED TO
SPEAK YEAH I KNOW IT'S GETTING
LATE BUT THIS THIS IS A GREAT
IDEA JUST TWO THINGS ONE. I DID
MY GRADUATE THESIS ON WHY PEOPLE
DON'T GO TO COLLEGE AND THERE IS
A GREAT STUDY BY THE TOMAS
RIVERA CENTER IN YOUR NECK OF
THE WOODS AND INTERVIEWED.
PEOPLE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY. FIVE WHO DIDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE AND ASK HIM WHY TO GO
AND IF THE ANSWER WAS MONEY.
TENNESSEE DID YOU EVER HEAR
ABOUT THAT CALTRAIN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM.
NO.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO NOW
IS THAT THE CHAIR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OVERSEEING FUNDING ONE
OF THE MOST DEPRESSING THINGS
THAT I SEE EVERY YEAR IS WHEN
THE CA COMMISSION. COMES BACK
AND SAYS WELL. YOU'D ALLOCATE
THIS MUCH MONEY FOR CAL GRANT
PROGRAM. YEAH THROW BACK IN THE
GENERAL FUND WE'RE COULD END UP
FOOD WHO KNOWS.
CORRECTIONS WERE HAVE YET.
AND THAT MONEY WAS EARMARKED FOR
FINANCIAL AID AND.
.
YOU CAN JUST ON APPLYING SO I
THINK THIS IS MUCH A MUCH NEEDED
APPROACH SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I.
I HOPE EVERY SCHOOL IS ALREADY
DOING THIS IN THE STATE ACCOUNT
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE.
BUT THIS IS LIKE PRETTY COMMON
SENSE TO HELP STUDENTS MOVE
FORWARD.
AND ON TO SUCCESS OUT OF THE HUT
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE.
ARE WITHOUT THE MOTION IS
SUPPORT AS AMENDED I'M SORRY TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WE NEED A MOTION.
MISTER KALRA MODE.
MOVES MR MCCARTY SECONDS.
PLEASE CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO PROMOTE READING US FOR
COLLEGE WE MUST DO AND I THANK
YOU FOR I THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE AMENDMENT THANK YOU TO
PASS AS YOU PASS YOU
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I COME AYE
KIND AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
GOT ALL POLITICALLY.
RULES OUT AS FIVE VOTES.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL TURN
MISTER OBERNOLTE HAS GOT FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY FIVE FIVE AND NUMBER TEN.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM CONVINCED
THAT THE COMING YEARS WILL SEE
AN INFLECTION POINT WHERE
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY WILL
FUEL.
OUT EXPLOSION IN HUMAN
PRODUCTIVITY IN DEVELOPMENT
GREATER THAN ANYTHING THE WORLD
HAS EVER SEEN AND WE'RE ALREADY
STARTING TO SEE THIS IN FACT
CAREERS IN SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY RELATED FIELDS. HEAVY
JOB GROWTH OF OVER NINETEEN
PERCENT WHEREAS CAREERS IN OTHER
FIELDS ARE STAGNANT.
I HOWEVER I AM CONVINCED ALSO
THAT WE HAVE A GROWING PROBLEM
WHERE WE'RE FAILING TO PROPERLY
PREPARE. OUR CHILDREN FOR
CAREERS IN THESE FIELDS AND.
CAN FACTOR BEEN ONE NUMEROUS
STUDIES THAT DOES DON THAT SEE.
THAT SHOW THAT WE ARE UNDER
PREPARING STUDENTS AND SO THE SO
CALLED STEM FIELD SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
FIVE.
IS ONE SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM
IT CREATES A NEW DIPLOMACY ALL
THE SEAL OF STEM FOR CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS THAT
RECOGNIZE PREPARATION IN THESE
FIELDS TO QUALIFY THE SEAL AS
FOR THE SEAL. AS OUR.
AS PROPOSED YOU WOULD NEED FOR
YEARS OF MATHEMATICS ONE YEAR OF
WHICH COULD BE COMPUTER SCIENCE
YOU NEED FOUR YEARS OF A HARD
SCIENCE SUCH AS BIOLOGY.
OR PHYSICS OR CHEMISTRY THAT
YOU WOULD YOU DO ACHIEVE A
MINIMUM GPA OF THREE PA THREE
POINT OH IN THOSE.
IN THOSE CLASSES.
I THINK THAT IT'S ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE THAT WE MOTIVATE
STUDENTS TO CHOOSE CLASS WORK IN
THESE FIELDS AND WE ALSO MOVING
SCHOOLS TO EMPHASIZE ENROLLMENT
IN THESE CLASSES AND.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON IT WILL BE SAY
THAT.
VERY THANKFUL TO YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL BUT
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THERE THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT BRAD
STRONG SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
CHILDREN DOWN SUPPORT WE HAD TO
HAVE OLDER DAUGHTER THAT TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE STILL BY
LITERACY SHE WAS WENT INTO
NURSING.
ANALYTICAL AND COLLEGE STUDENT
ANOTHER STUDENT WHO ISN'T BUT
WASN'T A STAMP PROGRAM BUT
DIDN'T HAVE A SIMILAR
OPPORTUNITY WITH THAT THE STATE
SEAL OF STEM AND. I DO THINK IT
IS ENCOURAGING FOR I'M FOR
STUDENTS TO. PURSUE THOSE THOSE
CAREERS HOME AND ARE WE WE ARE I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE STEM
SEAL.
ERICA OFF WHEN WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT FOR
MANY OF THE SAME REASONS.
ALREADY MENTIONS WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WELL MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FINSTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA STEM
NETWORK AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RON RAPIDLY UP THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION ON
THIS BILL AND ARE WITH AND I
KNOW IT'S LATE I'M NOT GOING
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS BUT WE'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TO TALK THROUGH THOSE AND. MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE COME ANY
OPPOSITION.
ANY OPPOSITION ON THANK YOU I
JUST ONE COMMENT WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF STEM PROPOSALS THIS YEAR. ARE
LOT I'M SORRY SEALED. DIFFERENT
PROPOSES TO MAKE IT PEOPLE
DIFFERENT SEALS ONE MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE ARE RIGHT NOW WE ARE THE BY
LITERACY WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
KEEP THAT VERY VALUABLE.
AND WE DON'T START TRACKING KIDS
EITHER TRACKING THEM AWAY FROM
STAMMER INTO THE STEM I JUST AS
THE DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW SEAL
PROPOSALS COME FORWARD I THINK
WE MAKE SURE. IT'S REALLY
VALUABLE TO THIS REALLY
MEANINGFUL PUMPS WITH THAT I
THANK YOU.
.
YOU MAY GO TO EL OF MO IF A
MOTION.
MOVED AND SECONDED ARE MOTIONS
YOU PASS AS A MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS.
MIKLOS
WELL KNOW APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT REQUEST AND I DON'T.
THANK YOU.
TO PRESS IS A MEASURE
APPROPRIATIONS FISCAL ROOM
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX VOTES THANK
MISTER MAKE YOU. WELL TURN TO
MONSIEUR.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
S. YOU GOT FROM.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER LOVE.
IT IS IMPORTANT YOU GOT SUPPORT
A SPORT ON THE SO YOU WANT TO BE
AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
YOU ONLY LOSE VOTES THE MORE YOU
TALK OKAY.
I HAVE A MOTION THAT HEY I'M
JUST BASICALLY THIS IS UP FOR
CHILDREN AND THIS IS FOR
BASICALLY ZERO TO THREE YEAR
OLDS THOSE THAT ARE POTTY
TRAINED WILL NOW HAVE SOMEWHERE
TO BE STE TO TAKEN CARE OF. SO
WE HAVE A.
WILL INCREASE THE RATE TO BE
PAID FOR CHILDCARE CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS WE WILL CREATING
INCLUSIVE GRANT PROGRAM. AND WE
WILL DO RECRUIT IN TRAINING OF
NEW.
GENERATION OF FAMILY CARE
PROVIDERS.
I'LL TELL YOU IN WHEN I WAS A
SINGLE MOTHER AS I WAS A SINGLE
MOTHER WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE A
PLACE TO SEND MY CHILDREN. SO
ALL WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE QUICKLY.
OUR SUPPORT HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY PRIMEROS
ON BEHALF OF FIRST OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO NINE TWO. JUST ST OUT WE
HAVE NOT RESTORED INFANTS AND
TODDLERS SINCE THE RECESSION WE
THINK THIS BILL IS THE FIRST
STEP AND.
ALL FIRST WIVES INCLUDING ALL
YOUR LOCAL FIRST WIVES AREN'T
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE ALLEN JAVAID WITH THE
BEST PROJECT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
MARGARET GO TO THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CAN A KAISER WITH
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EQUITY
IN EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PATIO WHERE REPRESENTING EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DINEEN MICHELETTI COLBERN
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT.
RON PROBABLY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE INJURY REPRESENTING THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR MCCARTY YES EXCELLENT EFFORT
JUST CAN CURRENTLY WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
INFANTS TODDLERS THE FACTOR IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
GLAD YOU'RE WORKING ON THIS WILL
BE LOOKING AT THAT FROM THE
FINANCIAL WORLD AS WELL WE'RE
GONNA MOVE THIS TOGETHER. THANK
YOU AYE MR MCCARTY MOVES AND
SECONDED BY DOCTOR WEBER.
UP.
THE MOTION AGAIN IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. O'DONNELL.
I AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SIX VOTES IS OUT.
WITHOUT BITTERNESS BURKE WHO
HAS.
.
TWO BILLS OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY. AND THIRTY SIX WILL
START WITH THIRTY WHICH IS.
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY NINE APPEARS
BY ONE NUMBER THIRTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
AT LAKE START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THINK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF ARE
THROUGH. YOUR WORK WITH MY
OFFICE ALSO I'M THINK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK ON CT. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY NINE SEVEN I
ESTABLISHES THE STATE SEAL OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY COMPLETION TO RECOGNIZE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES. WHO HAVE
ATTAINED A HIGH LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE AND PROFICIENCY INCUR
TECHNICAL?
I EDUCATION PATHWAYS AYE AYE I
HEARD YOUR NOTES ON.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE IS BILL
AND WE WANT THIS TO BE OF VALUE
SEAL.
WITH THAT I HAVE MY WITNESSES
WHO WILL BE BRIEF.
THANK YOU ARE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YES NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA MANY
FACTORS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE DO APOLOGIZE FOR
EARLY POSITION LETTER BUT WE ARE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED WON'T GO INTO
YOU OF WHAT WE LIKE THOSE LEAD
WHICH CHANGES TO BE BUT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE AND CONCEPT OR JUST
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. ON TO
TIGHTEN UP SOME AND WOOD
ELIGIBILITY LANGUAGE.
BUT WE DO YOU ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
FRED JONES CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
PATRICIA RECORD CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
SPREE IMPACT REITERATE MY OTHER
COMMENT THAT YOU HEARD ME SAY A.
THE QUEEN TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
ABOUT.
THIS THE SEALS.
BECAUSE.
THERE I WANTED TO MEAN
SOMETHING SO I WILL SOMETIMES
WONDER CERTIFICATION.
IN SOME TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY HERE
SOME APTITUDE IS BETTER THAN
EVEN A SEAL OF THE MAKES MIGHT
MAKE THEM MORE EMPLOYABLE. ME
AND WITHOUT I OF RAY THESE THIS
YEAR IN PARTICULAR AND WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THEY REALLY HAVE
VALUE AND I KNOW YOU AGREE WITH
THAT SAID THANK YOU.
I'M WITHOUT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I'LL SECOND THE COMMENT ABOUT
THE CONCERN ABOUT SEAL INFLATION
WE SHOULD I THINK A LITTLE.
MORE HOLISTICALLY ABOUT THAT.
I MIGHT ALSO SUGGEST A FRIENDLY
AMENDMENT TO MAKE IT THE CAREER
EDUCATION OSTEOLOGICAL TO
CRITICAL EDUCATIONS.
AND I KNOW THAT'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KYLIE'S ONE OF HIS ISSUES
WITH CURRENT THE WAY WE PHRASE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE NOTE.
AND MORE SERIOUS ME MORE SHARKS
YES AND HE CAREFULLY. ON.
WHO?
SO WITH THAT.
.
EXPECT WHERE QUESTION I YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE OKAY WITH.
WITH THE MOTION IS.
.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL AYE AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY. KIND THE
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
PARTY AYE STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE THURMOND. AND
WEBER SWELLING THOUGH WEBER AYE.
MADE PROCEED WITH YOUR SECOND
BILL WHICH IS ON.
I APOLOGIZE.
IT.
WELL I NEVER THIRTY SIX A. B.
THIRTY TWO TO TWENTY EIGHT
ABILITY.
THANK YOU I THINK MISTER
CHAIRMAN WHAT I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS ALLEN IN THE
ANNOUNCES SOMETHING IN THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT. AUTHORIZES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN RECEIVERSHIP
TO USE REVENUE FROM THE SALE OF
SURPLUS PROPERTY FOR PAYING DOWN
THE AMOUNT OWED BY THE STATE. I
CURRENTLY REVENUES FROM THE
STATE A SALE OF SURPLUS
PROPERTIES MUST BE IS DEFINED
IMPROVEMENTS TO SKILLED SCHOOL
FACILITIES.
I HAVE A SCHOOL DISTRICT AS ARE
OTHERS THAT ARE IN STATE
RECEIVERSHIP AND AND OF THIS
WILL HELP US ATTAINS. KIND OF
SOLVE SOME OF OUR OUR FINANCIAL
ISSUES WITHOUT I HAVE.
WITNESSES THAT WILL BE SURE
THANK YOU IT IS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING DEBORAH BROWN ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM
TOILETS AND EIGHT WE WANT I
THINK I MISSPOKE FOR CARRYING
THIS MEASURE WE DO THINK THAT
THIS DOES. HELP.
AT A LIMITED NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS WHO ARE IN IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS TO HELP THEM.
I TURN THE CORNER SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND.
INGLEWOOD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS IN OUR JURISDICTION
WE HAVE AB TWELVE HUNDRED
AUTHORITY I'M OVER THEM TO
IMPROVE THEIR BUDGETS AND SO
FORTH. AND SO WE'RE VERY CLOSELY
RELATED TO THEM AND WORKING WITH
THEM WE THINK THIS WOULD BE
HELPFUL AND TO IMPROVE THEIR
FISCAL SITUATION SO WE URGE YOUR
IPHONE.
PATTING HER RARE REPRESENTING
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE THINK MISS BURKE FOR
CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FOR US WE'RE CURRENTLY
EVALUATING OUR SCHOOL PORTFOLIO
AND OUR SCHOOL UTILIZATION
RATES.
AND WE WOULD LIKE THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED IN THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARM WITHOUT ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WE GET A MOTION.
QUESTION ARE YOU CAN THIS IS
DESIGNED TO MAKE IT PROBABLY
LIQUIDATOR SELL PROPERTY IS THAT
RIGHT NAUTA.
SORRY IT'S EITHER LEASE OR SALE
SALE.
AND IT'S FOR SCHOOLS IN
RECEIVERSHIP FOR OBVIOUSLY WERE
ALREADY FACING FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES AND WE DO HAVE A
PORTFOLIO OF REAL ESTATE I'M
SOME DISTRICTS. LIKE MY OWN
RIGHT NOW SELLING IS PROBABLY
NOT WE'RE GOING TO PRY LEAST BUT
IT GIVES US THE OPTION TO DO
SOME OF THOSE THINGS. AND I SOME
OF THE FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE
HERSELF SOLVENT. AND ARE
DISTRICTS SO SOME PROPERTY I
HATE IF THEY SOLD IT BECAUSE
ONCE IT'S SOLD IT'S GONE RIGHT
AND SKINNER IS. YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S IT'S GONE YEAH WELL I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE LOOK WHAT WE SAYING
OR AT LEAST STATE BUYING THE
PROPERTY FROM YOU AND THEN
HOLDING AND POSSIBLY YOU. BEING
APPLIED BACK I MEAN IT'S ZERO
SUM GAME TERMS OF MONEY BUT.
OF. SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT WHAT CLEARLY OF
DOING SOMETHING WITH THE
PROPERTY BUT. I HOPE THAT'S
SELLING WELL OUR GOAL IS JUST TO
MAKE SURE WHATEVER WE DO IS A
MARKET RATE YEAH YEAH THAT AND
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THINKS.
THANK YOU.
.
WITH THAT.
THE MOTION IS US FOUR ISM THAT.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MIKLOS ASPECT
CLEARQUEST ENABLE.
DO PASS IS MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WE DON'T MOTION.
YEAH WE DID.
THE DOCTOR WEBER MOVES.
SCAR SECONDS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A DONALD.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
ANOTHER.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THAT.
THE BILL IS OUT
.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR AB THREE TWO ZERO
FIVE MISTER O'DONNELL YOU MAY
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER THAT HAS PARTICIPATED IN
MANY SCHOOL LOCKDOWNS.
SOME LASTING AS LONG AS SIX
HOURS I CAN ATTEST TO THE NEED
FOR A TEACHER TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO LOCK A CLASSROOM DOOR
FROM INSIDE THE CLASSROOM.
IMAGINE THIS BILL GOES OFFER YOU
MADE TO YOUR MADE AWARE THAT YOU
NEED TO IMMEDIATELY LOCK THE
CLASSROOM DOOR TO ENSURE STUDENT
SAFETY.
THIS MEANS YOU HAVE TO GET OUT
YOUR KEYS WALK OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM AND LOCK THE DOOR.
THIS TAKES TIME AND MAY REQUIRE
REQUIRE TEACHER TO STEP OUT INTO
A VERY SAFE ENVIRONMENT. YOU MAY
HAVE YOUR KEYS IN YOUR POCKET.
pIN YOUR POCKET YOU TO LOCATE
THEM OFTEN I WOULD KEEP THEM
OFTENTIMES I WOULD KEEP THE MY
DESK THAT MEANS I MIGHT NOT BE.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN NEAR MY DESK I
WOULD HAVE TO WALK OVER TO MY
DESK LOCATE MY KEYS. GO THROUGH
MY KEYS WALKED TO THE DOOR STEP
OUTSIDE.
INTO WHAT MIGHT BE A VERY
SERIOUS SITUATION.
FOLLOWING THE COLUMBINE COLORADO
SHOOTING IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
WHERE THIRTEEN STUDENTS AND A
TEACHER WERE KILLED.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL
THAT REQUIRES ALL NEW SCHOOLS TO
HAVE LOCKS.
THAT LOCK FROM INSIDE THE
CLASSROOM.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR SCHOOLS ARE
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD THIS
MEANS THAT IS LIKELY THAT MOS
OF OUR CLASSROOM DOORS. DO NOT
LOCK FROM THE INSIDE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX STUDENTS AND
EDUCATORS WERE KILLED AT SANDY
HOOK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
CONNECTICUT.
A NUMBER OF THEM WERE SHOT AND
CLASSROOMS THAT COULD ONLY BE
LOCKED FROM THE OUT SIDE.
ONE OF THE MAIN RECOMMENDATIONS
OF A COMMISSION FORMED AFTER THE
INCIDENT WAS CHANGE THE LOCKS
ALLOW A TEACHER TO LOCK THE
CLASSROOM DOOR FROM INSIDE THE
CLASSROOM.
THE RECENT TRAGEDY AND MARJORIE
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL IN
PARKLAND FLORIDA REMINDS US THAT
OUR WORK IS NOT DONE CALIFORNIA
MUST ACT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS SEEKING STATE BOND
FUNDS TO INCLUDE IN THOSE
PROJECTS
LOCKS ON CLASSROOM DOORS THAT
CAN BE LOCKED.
FROM THE INSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM.
AS A TEACHER AND A PARENT I TAKE
STUDENTS SECURITY VERY
SERIOUSLY.
LET'S ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND ALL SCHOOL STAFF
ARE ABLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
WHETHER THEY ARE IN A NEW
SCHOOL.
OR AN OLDER SCHOOL.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I
HAVE.
TO WITNESS IS HERE WITH ME
TODAY MISTER CHAIR.
IF THEY MAY PERCEIVE YOU MAY
PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS OF THE COMMITTEE
RON RAPIDLY HAVE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS I ACTUALLY LIVED FIVE
MILES FROM COLUMBINE WHEN THAT
WENT DOWN BOTH OF MY.
GUTTERS WERE IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND IT WAS A TERRIFYING
EXPERIENCE.
SO YOU KNOW THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE'VE
SPONSORED A SIMILAR BILL MANY
MANY TIMES AND AND YET IT WAS
KILLED BECAUSE OF COST.
HOW CAN WE PUT A COST ON A CHILD
TO LIVE THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE
SOLUTION BELIEVE IT OR NOT?
YOU HAVE TO WALK OUTSIDE YOUR
CLASSROOM AND MANY SCHOOLS TO
LOCK YOUR DOOR IMAGINE IF A
SHOOTER.
COMES INTO THE BUILDING AND AND.
YOU'RE TO WALK OUTSIDE SO WE'RE
PUTTING OUR OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
STUDENTS LIVES IN DANGER.
WE NEED TO TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS WE THINK THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE STRATEGY AND. AND.
CERTAINLY.
ONE THAT WE CAN AFFORD TO.
PROVIDE FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
OUR.
STUDENTS AND FOR OUR TEACHERS
NOW'S THE TIME TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS THIS IS A SIMPLE
STRATEGY AND LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE LEAD ON
THIS. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE BUT THANK YOU.
TONY TOOK CARE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WILL ALIGN OUR REMARKS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE. BUS SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER BECAUSE ABOUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ASPIRIN AYE VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ENSURE
STUDENT SAFETY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
MY I WOULD WE HAVE EVENTUALLY OF
MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY AYE UPON THE AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH. STEINORTH
AYE THURMAN.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SIX VOTES THE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY
TAKE UP AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX.
THAT IS FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE.
.
OKAY.
GUY AND I AM PRESENTING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN. AND THIS IS UP I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M SORRY
IT IS MISTER MOANS WILL.
HE IS NOT HERE HE HAD.
SOME OTHER DUTY.
MAY HAVE RECEIVED ALREADY
DOUBLE DUTY SOMEWHERE.
THIS WAS IT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN.
HE WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANKS
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
FINE WORK.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX PROVIDE
SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITY AS ORDER
IN DIVIDE INDIVIDUALIZE COUNTY
CHILDCARE SUBSIDY PLANS.
TO THE STATE.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MISS
FOR MONIQUE ROMANCE FROM FOR A
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA. MARGOT
GRANT GOULD FROM FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION.
AND JULIAN CUEVAS LEGISLATIVE
POLICY REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
AND SARAH.
NOVELL MORGAN DIRECTOR OF EARLY
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT DIVISION
OF CD. AND I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR S. FROM IVAN I KNOW ALL
THE WITNESSES KNOW THAT THEY DO
HAVE A TIME.
THANK YOU
WAS THE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
ARE DOING WELL US ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION.
AS A SPONSOR WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AS THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED I DO
HAVE SERRANO MORGAN THE DIRECTOR
OF THE EARLY EDUCATION SUPPORT
DIVISION HERE JUST TO ANSWER ANY
UP FOR DRAMATIC IN TECHNICAL
QUESTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARGOT GRANT
COOLED WITH THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
LIKE TO THINK I'M THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION FOR SPONSORING THIS
BILL. CURRENTLY THIRTEEN
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO PILOT
STERN EARLY EDUCATION POLICIES
TO BETTER CAPTURE THE CHILD CARE
FUNDING THAT IS ALLOCATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE EACH YEAR. AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX WITH SIMPLY SCALE
MENTAL MANY OF THESE POLICIES
THAT HAVE BEEN TESTED AND PROVEN
TO THE REMAINING TWO THIRDS OF
THE STATE THAT CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE THIS AUTHORITY. SIMPLY PUT
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE MORE
CHILDREN AND MORE FAMILIES WILL
RECEIVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUIT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION AND FOR
THIS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MUST SOMEHOW
FIRST THAT CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT.
PATTY EUROPE PRESENTING EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
DINI MICHELETTI COLBERN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
CITIES ALLEN JAVA DID BASS AND
PROJECT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN DOWN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MCCARTY
MEMBERS.
MISTER O'DONNELL SLASH MULLIN
PROJECT BECAUSE.
WELL I'M.
ANYWAY I FAST FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WE NEED A MOTION.
WE MENTIONED THE SECOND IS THE
PAST APPROPRIATIONS
IT'S CALLED THE LAW AS AMENDED.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL I KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE THURMAN.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT
.
TO CUNNINGHAM.
IS FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY MISTER CUNNINGHAM
PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE STATE. IS
CHARGED WITH PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION RELATED
DISPUTES THAT CANNOT BE
RESOLVED.
THESE HEARINGS ARE CONDUCTED BY
THE MINISTRY OF LAW JUDGES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW OR UNDER
CURRENT LAW EITHER PARTY MAY
REQUEST A CONTINUANCE OF THE
HEARING.
WHICH THE STATUTE SPECIFIES
SHALL BE GRANTED UPON SHOWING OF
QUOTE UNQUOTE GOOD BECAUSE.
HOWEVER UNLIKE OTHER AREAS OF
LAW THE STATUTE DOES NOT DEFINE
WHAT GOOD CAUSE IS.
SO WE HAVE SITUATIONS WHERE THE
HEARINGS ARE SET AT A TIME
PERIOD WHERE THE SCHOOL.
IS OUT OF SESSION FOR SUMMER
FOR WINTER.
SPRING AND YOU HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING WITNESSES THAT HER.
EMPLOYEES OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO ATTEND THE HEARING.
THIS.
PROLONGS DISPUTES AND MAKE
SETTLEMENT DIFFICULT.
AND IT DRIES UP COST FOR BOTH
SIDES AND ACTUALLY IN SOME CASES
CAN HAMPER OUR KIDS FROM GETTING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES IN A
TIMELY WAY. IT'S THIS BILL WOULD
DO TWO THINGS THAT WOULD CLARIFY
IN STATUTE THE STANDARD FOR GOOD
CAUSE. FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
HEARING.
.
IT IT WOULD CLARIFY THE STANDARD
FOR BECAUSE IT WAS SPECIFIED
THAT.
THEY'RE TWO GROUNDS ACCOUNTS TO
GOOD CAUSE FOR A ONE TIME
CONTINUATION HEARING.
THE FIRST ONE IS WHEN A MATERIAL
WITNESS IS ABSENT.
DO TO THE HEARING DATE BEING SAT
ON A DAY WHEN THE SCHOOL WAS NOT
IN SESSION.
AND THE OTHER IS WHERE BOTH
PARTIES BOTH PARTIES STIPULATE
THAT EXTENSIONS NECESSARY TO
RESOLVE THE MATTER. BY
SETTLEMENT.
A SOMETIME SCHOOL BOARDS CANNOT
A ENACT A SETTLEMENT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT MEETING OVERWINTERED
THEY CAN'T.
VOTE ON IT AND SO YOU'VE GOT
HEARING DATES THAT ARE DRIVING
UP LITIGATION COSTS
REALLY FOR NO.
FOR NO REASON.
I THINK IT'S COMMONSENSE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE LAW.
AGAIN IS JUST A ONE TIME
CONTINUOUS FOR ONE OF THESE TWO
GROUNDS.
I THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR
TEACHERS GOOD FOR SCHOOL STAFF
AND GOOD FOR KIDS AND HASTEN THE
PROVISION OF SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE DOESN'T SUPPORT.
KRISTY'S MOTHER BRIDGETTE READ
EDUCATE ADVOCATE EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIANS PART THANK YOU.
EVELYN ABA HASN'T DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S EQUALIZATION IN THE
PROCESS OF THAT. DISCONTINUANCE
IS NOT JUST FOR ONE SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
AVAILABLE BUT ALSO FOR PARENTS
WHEN THEIR MATERIAL WITNESSES
ARE NOT AVAILABLE.
SO WE'VE ON SANTA LETTER TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE I THINK FOR
WORKING WITH THE STAFF TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE BUT I JUST
WANTED TO. TESTIFY TO THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I DON'T THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
IT'S CUNNINGHAM BUDGET BECAUSE.
SURE AND I DID GET A LETTER FROM
THAT GROUP I THINK THERE
PROPOSAL MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
WERE WORKING WITH THEM IT SHOULD
THE COMMITTEE SEE FIT TO PASS
THIS BILL. ALONG I WILL BE
WORKING WITH THEM TO AMEND THE
BILL SO THERE'S PARITY IN THE
CONTINUANCE FOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND IT
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA HIVE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STORE NOT STEINORTH AYE THURMAN.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT.
AND I SEE MISTER LAZAR IN HERE.
YOU'D LIKE TO APPROACH.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTEEN. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY.
SEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY. THIS EVENING. OTHER
CLEAN AND HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY REQUIRES ALL
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS WITH
FIFTY OR MORE STUDENTS TO SWITCH
TO SAFER. ENVIRONMENTALLY
PREFERABLE CLEANING PRODUCTS
ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERABLE
CLEANING PRODUCTS ARE THOSE THAT
ARE INDEPENDENTLY CERTIFIED BY A
THIRD PARTY. AS HAVING GREATLY
REDUCE THE FACTS ON HUMAN HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLISHED A REPORT URGING
SCHOOLS TO SWITCH TO
ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERABLE.
CLEANING PRODUCTS
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO WARNED THAT
CONVENTIONAL CLEANING PRODUCTS
MAY CONTAIN CHEMICALS ASSOCIATED
WITH ASTHMA CANCER REPRODUCTIVE
HARM AND AND. CAN INDOCTRINATE
OF DESTRUCTION.
WHILE MORE AND MORE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE SWITCHED TO LESS
TOXIC ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERABLE
CLEANING PRODUCTS CONVENTIONAL
CLEANING PRODUCTS ARE STILL
WIDELY USED.
THE REQUIREMENT TO SWITCH TO
ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERABLE
CHEMICALS IS ONLY REQUIRED IF IT
IS ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE TO THE
SCHOOL MEANING.
IF SWITCHING WILL HAVE NO NET
COST INCREASE.
IN REALITY ALMOST EVERY
INSTITUTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAS ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY
SWITCHING TO ENVIRONMENTALLY
PREFERABLE CLEANING PRODUCTS.
IF SCHOOLS OR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHOOSE NOT TO COMPLY WITH THESE
PROVISIONS THAN A LETTER
DETAILING THE REASONS WHY
COMPLIANCE IS NOT FEASIBLE SHALL
BE POSTED. ON THE SCHOOLS OR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WEBSITE.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY WILL
REQUIRE SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO AVOID CLEANING
PRODUCTS.
THAT ARE HARMFUL TO TEACHERS
STUDENTS AND CUSTODIAL STAFF.
WHO HAVE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE BY REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO
SWITCH TO ENVIRONMENTALLY
PREFERABLE CLEANING PRODUCTS IF
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE? WITH ME I
HAVE BILL ELIUD WITH THE.
SPONSOR ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP AS WELL AS TONY TRICK
ARROW. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M BILL ALEJO
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
HAPPY TO SPONSOR THE BILL.
MISTER NAZARIAN SAID MOST OF
WHAT I NEED TO SAY SOLVE BE
BRIEF.
THE THIRD PARTY CERTIFIER IS
THAT WOULD APPROVAL LISTA
PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS EXCEPT
FOR U. S. EPA SAFER CHOICE.
PROGRAM WHICH IS NEWER AND
DOING THE SAME THING AND THEY
PROVIDE A LIST OF. DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF CLEANING PRODUCTS IS
NOT CREATING MONOPOLY WHICH JUST
THOSE A MANUFACTURER TO WHO
COULD HAVE THAT APPROVED.
WE'VE.
TAKE A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS AND
WILL CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION.
I'M AND I THINK WE'RE CLOSE WITH
THAT. A COUPLE OTHER ISSUES HAVE
COME UP IN THE LAST WEEK.
WHY NOT LET A STATE BODY
CERTIFY THESE THINGS OF THE
THIRD PARTY WITH A THIRD PARTY
PEOPLE BEEN DOING IT FOR THIRTY
YEARS OF DOING A GOOD JOB
MANUFACTURERS SCHOOL DISTRICTS?
OUR OWN DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES USES THEM.
AND DO WE WANT TO PAY FOR A NEW
STATE AGENTS I NEW PRODUCTS A
PROGRAM A STATE AGENCY TO WOULD
HAVE TO BE FEE BASED. OR COME
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND I DON'T
THINK SO WE HAVE A GOOD
ALTERNATIVE NOW.
THIS THERE'S ALSO AN ACCUSATION
SORT OF FIRES ALLOW TOXICS LIKE
PROPS SIXTY FIVE CHEMICALS TO BE
CERTIFIED NOT TRUE I'VE LOOKED
AT THEIR STANDARDS. THEY ALLOW
NO INTENTIONALLY ADDED.
MUTAGENS CARCINOGENS OR A
CONTAINING THOSE
INGREDIENTS IF THERE IS A TINY
MOUSE ONE TARA HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION OR LESS.
LASTLY SOMEONE SUGGEST WHY WE
JUST THIS WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE
OF DO IT YOURSELF PRODUCTS LIKE
VINEGAR AND BAKING SODA. A THOSE
ARE NOT ALWAYS BENIGN VINEGAR IS
ALSO AN* MEGYN AND BE
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE LAW THAT
WOULD SAY A TEACHER CAN'T
CLEANER DESK WITH BAKING SODA
VINEGAR IF THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO. BUT MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WE FEEL ONE USE REGULAR KEENING
CLEANING PRODUCTS AND NOT START
RESORTING TO BAKING SODA AND
VINEGAR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR TONY TO CARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE BILLS WHERE IT'S SIMPLY
WHERE THERE'S A WILL THERE'S A
WAY. UMP THIS.
ISSUE IMPACTS EVERYONE AT THE
SCHOOL SITE NOT JUST STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS BUT ALL THE
EMPLOYEES THERE I THINK THE
ANALYSIS. ON PAGE BY POINTS OUT
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS IT'S A SOUND ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS ALICE FELONIES
FELONIES GROUP ON BEHALF OF
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY IN
SUPPORT.
CAMERAS MURDEROUS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION WE
REPRESENT COST BY MEMBERS ON THE
MOST POPULOUS DISTRICTS
INCLUDING JANITORS AT WORK WITH
THESE PRODUCTS NAM BEHALF BY
MEMBERS THE STUDENTS WE SUPPORT.
CHRISTIE'S MOTHERBOARDS ON
BEHALF OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND
EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
WENDY CUTIE PARENT OF A CHILD
WITH SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL
.
GOOD EVENING A COOKING UNITARILY
HALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO STARTBY SAYING WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENTS THAT EXEMPTED. REAL
PRODUCTS FROM THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS BILL OTHERS CLEANING
PRODUCTS ARE CENTRAL IN OUR
OPINION FOR REDUCING BACTERIAL
CONTAMINATION ON FOOD SERVICE
SAYS PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
FLU OUTBREAKS CLEANING
RESTAURANT AT ULTRA.
AND THEY ALREADY GO THROUGH AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW BY THE US EPA
AND DP ARE BEFORE REGISTRATION.
WE ALSO AND RECOGNIZE THAT THE
AUTHORED SPONSORS TO BELIEVE
THAT USEPA SEE FOR CHOI
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WOULD
QUALIFY UNDER THIRD PRE
CERTIFIER.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE U. S.
EPA HOWEVER JUST TO CONFIRM NOT.
AND.
MAY LOOK TO YOU.
MAKE SOME CHANGES TO MAKE THAT
EVEN CLEARER IF NECESSARY BUT WE
DO SUPPORT THAT THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
IS.
BUT IT QUALIFIES.
I'M WE JUST ALSO I WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT THAT.
WHILE WE SUPPORT THAT THIRD
PARTY CERTIFICATION WE WOULD
ALSO ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
LOOK AT OTHER SYSTEMS.
AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO IMPROVE THEIR SUSTAINABLE
PURCHASING PROGRAMS.
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S A.
AND ORGANIZATIONS SUSTAINABLE
PURCHASING LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
AND THEY HAVE A PROCESS BASED
APPROACH THAT HELPS.
ORGANIZATIONS IDENTIFY THE
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS THAT THEY
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE IF IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO REDUCE.
ALLERGENS AND PRODUCTS.
THEY CAN WAY AMONGST THE GREEN
SALES WHICH HAVE BETTER.
REDUCTIONS AND ALLERGENS.
VERSUS WHAT MIGHT HAVE MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL.
BENEFIT SO.
WE JUST THINK THIS ALLOWS THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ACHIEVE
THEIR OWN GOALS.
SO FOR THESE REASONS AND OTHER
STATE IN OUR LETTER THAT I WON'T
GO INTO WE ARE OPPOSED TODAY
THINK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS TIM JUSTIN WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL OUT
JUST TWO QUICK POINTS WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEEK SOME CLARIFICATION
ON THE LANGUAGE AROUND
DISINFECTANTS AND SANITIZERS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PRODUCTS.
ARE AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS
POTENTIAL THREATS FROM PATHOGENS
NOROVIRUS WHAT HAVE YOU.
AND THEN SECONDLY AS IT RELATES
TO THE CRITERIA FOR A THIRD
PARTY CERTIFICATION WE DO HAVE
SOME SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED BY OUR LEGAL FOLKS
WE SHARE THOSE WITH MISTER HIS
AREA AND. A LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THEM AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SIMILAR OPPOSITION WARRIOR BACK.
STUDENTS ARE MAYBE YOU CAN
ANSWER MY QUESTION MAYBE YOU CAN
STEP YOUR ARM WHEN YOU AWARENESS
ABOUT OF THE SAFER CHOICE
PROGRAM OF PUBLIC SHE DID.
COULD YOU JUST ELABORATE ON WHAT
MY CONCERNS HERE IS THAT WE'RE
BEING ASKED TO PICK WINNERS AND
ON THE BUSINESS SIDE AND I DON'T
THINK THAT YOUR INTENT HERE
TODAY IS NO I'M SAYING AS MUCH
SOME.
I'M WORRIED THAT SOMEONE STARTS
A LABEL SAYS LOOK YOU GET
CERTIFIED BY US.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE GOLD
pENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY NOW
I'M
GONNA MAKE MUCH MONEY NUMBER
SIX.
NOT SAYING THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE BUT THAT'S MY
CONCERN SO MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT MAYBE ONE OF THE.
OTHER THE OTHER WITNESS COULD
TALK ABOUT THE SAFER CHOICE
PROGRAM.
CHESTER.
I'M SURE SO THE SAFER CHOICE
PROGRAM IS RUN BY THE.
U. S. EPA EYES SO WE DEFINITELY
IT'S ANA OBVIOUSLY A PRIVATE
ORGANIZATION SO WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THEY ARE A A PROGRAM THAT'S
CONSIDERED DATE CERTIFIED.
OVER TWO THOUSAND.
PRODUCTS IN TERMS OF. THEIR
COMPLIANCE.
BUT FOR OF MANY OF THE THE
REASONS YOU.
MENTIONED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THAT'S WHY
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO LOOK AT
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY CERTIFICATION BASED.
BUT MORE.
HOLISTIC AND PROCESS BASED.
IF I MAY COMMENT BILL ALLEY WITH
THE WG.
FOR MANY YEARS THAT WAS ON THE
GREEN SEALING EAGLE LOGO AND NOW
IT'S YOU EPSA PER CHOICES MUCH
MORE ROBUST THAN JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO THAT'S WHY WE THINK
THE CRITERIA. AS EXPANDED WOULD
ALLOW THE MEN WERE OKAY WITH
THAT THEY'RE NOT QUITE AS
RICHEST THAT THEY'RE DOING A
REALLY GOOD JOB TO EXTREMISTS
WITHOUT THESE PROGRAMS WITHOUT
CERTIFICATION THEY'RE MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THAT IT'S KIND OF THE WILD WEST
OF A WOMAN NINE WELL APPARENT IN
A WOODEN SCHOOL DISTRICT. WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT CHEMICALS AND
THEY JUST TOLD HER THEY'RE ALL
LEGAL LEAVE THE SALON THESE ARE
LEGAL CLEANING PRODUCTS SO YOU
HAVE TO. DISTRICTS WILL KIND OF
FUN THERE KNOWS THAT THESE
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY THE
JANITORIAL STAFF TO GET THE MOST
EXPOSURE I'VE SEEN PERSONALLY
HOW WORKS IN ELK GROVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOWN THE ROAD. THEY
DEMONSTRATED ALSO WERE SAVING
MONEY KILLING BACTERIA ALL GOOD.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO DO SO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
.
ARE YOU MAY CLOSE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST WANT
TO REMIND THAT MORE THAN ONE IN
FIVE CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING SIX
MILLION CHILDREN ARE. UP SPEND
TIME IN SCHOOLS DALY AND.
HAVE EXPOSURE TO THESE PRODUCTS
AND IF THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE
CAN HELP CURB.
SOME OF THAT EXPOSURE OF OR
HELPED MOVE ALONG THE
CONVERSATION ALSO IDEA.
BUT HATE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE TO
HELP DO SO.
THANK YOU I DO HOPE YOU CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE I WANT
TO CONFUSE WHAT THE.
THE DISCONNECT HERE IS BUT I.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL. I'VE O'DONNELL KILEY.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
LIBERALS OUT THANK YOU
.
WHO?
LET HIM GO.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO A MR MCCARTY
WHO HAS TWO BILLS FILE ITEMS
NUMBER TWO AND SEVEN.
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
DID BETWEEN.
THREE BILLS MISS ANY OF THREE
YEAH MICHAEL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
FIRST LIKE TO THANK OUR CHAIR IN
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING
WORK ON THIS BILL THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL. INCOME ELIGIBLE
LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS OF
ACCESS TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT
CALIFORNIA. AS WE KNOW RESEARCH
SHOWS THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS. ARE.
.
EFFECTIVE WHAT'S THE ENTER
KINDERGARTEN HAVE ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AND. HOPEFULLY I HAVE
THEM ON THE. ON A JOURNEY
THROUGH A LIFE AND.
STAY AWAY FROM THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND STAY AWAY
FROM ISSUES SUCH AS POVERTY WE
KNOW THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THIS REALLY MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
I WITH ME TODAY ARE.
WITNESSES FROM FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA AND THE ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT.
MAYBE YOUR WITNESSES BUT.
OF GOOD EVENING UMMC THE JOHN
JOB IT WITH THE BEST PRICE IT
FASTER PODCAST FORTY OUT. HERE
TODAY NOT JUST AS AN ADVOCATE
BUT A MOTHER OF A FOUR YEAR OLD
WHO IS ATTENDING A PRETTY
PROGRAM.
I WON'T BELABOR THE POINT ABOUT
THE RESURGENT BENEFITS OF EARLY
EDUCATION. YOU'VE HEARD THAT
BEFORE AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS DONE A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF LAYING THAT OUT. I WILL
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE AS A
MOTHER. WHO HAD WHO WHOSE SON IS
DRIVING BECAUSE HE'S IN A
QUALITY PRE CARE PROGRAM?
I THINK MY SIDE IS BRILLIANT AND
I MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIASED.
BUT HE'S BRILLIANT AND LEARNING
BECAUSE HE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SO.
AT THE AGE OF FOUR YOU CAN DO
ADDITION SUBTRACTION HE CAN
WRITE A WHOLE SENTENCE HIS
COMPASSIONATE
CRITICALLY THINKS WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE IF HE HAS SAID OR DONE
SOMETHING TO HURT HIS PEERS.
I CAN TEACH HIM THAT HIS
TEACHERS DEBT.
IT'S ATTRACTIONS IN HIS SCHOOL
TAUGHT HIM TO CONTROL HIS SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS.
TO SHARE.
IMAGINE FORTY THREE THOUSAND TO
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND KIDS.
PRIVATELY SUCH OPPORTUNITIES IN
OUR STATE.
PRIVATE OF SUCH KNOWLEDGE.
DEPRIVED OF BECOMING PERHAPS
BRILLIANT.
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL AN
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
WHEN THESE KIDS STEP INTO A
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM.
WE'RE THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH
CHILDREN WHO HAVE HAD THESE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THEN THEIR
KIDS HER LEARNING TO STILL SIT
STILL. PAY ATTENTION PERHAPS
EVEN LEARN TO SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE AS THEIR PEERS AND
TEACHERS.
THIS MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
IS WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY GAP
BECOMES AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AND
IT PROCESS THROUGHOUT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREER.
I'M LUCKY THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE FOR MY CHILD.
AND.
.
PUTTING MY CHILDREN ON INTO A
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING SETTING
BUT MANY PARENTS HAVE TO MAKE
THAT CHOICE.
REALITY IS THAT PARENTS CAN
AFFORD TO DO SO BILL PROPRIETOR
BET PROVIDE THE BEST EDUCATION
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
MANY PARENTS CAN'T DO THAT.
AND THIS IS WHERE THE STATE
NEEDS TO COMMENT. IT IS THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY O MAKE
THINGS EQUITABLE AND MITIGATE
THESE GAPS EARLIER ON.
IT DOESN'T PROJECT IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ANY FULLY SUMMARIZED
YES ALMOST UNHEARD. OF PRE K.
FOR ALL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UNTIL THEN WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
A GOING CONCERN TO YOU. NEXT
BUT.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARGARET
GOULD I'M HERE FROM THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE FIRST LIVES
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING OUR
STATE AGENCY FOR SPIKE
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AS WE ALL
KNOW THERE'S OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE AND.
AND DECADES OF RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS THAT INVESTING IN HIGH
QUALITY PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS CAN
LEAD TO PROMOTING BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT PREVENTING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AND PREVENTING
LONG TERM EFFECTS LIKE POVERTY.
SIMPLY PUT AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR WOULD CODIFY CALIFORNIA'S
PRESCHOOL PROMISE AND ENSURE
THAT ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
REGARDLESS OF THAT ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS WHO ARE INCOME ELIGIBLE
WOULD RECEIVE HIGH QUALITY
SUBSIDIZED CARE.
ENCLOSING ABLE TO SHARE THAT
THERE ARE A FEW BROADER ISSUES
THAT WE KNOW ARMS ARE ARE.
OUR BARRIERS IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVING THE PRESCHOOL PROMISED
THAT PROMISE THAT SIMPLY BAR TOO
FAR TOO MANY CHILDREN FROM
ACCESSING CARE THE TWO CRITICAL
PIECES THAT WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SHARE ONE THE LACK OF FACILITIES
SUPPORT. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY IS
LEADERSHIP AROUND EXPANDING
QUALITY PRESCHOOL AND WE SEE AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR AS THE
CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN ENSURING
THAT ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS DO YOU
HAVE HAVE ACCESS TO THESE HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PATTY HERERO REPRESENTING EARLY
AT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAT DE BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DO YOU COULD WATCH ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN NOW STRONG
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CANADA KAISER WITH
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JEFF BOCK OF REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT.
STENA MARCELLUS REPRESENTING A
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUPPORT.
MEANS THE READ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR THE
GIFTED IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AND
SUPPORT.
RON RAPOPORT HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
I DON'T HAVE A HOUSING DISPLAY
RATES CALIFORNIANS PART.
DINI MICHELETTI COLBERN FOR
ACTUALLY IN A WATCH POSITION AND
WE'RE HOPING TO FLIP TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I REALLY OPPOSITION.
SEE NO OPPOSITION ANY OTHER
COMMENTS REALLY COMMITTEE MEMBER
SEEING ON TO HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED AND SECONDED ALL SECONDED.
.
YOU MAY CLOSE TO MOTIONS TO
PASSED.
DO PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU THIS IS THAT CREE QUE
FOR ALL ACTING CALIFORNIA AND
HOPE THIS IS THE YEAR THAT WE
CAN GET IT PASSED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE STEINORTH. STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
BILLS FOR VOTES IT IS OUT.
WHEN I MOVED TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN TWO ZERO NINE A PILOT.
FILE NUMBER SEVEN.
TWO ZERO AB TWO ZERO NINE.
WHICH WHEN YOU SEND MR JR. BUT
TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT OKAY THANK
YOU. AGAIN LIKE TO THINK THAT
YOU'RE ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL WE
HAVE BEFORE US THE. KIDS CODE
PROGRAM WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
THE ISSUES WAS STEM IN
CALIFORNIA NOT HAVING ENOUGH.
INDIVIDUALS TO TO TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE WORKFORCE.
WE ALSO KNOW NOT ENOUGH LOW
INCOMES AND UNDERREPRESENTED
KIDS ARE PARTICIPATING SO WE
HAVE A CREATIVE IDEA. PILOT
PROJECT AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WITH OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE THERE EVERYDAY
BETWEEN THREE AND SIX.
THIS WILL GIVE THEM AN EXCITING
THING TO DO AND THAT TEACH THEM
ABOUT CODING AND STEM AND. AND
REALLY PROVIDE A WIN WIN FOR
THE.
FOR THE KIDS FOR CALIFORNIA AND
FOR INDUSTRY AS WELL WITH ME IS.
COMPTIA TO PRISON PER TO.
.
PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
GREAT THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMAN WILL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME WITH TERRIBLE
ASH AND THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS THAT COMITIA
WERE FORMERLY KNOWN AS THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. FIRST OFF WE'D LIKE
TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STAFF IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THEIR GUIDANCE AND
EXPERTISE IN THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. WE ARE HERE TODAY AS CO
SPONSORS WITH TECH NET
I AM REPRESENTING THE PRICE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ON AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THAT THREE YEAR AFTER
SCHOOL COATING PROGRAM HAD A
PROGRAM. I'M UNDER THE CURRENT
EXISTING EAST THIS FRAMEWORK AS
INDUSTRY LEADERS WE URGE THE
STATE TO INVESTING EFFORTS TO
EQUALIZE ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE ENCODING COURSES
STARTING WITH THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION AND
TECHNOLOGY JOBS INNOVATION AN
AVERAGE WAGE
ACCORDING TO KANT TIAS TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIVER STATES REPORT.
IT QUANTIFIES THE SIZE AND SCOPE
OF THE TECH INDUSTRY IN THE TOP
WORKFORCE.
ACROSS MULTIPLE VECTORS
EMPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY EXPANDED BY
AN ESTIMATED THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND JOBS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AND CONTRIBUTED MORE
TO THREE HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
ACCORDING TO THE U. S. BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS IT IS PREDICTED
THAT BY YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION JOBS WILL BE
IN COMPUTING OUR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS MORE THAN
ALL OTHER SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY.
ENGINEERING AND MATHEMATICS THE
COMBINED HOWEVER IT THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS GRADUATING WITH A
COMPUTER SCIENCE DEGREE IS
MINUSCULE COMPARED TO THE NUMBER
OF AVAILABLE TECH JOBS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY AS IT RELATES TO
THIS BILL. THERE REMAINS A LARGE
DISPARITY BETWEEN STUDENTS FROM
AFFLUENT SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME SCHOOLS WITH
ACCESS TO QUOTING COURSE THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
COMPUTER CODING GRANT PALETTE
PROGRAM PROVIDES CRITICALLY
NEEDED EXPOSURE AND ACCESS.
THE CODING FOR AFTER SCHOOL
YOUTH WHO ARE LESS LIKELY TO
LEARN.
TO CODE IN SCHOOLS ARE OUT HOME
PLEASE SUMMARIZE.
WE BELIEVE EDUCATION HOLDS THE
KEY TO PREPARING THE NEXT
GENERATION LEARNER TO THRIVE AND
SUCCEED IN THE DIGITAL
MARKETPLACE. AND WITH THOSE.
COMMENTS AND OTHERS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THINK YOU.
.
ANY OPPOSITION
OR OTHER SUPPORT ANY OTHERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES LAURA
BENNETT WITH TECH NET WE OF THE
CO SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE
WOULD COME TO YEAH HE SIMPLY
ASSOCIATE THOSE COMMENTS WITH
OTHER COME TO YEAH WE ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BUT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN STRAIGHT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK WE HAVE
A WATCH POSITION ON THIS BILL.
BUT WE ARE ALSO PART OF THE.
CALIFORNIA OR THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE FOR CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE AND BELIEVE THAT THIS
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO
INCREASING ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION ENCODING THANK
YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SEEN
OPPOSITION THE COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMANDERS YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CAUSE.
JUST ASK THE DRIVER THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO PASS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA. KALRA HIKE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMAN. THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT YEAH THATS AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY.
THANK YOU LAST BILL HERE AND
AGAIN THINK THE US HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE WILL LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTED A
FEW ISSUES THAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON AS WE GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SIMILARLY AT OUR SUCCESSFUL
TODAY THIS WILL CREATE THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IN SCHOOL
CLAIM IT.
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT BLOCK
GRANTS
TO HELP TO HELP MAKE SURE WE
HAVE.
ADEQUATE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
RELATE TO OUR EL CAPS
AND.
BASICALLY.
COMMUNITY DIALOGUE RELATE TO
SCHOOL CONDITIONS AND CLIMATE
THAT WE ALL KNOW THE AFTER FOUR
YEARS OF LCF THAT IT'S A START
BUT THERE'S NOT. AND NOT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT IN THIS
IS WHAT THIS BILL. IS THAT
GUIDED TO DO AYE WITH ME TODAY.
ARE.
.
I CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE AND
THAT MR ROBERT GREEN ELEVENTH
GRADER IT FROM HE WORDS UNIFIED
SCHOOL MOUNT HAYDN HIGH SCHOOL.
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO OF THINK.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON HELP YOU STAY
AWAKE.
AT THEIR MERCY.
I'M HONORED TO SPEAK IN FRONT
OF THIS COMMITTEE. I AM MY NAME
IS ROBERT GREENE I'M A STUDENT
LEADER FROM CALIFORNIA'S FROM
JUSTICE.
NOW I AM GOING TO BE THE FUTURE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THIS IS WHY I AM HERE TO SAY IT
IS TIME FOR THE STATE TO POOR
AYE STUDENTS FAMILY ENGAGEMENT.
AND SCHOOL CRIME IN IN THE SAME
WAY THAT WE INVEST IN OTHER
STATE PRIORITIES.
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ARE
EXPERTS IN OUR EDUCATION AND NO
ONE HAS MORE AT STAKE IN OUR
SCHOOLS THEN.
WE DO.
I NEVER BELIEVED THAT I WOULD
EVER GO TO A COLLEGE BECAUSE
NONE OF MY FAMILY HAVE DONE
BEFORE.
I ASSUMED IT WASN'T FROM ME.
BUT IN MY SOPHOMORE YEAR AND
METAL LEVIN TEACHER MISS
EASTWARD.
SHE WAS SO SUPPORTIVE AND
AMAZING.
SHE CHANGED MY MIND ABOUT
COLLEGE AND GIVE ME RESOURCES
LIKE TUTORING.
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
TEACHERS AND STAFF IS CRITICAL
FOR STUDENT SUCCESS.
SLIGHTLY FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
OF COLOR.
HOWEVER SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS
SHOW THAT ONE OUT OF THREE
STUDENTS CAN IDENTIFY A SINGLE
CARING WIDOWED AT SCHOOL.%
THIS SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA IS WHAT
MY FELLOW STUDENTS AND HAVE
SHARED. WITH MY DISTRICT TO PUSH
THEM TO CHANGE THIS REALITY IN.
AND GUESS WHAT.
THEY ARE LISTENING AND
PARTNERING.
WITH US TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
THEY ARE LISTENING BECAUSE
THROUGH OAKLAND'S EL CAP PARENT
STUDENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BUILD TRUSTING
COLLABORATIVE.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH DISTRICT
STAFF ARE SUPER. AND SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS.
MY STERN SHOW THAT LOCAL CONTROL
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. CAN WORK BUT
LET'S FACE IT.
MOST DISTRICTS ARE NOT THERE
YET.
WE ASKED YOU TO VOTE YES FOR A.
B. TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY. TO
IMPROVE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
SO CLIMB IN.
WE ARE BETTER WHEN WE LEAD TO
GATHER.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I AM VERY.
I'M TERRY ISSUED EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
JUSTICE REPRESENTING A COALITION
OF STUDENT PARENT ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON LTFS AND
THIRTY DISTRICTS.
THEY ARE HELPING TO DEFEND IN
MEL'S AND MEND LTFS AND I'VE
ALSO SERVED ON THE DEPARTMENT
SCHOOL CONDITIONS IN CLIMATE
WORK GROUP WHICH PREPARED THIS
REPORT THAT WE'VE.
SHARED BEHIND ME.
FIRST OFF THANK YOU TO THE AG
COMMITTEE STAFF UP FOR THE
FEEDBACK ON OUR BILL.
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND THE DEPARTMENT
HAVE SHARED AMENDMENTS ON MONDAY
THAT ADDRESS STAFF'S CONCERNS.
WE'RE AT A MAJOR CROSSROADS WITH
ALTHEA BENEFITS A HOOF YOU KNOW
WELL AND WE FIND THE BIGGEST
THREAT.
TO THE SUCCESS OF LC FF THE
BIGGEST THREAT EQUITY IN LC FF
IS ACTUALLY THE LACK OF CAPACITY
FOR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
SCHOOL CLAIMING.
RESEARCH AND OUR EXPERIENCE IN
THIRTY DISTRICT SHOWS THE
REQUIREMENT TO ADDRESS PARENT
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AND SCHOOL
CLIMATE IN LC FF IS A
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT FOR ELOISE.
MOST OF WHICH WERE NOT PREPARED
WITH THE SKILL SETS AND
PRACTICES NECESSARY TO DO THIS
WORK AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
WOULD PROVIDE ONE TIME FUNDING
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY AT ALL
LEVELS OF THE SYSTEM TO IMPROVE
COMMUNICATION AND SCHOOL
CLIMATE.
FUNDING WOULD ACCELERATE AND
SCALE INNOVATIVE MODELS ENSURE
THE STATE EVALUATES AND SHARES
BEST PRACTICES WIDELY AND
STRENGTHENS COUNTIES. THAT THEY
CAN CARRY THIS WORK ON BEYOND
THE STATE INVESTMENT.
THESE TWO THINGS ARE DEEPLY
INTERTWINED AND ARE THE LYNCHPIN
OF AL CFF AS YOU HEARD FROM
ROBERT SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS
COMBINED WITH COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT CAN LEAD TO REALLY
POWERFUL CHAINS.
OUR FRAMEWORK HERE THIS REPORT
SHOWS THAT SCHOOL CLIMATE
SURVEYS ASSESS SAFETY
RELATIONSHIPS CONDITIONS FOR
TEACHING AND LEARNING AND
ENGAGEMENT.
THE STATE HAS PUT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
TO BUILD CAPACITY IN THE SYSTEM
FOR NEW IN MAJOR CHANGES LIKE
COMMON CORE NOW IS THE TIME TO
PUT THAT SAME INVESTMENT INTO
THE NEW AND MAJOR CHANGE AROUND
SCHOOL CRIME AND ENGAGEMENT.
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WILL FOSTER
LET'S TRYING IN COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIPS AT THE HEART OF
LTFS.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
IF YOU OTHERS AND SO.
WHISKEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
ALSO OF REPRESENTING THE ACLU
THANK YOU THANKS.
OTHERS IS SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION.
GET UP TO THE MICROPHONE BECAUSE
I FOURTH YEAH ANY OF US GET SOME
APPARENTLY THERE WERE SACRAMENTO
AKA MULHOLLAND HERE FOR ALL TO
SCHOOLS WHERE MY CHILDREN GOAL.
IN SUPPORT.
DEMOCRAT ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TILLOTSON AND
SUPPORT.
BROWN'S STRONG CHILDREN NOW IN
RON RAPIDLY AFTER CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
WE THINK ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISSED MCCARTY FOR
THE BILL IS THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK HERE THAT PROBABLY SHOULD I
HAPPENED A LONG TIME AGO QUITE
FRANKLY.
.
YOU KNOW I JUST WE WANT TO BE
CAREFUL HERE I WANT TO SHOW THIS
IS A MONEY GRAB A NON PROFITS
QUE.
BECAUSE WE ARE WATCH WHERE PROP
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS GO SO WHO
WATCH THAT AS WE GO THROUGH.
DIFFERENT ITERATIONS OF THE BILL
MOVING FORWARD ON THIS IS ONE OF
MY KEY CONCERNS
AB YOU KNOW THE PROPER. MY GHOST
TO EDUCATE CHILDREN AND THOSE
EFFORTS ASSOCIATED WITH
EDUCATING CHILDREN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS WE HAVE
A MOTION.
AND MOVED ALL SECOND.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS.
TO PASTOR PROGRAM NINE TO READ
THE LIST FOR THERE'S A LONG LIST
HERE OF CHALLENGES WITH THIS
BILL. JUST JUST TO RESPOND
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S ALWAYS A
TOMORROW IN THIS BUSINESS.
AND SO WE WILL TAKE WELL YOU
KNOW HOW HARD IT WAS THE ANSWER
THAT I TO.
AND THERE ARE THE LAST WEEK IN
THE LAST MONTH.
WE WILL GO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ANTI AND UP AS YOU KNOW THIS ONE
GOING TO FACT WITHOUT. ON SOME
TYPE OF THAT BUDGET ACTION SO
WE'LL MAKE SURE THESE ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY AYE AYE
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THANKS IT WAS MISTER THURMAN
WHICH ONE DID YOU PUSH PRESENT
FIRST.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX BY MR
THERMOS FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT.
EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STUFF FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS BILL SO THERE ARE
WITNESSES THERE WHO NEEDS TO.
APART CANDICE'S AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX THIS IS A STAND
GRANT.
BILL.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT STEM
LOTS NIGHT OF THIS IS A BILL
THAT SEEKS TO GET DIRECTLY HOW
WE PREPARE OUR STUDENTS FOR THE
JOBS OF TOMORROW. OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM HAS FALLEN
BEHIND.
WHERE THE PROJECTIONS AND STEM
JOB SAY THAT WE NEED TO GO OUR
STUDENTS NEED MORE COMPUTER
SCIENCE? WE NEED MORE TEACHERS
WHO HAVE HAD PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AROUND STEM RELATED
TOPICS
I AND THEY NEED ACCESS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HARD TO
SERVE. UP LIKE OUR RULE
COMMUNITIES MANY OF WHICH DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO WIFI LISTA TRUCK
PULLS UP IN A HOT SPOT. THIS IS
CALIFORNIA AND WE CAN DO BETTER
FOR OUR KIDS IN THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THE BALL IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AT THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TEACHERS AND STEM AREAS AYE IT
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE.
DOLLARS FOR.
INTO.
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
TO HELP SUPPORT NEW TEACHER
RECRUITMENT OF WITH A
SCHOLARSHIP UP TEACHER
RETENTION.
IN IN THE AREAS OF STEM
ADDITIONAL COMPUTER SCIENCE
RELATED.
SUPPORT A AND AN EMPHASIS ON
RESOURCES FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES.
.
I BROUGHT SOME WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO PROVIDE EMPHASIS
SOME OF WHOM YOU'VE MET EARLIER
TONIGHT AND THEY WILL GIVE BRIEF
EMPHASIS ON HOW THIS CAN HELP WE
HAVE BEEN STEWART EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STEM
NETWORK.
JESSICA SOCK OUT THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THIS IS TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX BY THE WAY TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX WASN'T A NUMBER NOT
ANYONE EIGHTY SIX AND.
YOU TELL ME TO WILL ACCEPT
WHATEVER AMENDMENTS YOU HAS IT.
YEAH.
BUT. I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE I'M
VINCE STUART THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STEM
NETWORK IN THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX.
WERE STATEWIDE NETWORK
AFFILIATED WITH THIRTEEN
REGIONAL NETWORKS AROUND THE
STATE THAT SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AS WELL. I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR FOR
THE AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE IT
IMPROVES THIS A PROPOSAL.
SUBSTANTIALLY.
I THINK THE AUTHOR REALLY WENT
THROUGH WHAT THE BILL DOES.
SO GIVEN THE HOUR I WILL NOT
BELABOR THE POINT IN JUST A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JESSICA SOCCER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION SIMPLY
WANTING TO ADD THAT WITH THE
GAINING MOMENTUM OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS
NOW'S THE TIME TO MAKE THIS
CRITICAL INVESTMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SCIENCE AND STEM EDUCATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROFESSIONALS IN
SUPPORT.
THE INJURY DONE BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT'S PART.
DANIELLE CAN A KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
LARA BENNETT WITH TECHNICIAN
KARRUECHE WITH CANTIERE WERE IN
THE PROCESS OF FORMULATING A
SUPPORT POSITION.
YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
A CONCERT BY ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION.
IT'S MCCARTY MOUSSE MISTER CARR
SECONDS.
I YOU MAY CLOSE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IT'S CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL TIME O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
HOPEFULLY.
LUIS FIVE VOTES IT IS OUR IN OUR
REMOVED A FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT.
PINE RIVER EIGHT IT'S AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY PERCEIVE
IN WRITING. THINKERS CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE SCHOOL'S AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT THAT
SEEKS TO HELP US. WITH THE
RETENTION OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS WE'VE TALKED A GREAT
DEAL ABOUT THE NEED TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION THIS BILL PROVIDES.
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT A MENTOR
TEACHER PROGRAM WHERE.
TEACHERS IN SPECIAL ED WOULD BE
BENT TOWARD.
BY TEACHERS AYE IT WOULD
SUPPORT STIPENDS CURRICULUM.
AND DEVELOPMENT OF OTHER
PROGRAMS.
TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU KNOW THIS IN SUPPORT I'M
SURE.
I. APOLOGIZE OUT WITH ME TONIGHT
IS DEBORAH BROWN OF FOR THE
COMPANY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO PROVIDE DECIMAL.
GOOD EVENING DE AROUND ON BEHALF
OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC CONTRACTING INSTRUCTION
TOP PRODUCTS AND IT IS NOT THAT
THIS BILL DOES. SEEK TO PROVIDE
SOME SUPPORT FOR TEACHERS HAVE
MADE THE COMMITMENT TO HELP OUR
HIGHEST NEED STUDENTS AND SO WE
THINK THAT HAVING. MENTORSHIP
PROGRAMS WILL REALLY PROVIDE US
ON SOME SPORTS WE CAN'T KEEP
THOSE TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM
ENERGY OF YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WHISKEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
AB EVENLY INJURY DOWN BIAFRA
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT.
DANIEL CANDOR KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
HE LOOKED.
HAVE ANA HASN'T DISPLAY RIGHT
CALIFORNIANS PARK WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS WORKING WITH
THE OTHERS UP STICK IN
ADDRESSING THINK YOU.
.
NO THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS UNSEEN
COMMENTS READY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS.
WOULD IT.
SO YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU TO
PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. O'DONNELL
AYE.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE KILEY
AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMOND AYE THURMOND AYE
WEBER.
WEBER I.
BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T MIND RIGHT.
SO WITH.
LET'S GO AHEAD NOT TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR BY MR
MCCARTY FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEMI MISTER
INDIA. THAILAND NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY NINE BY MISTER
GARCIA.
FOLLOW OVER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY ONE BY MISTER CHIU
FILE ITEM OR SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY NINE AIRSTREAM PUT.
IS THAT OKAY THESE ARE NOT THE
GAZETTE. THANK.
WELL ONLY THREE OKAY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE.
MISTER HOLTON DO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO AB
THREE ZERO FIVE EIGHT O'DONNELL
TO PASS TO APPROACH IT
APPROPRIATIONS IS THE MOTION.
FILING OR THIRTY SEVEN AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY THREE BY MR CARL THE
MOTION AS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THAT. REMOVED AND SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL BY
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE KILEY
AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMAN THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
OKAY SO STRICT WITH SICKLE BUT
VIOLENT FILE A MOTION ON FILE
ITEM WITH THAT SO GOOD YOUR FILE
ITEM.
ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
WEARS A CAVE BY MR MEDINA DO WE
HAVE A MOTION.
PHONE NUMBER TO THE MOTION.
ARE WE DO NOT HAVE A MOTION SO
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FAILS.
MOVED TO. WHERE WE GO NEXT?
GO TO THE BILL'S ON CALL FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
PHONE NUMBER THREE I'M SORRY
FILE ON NUMBER THREE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE BY MISTER
CHIU.
IS CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY AYE COAT KILEY NO AND
KALRA.
I AM KALRA AYE.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH BY.
SEVENTEEN SEVERELY THREE.
SO IT'S OUT IT HAS.
THROUGH THE FILE AND RIVER FOR.
FIVE FUND RIFAI FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. A. B. TWO THOUSAND TWO BY
MISTER RAMMELL THIS AB TWO
THOUSAND TWO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN.
IN COLOGNE AND WITH IT IS WHO'S
THAT.
I AM FOURTEEN IT'S O'DONNELL.
THREE FILE ITEM FORTY TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT O'DONNELL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
THIS BILL IS OUT WITH SIX VOTES.
IF I AND NUMBER TWENTY TWO
THAT'S A BY DOCTOR WHETHER
THAT'S A. B. TWENTY THREE FIFTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
SEVEN.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN
STARSCREAM TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN.
MY DOCTOR WEBER.
IS CALL THE ROLL.
AND KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING.
IT HAS FOR BOTH THE BILL'S EYES
FOR VOTE.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE THIRTY
THREE BY MR MCCARTY.
I KNOW I IS HAVING THIS
RECORDING.
I CAN'T WORST THIRTY THREE.
AND NOW WE ARE PARA OF I MISS
RUBIO FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
IT'S A. B..
I BELIEVE THREE ZERO NINE SIX.
THREE ZERO NINE SIX.
I WAS RUBIO.
AND KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
SINCE.
WE'VE DUG UP IN JUST
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED